Was machen wir eigentlich zu unserer 100. Sendung?
So liebe Lange, jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen zur Ruhe kommen und einer nach dem anderen. Tim, dein Blutdruckmesser zeigt hier auf meinem Bildschirm an. Nein, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Leute, seid doch nicht alle so zart, beseit wir streiten uns doch überhaupt nicht.
Beides ist richtig. Könnt ihr euch einfach damit abfinden?
Moment, Moment, also wir müssen hier schon das Protokoll, der Max war schon als Erster dran. Du musst dich mal ganz kurz gedulden bitte.
Also ich, genau und schreib ihm bitte dann auch noch einen Brief, in dem du dich entschuldigst und mach ihm ein Bild.
Guck mal, da ist es weg.
Guck mal, sagt man nicht im Audio-Podcast. So ist es mit der Programmfindung. Es ist nicht einfach.
Wir müssen mal mehr über Bier reden.
Über Bier?
Zwar ja der Artikel heute auf Spiegel, aber ohne den Burg.
Ja, stimmt.
Ganz schön lame. Die Spiegeljungs.
Naja, könnt ja auch sagen, der Burg ist zu spät.
Der ging über Berliner Brauereien und dann lassen sie den Burg weg, der die Berliner Weißer reanimiert. Was ist denn das? Ist ja mal schlecht recherchiert, oder?
Sie haben sich halt nur um ein Bier gekümmert.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war über drei, glaub ich.
Aber die Fotoserie war nur bei Rollberger dann.
Nee, da war noch der andere.
Die haben sich halt auf die konzentriert, die eben auch schon liefern, stehste? Nicht irgendwie Ankündigung und Pressemitteilung und Pipapo.
Aber trotzdem hätte man noch so mit reinschütten können, noch ein bisschen Vapor-Bier.
Vapor-Bier, genau. Das wird nicht unterstützt von dem aktuellen Nachrichtmagazin.
So, aber wir haben wichtige Themen, ne? Neue Telefone, neue OS und T-Note, alles wie geliegt, aber...
Und wir trinken Bayreuther Hell hier, eigentlich gemeinschaftlich außer Dennis, der sich dem noch verweigert. Aber Bayreuther Hell aus dem Bayreuther Brauhaus, auch ein wirklich sehr schönes Bier. Wir werden jetzt hier in der Meta-Ebene auch in Mannschaftsstärke quasi im Kühlschrank vertreten.
Ja, im Gegensatz zu unserem Team, die Mannschaft ist nicht komplett. Wir haben einen Verletzten. Roddi bleibt heute auf der Bank. Und mal gucken, also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass er während der Sendung es schafft, noch sich zu rekultivieren, sonst hätten wir ihn ja noch einwechseln können.
Aber die Länderspielpause, die kann natürlich jetzt dazu genutzt werden, um dann zu alter Stärke zu finden, damit er dann bei der nächsten Sendung wieder in vollem Saft wieder mit einsteigt.
Ist schon wieder Länderspielpause? Wie war es jetzt?
Nächste Woche oder was? Diese Woche? Heute? Diese Woche ist keine Bundesliga.
Tja, hat doch gerade erst angefangen. Na ja, wie auch immer, wir spielen ja in einer anderen Liga. Denn wir sind MOBA Max und das hier ist die 95. Ausgabe. Die sich jetzt an euch heranpirscht, vielmehr an euer Gehör. Ja, nachdem wir kleine, minimale, eigentlich nicht weiter ins Gewicht fallende Stream-Aufsetzprobleme hatten. Aber das interessiert euch ja eh nicht. Ihr hört das ja jetzt gerade im Wald beim Joggen oder bei irgendeiner frivolen Aktivität. Man weiß es ja nicht. Man weiß ja nicht, was die Leute jetzt machen, während wir das sagen.
Kann sich jemand mal melden, der eventuell schon mal im Overmax beim Sex gehört hat?
Jetzt sprichst du es einfach so aus.
Allein oder zu zweit?
Mindestens zwei. Genau, mindestens zwei. So viele Rückmeldungen wollen wir dann doch nicht haben.
Ja, also ich meine, dein Stachelbärkuchen-Experiment war ja dann doch auch sehr erfolgreich. Man hat immer auch gesehen, was das für eine Latenz haben kann.
Genau, also ich kriege tagtäglich immer noch vereinzelte Stachelbärkuchen. Also heute waren es tatsächlich dann nur noch ein oder zwei. Aber so wirklich jeden Tag kommt immer mal so ein Stachelbärkuchen vorbei. Außer hier im Studio leider.
Ja, ist irgendwas passiert?
Wie gesagt, neues Telefon, neues OS.
Neues Telefon, neues OS?
Das du meinst, das Lumina, das ist etwas ansonsten. Was mehr Retina ist als das iPhone 4S.
Das war heute, ich hab das nicht so ganz mitgeschnitten. Ich war im Zug.
Ich hab nur Fotos gesehen.
Das ist das neue.
Ich hab mir nichts dazu durchgelesen, kein Wort bisher.
Nichts.
Außer dass es irgendwie eine neue Kamera hätte, die nicht so schlecht wäre.
Es ist gelb.
Es ist eine von vielen Optionen.
Ja, ansonsten ist es doch immer noch die gleichen Quadrate da drauf.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt Windows 8.
Jetzt ist das Telefon da, das stand bei Heiser stand.
Jetzt ist das Telefon, also jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt zu wechseln. Also die, die vorher so ein altes Lumia gekauft haben, ihr habt die Arschkarte gezogen, das war nicht der Zeitpunkt zum Wechseln. Und eure Telefone werden nicht upgradbar sein auf Windows 8. Ihr seid hier mit außen vor.
Volles Vertrauen in die Plattform. Geht man nicht davon aus, dass Windows 8.1 für euch ist? Ja, 8.1 bestimmt noch. Dieser Update-Fail nimmt auch kein Ende. Also ich meine, da hat sich ja jetzt nicht wirklich nennenswert irgendwas getan, oder?
Ich glaube, bei Windows ging das noch so halbwegs.
Also da konntest du relativ, also wenn es eins gab, konntest du das auch relativ schnell aktivieren. Aber jetzt haben sie halt die ganzen alten Telefone einmal komplett rausgekriegt.
Da erinnerst du dich aber schlecht. Das erste Update, was sie rausgebracht haben, hat ja diverse Geräte erstmal total geprägt.
Ja, aber alle.
Und dann mussten sie erstmal ein Update rausbringen, was die Updates ermöglicht.
Ich weiß noch, wenn sie dann ein Update gemacht haben.
Du meinst, wenn es schon nicht funktioniert, dann sollte es auch so demokratisch organisiert werden, dass dann auch alle nicht mehr funktionieren.
Nicht hier so wie bei Android.
Mein Telefon funktioniert nicht. Wieso funktioniert deins nicht? Ich glaube auch, dass mein Telefon nicht funktioniert.
Ja, eine, wie sagt man, konsistente Experience.
Ich bleibe skeptisch. Na ja, also wie erwähnt, Roddi ist nicht da, aber der Rest ist da, Dennis, Max, Hucke, Icke. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, was wir da so aus dieser Nachrichtenlage so machen können. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es zu diesem LUNIA irgendwas zu sagen?
Wir haben uns alle nicht angeguckt.
Ja, es kam ja heute erst, keine Ahnung.
Die drängeln sich jetzt alle irgendwie, um schnell noch vor Apple irgendwie noch Nachrichten zu bekommen, nachdem dann voraussichtlich ja dann in den nächsten vier Wochen keine Pressemitteilung mehr gelesen wird von irgendeinem anderen Unternehmen.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Die versuchen jetzt noch irgendwie, da Exposure zu kriegen, weil...
Samsung war schon, ne? Samsung hatte schon.
Man weiß es ja immer nicht.
Amazon kommt noch.
Samsung hat jetzt versucht auf dieser IFA, dieses Gerät mit dem Stift...
Das hatte ich auch kurz in der Hand.
Und?
Es ist... Ich habe einen Review gelesen, bei Android Police hieß der, heißt das Block, ist ein Android-Fanboy-Block. Und es ist ein kompletter Verriss. Es macht echt Spaß, das Ding zu lesen.
Mit diesem Video mit dem knarzenden Plastik und so?
Genau. Also du drückst an der Rückseite so ein bisschen ein, es gibt einfach nach, als ob das irgendwie eine etwas dickere Folie wäre, sage ich mal. Also es ist wirklich... Und ich hatte das jetzt an der Hand und es drückt... Also man sieht es nicht so stark, aber es drückt sich genauso durch. Es hat nicht geknarrt beim Hochheben. Also er schreibt in seinem Review auch, dass wenn man es mit einer Hand vom Tisch nimmt, dass es dann einfach knarzt, weil es in sich so instabil ist.
Im Chat gibt es auch schon Fanballs.
Und der Stift wiegt... Also es ist so, als ob man so ein Demostift hätte. Also der hat kein Gewicht. Also der ist nicht irgendwie mit innen, mit Alu- oder Altpapier gefüllt, sondern das ist einfach offensichtlich so ein hohles Rohr halt. Ein Mantarohr.
Tja, was soll man sagen? Also ich meine, jetzt wird uns natürlich sofort wieder vorgewerfen, wir würden das ja zu Recht total ignorieren und bashen, ohne es jemals wirklich getestet zu haben und so. Aber dieses Review war ja gerade zu vernichten. Ich habe das auch so gelesen ein bisschen und dachte mir nur so, hm...
Also ich habe ja jetzt auch ein Android-Device, darum lese ich jetzt auch Android-Blocks. Das hatte ich schon hier.
Das Mini-Tal.
Genau. Und wenn wir ein bisschen auf dem Laufenden bleiben, was es da so gibt, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass die echt, also die hypen auch schon mal irgendwie was ein bisschen über den grünen Klee. Nein, wirklich? Ja, aber wenn irgendwas Schrott ist, dann nennen sie es auch Schrott, habe ich das Gefühl. Und das Ding haben sie sehr laut Schrott genannt. Also das war wirklich beeindruckend. Und ja, davon haben sie jetzt auch eine Telefonvariante gebaut. Also Samsung ist ganz weit vorne.
Was für ein Note?
Ja, das Note ist ja schon immer ein Telefon eigentlich. Das Tablet ist ja nur zum Telefon dazu gekommen.
Ach so, Entschuldigung, ich habe das jetzt wieder verwechselt. Ach so, dieses Nexus 7 gibt es als Telefon?
Nee, das Note gab es schon vorher als Samsung, Blablabla, Galaxy Note. Genau, das gab es schon vorher. Und dann haben sie das Galaxy Note 10.1 vorgestellt. Das ist dann das Tablet.
Die machen aber auch schnelle Versionssprünge.
Samsung Galaxy Note 2, das ist nicht etwa die Zweitfolge-Variante, wie man sich jetzt vorstellen sollte bei 10.1, sondern es ist die...
Zwei-Zoll-Variante.
Es ist die Nachfolge-Variante vom Note ohne Zahl hintendran.
Und das ist dann irgendwie so 6-Zoll oder ich hab keine Ahnung.
So mal eine konsistente Botschaft damit zu kommunizieren mit diesem Produktnamen, auf die Idee kommt da auch keiner.
Ich hab ja irgendwie die Theorie gehört, dass das neue iPad darum neues iPad und nicht iPad 3 heißt, damit, wenn es neben einem iPad Mini im Regal liegt, damit nicht das eine hinten eine Nummer dran hat und das andere nicht. Also, dass sie sich damals das eventuell schon überlegt haben könnten so.
iPad 1 Mini.
Also iPad, iPad und iPad Mini oder sowas. Dass du zwei Geräte hast und nicht so irgendwie durcheinander kommst, wie was ist jetzt das Neure, sondern sind einfach beides die aktuellen Geräte. Klingt für mich total plausibel.
Wenn das Mini nach dem Neu rauskommt, und das Neu ist ja nun schon draußen und die Leute denken sich, das Mini ist ja das, was neu rausgekommen ist.
Dann fällt einfach das neue iPad.
Und dann steht da iPad Mini und iPad Neu.
Nee, da steht ja nur iPad auf der Packung, da steht ja nur iPad drauf.
Das ist absurd, ne? Mittlerweile kann man eigentlich über nichts anderes mehr rätseln, als über wie die Dinger dann heißen, weil alle anderen Fakten liegen ja irgendwie schon nackt auf dem Tisch.
Eigentlich ist es schon ganz cool, dass Apple die OS-Version Lion und Mountain Lion und so nennt. Oder da hat man Begriff, weiß man genau Bescheid, alle wissen Bescheid und die Zahlen und so, da verwechselt man ja öfter mal was. Aber so mit den Namen ist da eigentlich ziemlich klar. Und Mini neu, 3, 5, 7...
Nexus, Galaxy, Ultimate Edition, 64 Zoll.
Also ich leide jetzt auch nicht darunter, dass das iPhone, erst iPhone 4, dann iPhone 4S.
Nee, iPhone 45 hat es ziemlich sicher heißen, oder?
Das ist nicht klar.
Also es gab, es gab, es gab, ja, hab ich heute in meinem Prismatic gesehen, hab ich in meinem Prismatic Feed gesehen, aus einer chinesischen Verpackungsfabrik, ja, da hält eine chinesische Werkarbeitung, also so ein Bogen-iPod-iPhone-Verpackung raus und da steht New iPhone.
Ja, aber es ist ein Fake.
Ach Mensch, jetzt ist es ein Fake. Woher willst du denn das wissen?
Weil es YouTube auf der Verpackung ganz deutlich... Also es hat, es hat, es hat, Timo Hetzel hat das getwittert, direkt so hinterher so, fake, da ist ja YouTube auf der Verpackung. Dann hat jemand rangezoomt, hat da gesehen, dass da ein YouTube-Icon auch drauf ist und kein Passbook.
Tja, so schnell zerfallen, zerfallen die Mythen.
Sind wir jetzt schon drin im, im extremen Glaskugling? Ja, ich glaube, wir sind drin.
Das war doch die galanteste Überleitung ever, die wir hier bisher so gebracht haben.
Naja, dann müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen...
Ich würde sagen, du kannst jetzt mal den Stream starten und dann legen wir jetzt mal richtig los.
Na gut, bleiben wir dabei. Also es gibt diese Einladung jetzt für nächste Woche, was auch keine große Überraschung war, weil auch dieser Termin ist ja vorher schon weitgehend geliegt. Das heißt, die erste ist das 5. September und Release am 12. oder war das nicht sowas? Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist es jetzt klar, dass es diesen Termin gibt.
Aber es ist schon komisch, dass sie diesen Termin schon irgendwie vor, keine Ahnung, wann, 4, 6 Wochen oder so wussten alle?
Ich sag ja, es gibt keine Mysterien bei Apple mehr.
Das ist einfach mysterienfrei jetzt.
Das ist wirklich mysterienfrei.
Und ich finde das nicht gut.
Ich hab auch vorhin schon zu Tim gesagt, als das iPhone rauskam, da saßen wir vor dem Bildschirm und die Sonne zeigte sich und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt, weißt du, so sitzt du da, ja komm hier, sag Retina, komm.
Jetzt mach schon.
Sag fünf Icons. Sag neuer Doc Connect. Ach wirklich, es gibt einen Adapter für 25 Dollar. So, so, so.
Und das ist mal auch schon wieder alles. Größe hat irgendwie, kleinere SIM-Karte hat irgendwie.
Noch kleiner?
Hast du nicht mitgekriegt?
Bist du überrascht?
Ja, Scheiße, hätte das mal nicht verraten.
Ich meine, sie haben halt noch etwas Plastik weggeschnippelt.
Okay, das ist jetzt nur noch der Chip.
Das ist jetzt im Wesentlichen nur noch der Chip mit so einem dünnen iPad-Rand drumrum und das war's.
Ich hab jetzt so einen, hab bei Kongstar schon angefragt wegen der neuen SIM-Karte. Und die haben gesagt, wir wissen noch nicht genau, wie das mit den Dingern abläuft, aber sagen wir Bescheid.
Ja, schnibbelt man halt ein bisschen wieder.
Ja, muss man wieder wegstanzen.
Ach, man muss Schleifpapier aus dem Baumarkt holen.
Da muss man auch noch ein bisschen Schleifpapier holen.
Dünner ist es auch.
Langsam wird man da so zu so einem Heimwerker umfragt. Und der nächste Mal machst du noch ein Loch rein, mit dem man eine Format-Schule braucht.
Das war in der Zeit ein Heimwerker-Set.
Das war in der Zeit Schleifpapier, in Skypell. Und dann bist du ready to go for the next generation.
Ich meine jetzt mit dem kleinen iPad und so legt ja Apple wahrscheinlich eh Schleifpapier bei.
Wieso das?
Na hat doch Steve Jobs gesagt, dass wenn du so ein 7 Zoll Tablet machst, dann müssten die Finger ja so klein werden. Dann muss man auch noch Schleifpapier dabei legen, damit man dann die Finger klein fallen kann.
Was hat Steve gesagt?
Das hat Steve gesagt.
Ist nicht alles schlechter geworden.
Die dürfen jetzt auch 7 Zoll-Ipads produzieren.
Die bauen jetzt die ganzen Sachen, wo Steve immer am Schluss noch gesagt hat, ne, jetzt wollen sie das wissen.
Jetzt wollen wir auch wissen, ob es funktioniert.
Ich frag mich, ob bei iOS 6 wieder mal die Umlaut-Tastatur dabei ist. Die war schon bei iOS 5 dabei. Also bei der iOS 5 Beta war eine Umlaut-Tastatur, eine deutsche Tastatur mit Umlauten drauf.
Fand ich total super.
Wo noch S und so weiter separat wie auf einer deutschen Tastatur.
Exakt so. Irgendwann ist das dann mit einer Beta rausgeflogen. Ich hab mich total dran gewöhnt, das ist geil mit Umlauten und endlich mal vernünftig tippen. Auf dem iPhone ist das ja wirklich ätzend. Und mit der iOS 6 Beta ist dann plötzlich die Umlaut-Tastatur wieder da. Und auch mal, dass sie diesmal auch drin bleibt. Wahrscheinlich hat Steve letztes Mal gesagt, deutsche Umlaute braucht keiner, raus!
Wie Umlaut-Tastatur.
So wie auf deinem Notebook da.
Die gab's mal.
Die gab's mal, iOS 5 in der Beta.
Denn es ist noch ein bisschen, hat noch ein bisschen Lag. Na, am besten.
Ulti-checken.
Tja, also Umlaut-Tastatur, dünnere, kleinere SIM.
Längeres Display.
Längeres Display. Neuer Dock-Kollektor.
Wir sind uns einig, dass das kommt, oder? Es gibt ja Leute, die stöhnen darüber. Über dieses längere Display. Das Long-Phone. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum eigentlich. Ich finde das macht total Sinn.
Da ist doch jetzt bei jedem iPhone, was nicht das Original-iPhone war, da gibt's doch immer Leute, die dann, ah, ah, ah, und dann finden es doch alle geil. Wie finden wir das? Ich finde das okay. Also ich habe jetzt von vorne rein kein Problem, damit sagen wir mal. Also warum auch? Also gut, ich brauche ein neues Täschchen für mein Telefon, das ist das Problem.
Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall das neue iPhone schon holen, schon allein, weil ich dann in meinen Unterwegsordner und in meinen Praktischordner endlich wieder ein paar mehr Ecken reinpassen.
Hilfreich heißt der.
Wie viele passen da maximal rein?
Das sind zwölf.
Und dann passen da hoffentlich endlich 16 rein. Und dann habe ich hier nämlich, weil aus dem Unterwegsordner muss ich ständig schon was rausschmeißen.
Da sind die 600 Euro doch gut investiert. Ich kann viel mehr Ecken in deinen Ordner reintun.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, die eigentliche Frage ist halt, was ist so die USP? Also was ist es jetzt eigentlich mit dem sie uns ködern wollen? Weil ich meine Siri pfff.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich meine mal ehrlich, wer von euch hat ein 4S? Und wie häufig benutzt du Siri pro Tag?
Gar nicht.
Ich hab kein 4S.
Mich hat das überhaupt nicht gereizt so. Und dich auch nicht, Dennis.
Ich hab zwei Kumpels gesehen, dass sie es halt nicht nutzen.
Ja, ich will auch nicht mit meinem Computer reden.
Doch, ich schon.
Da anschreien will ich den aber nicht.
Ich will auch mit dem reden, aber du, das ist ja... Du redest ja nicht wirklich mit dem. Du gibst da sozusagen Anweisungen, der versucht dich zu verstehen. Also reden ist schon noch ein bisschen was anderes. Ich will irgendwann mal richtig so mit dem interaktiv... Ja, mach mal Folgendes klar. Und der so, ja, so geht es nicht. Was willst du denn genau? Und dann sag ich ja, ich will dit, dit und dit. Und dann sagt er, alles klar, ich verstande, ich kümmere mich drauf.
Na, das wird auch der Weg irgendwie. Sie schmeißen Siri raus und ersetzen sie durch Denise.
Kost aber.
Ja, so. Kannst du von Deutsch jetzt auch auf Berlinerisch umstellen?
Nein, ich meine, das war jetzt ein bisschen... Man kann halt auch ein Moodsetting machen, aber wo halt wirklich auch sozusagen...
Ja, halt so ein Moodsetting, so rotzig.
Nee, aber wenn halt was nicht verstanden wird, wo halt zurückgefragt wird. Also irgendwas, was wesentlich intelligenter ist als das jetzt.
Also ich hätte gerne so was eigentlich wie in vielen Fällen, wie in Star Trek, wo du dem Computer sagst, ich hätte gerne einen Earl Grey mit einer Spur Zitrone, bitte.
Eine Nutri-Matic hättest du gerne.
Ja, oder halt irgendwie...
Weil du weißt auch, was dann passiert. Wenn man die Nutri-Matic mit Informationen befüllt.
Ja, aber Star Trek, also wir lassen jetzt mal kurz die Hitchhiker-Guide-Episode weg und machen halt nur...
Was war denn gleich die Nutri-Matic?
Die Nutri-Matic ist auch das Gerät, was dir im Prinzip jedes Beliebige...
Achso, das war das, was dir den gesamten Prozessor nahmgelegt hat von der Herz auf Gold?
Na, Arsa Dent hätte halt gerne Tee. Und er hat gesagt, ich hätte gerne Tee und dann kam bei uns der Plörre raus, und dann hat er sich hingesetzt und der Maschine einfach alles über Tee erzählt. Über irgendwie indische Teeplantagen und irgendwie Zubereitung und wie das Blatt gebrochen werden muss und den Fermentierungsprozess und all das. Und die Maschine hat sich dann irgendwie hingesetzt. Darüber muss ich nachdenken.
Gibt es schon CAE über Tee?
Nein. Und dann hat sie sich die Hilfe vom Bordcomputer geholt, der daraufhin so viele CPU-Ressourcen belegt hat, dass leider den Angriff, der gerade stattgefunden hat, nicht abwerten konnte.
Wo wir gerade bei Star Trek sind, es gibt keine Star Trek-Episode, wo mal die Enterprise bei Warp 8 einen Kernelpanic hat auf dem Main-Screen, oder? Also wo wir schon bei Computer aus Star Trek sind. Eigentlich, das wär auch nochmal so ein Feature für die Zukunft. Das passiert einfach nicht, ne?
Bei denen geht immer gleich alles aus.
Stimmt, bei denen ist einfach immer Strom weg.
Ja, aber das kannst du nicht machen. Mach ich auf Mach 8 so, dann klebst du ja als Matschfahne an der Scheibe. Irgendwas geht da schon immer noch.
Ist man da nicht in irgendeinem Zwischenuniversum drinne? Bei Mach 8?
Gut, also iPhone 5, Siri. Ich hätte gerne schon mehr Star Trek-Feeling. Du sagst halt ein Problem, wie ist jetzt irgendwie die Flugbahn von meinem Pfeil, wenn ich ihn abschieße. Dann sagt er, er muss erst mal präzisieren. Dann fängst du halt so ein bisschen an, mit ihm zu reden und zu reasoning mit dem Computer. Und nicht einfach nur Set Alarm to five o'clock. Oder What's the Weather?
Man hat auch immer das Gefühl, man unterhält sich wirklich mit so einem...
Es ist ja schon besser als früher auf dem Kongress, so 18C3, Haus am Kölnischen Park, saß mal da und dann gab es hier US 10 und dieses Textes... Open my mail! Open my browser! Und dann hat es halt irgendwie 23 Versuche gebraucht, bis er das dann mal gerallt hat, weil wir dann in unserem feinsten Sauerkraut-Englisch irgendwie versucht haben, da mit dem zu kommunizieren. Von daher hat es schon einen großen Schritt gemacht, aber es ist halt noch lange nicht da, wo es sein soll. Und dieses Dictation-Feature habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal ausprobiert, aber es ist halt auch... Es ist einfach zu viel Hessel immer noch involviert. Braucht man nicht. Immer noch nicht.
So, die nächsten Jahre nichts. Bevor es nicht mit der künstlichen Intelligenz mal ein bisschen vorwärts geht, wird auch nichts passieren.
Dictation habe ich ja jetzt auch, ne?
Zwei Mal Function Key. Fünfin. Aber musst du ja erst anschalten in den System Preferences.
Stimmt, kann ich auch mal wieder ausschalten.
Transmittierst du jetzt die ganze Zeit quasi deinen Content zu Apple?
Ne, ich meinte, den Shortcut kann ich wieder abschalten. Könnte man eigentlich mal... Aber lass das doch mal hier in dein Mikrofon reinlaufen und dann die ganze Zeit unsere Sendung transkribieren. Dann packen wir das in den Sender, dann machen wir keine Schulden aus.
Dann stürzt dein Notebook ab nach irgendwie 600 GB.
Also ich hab's mir gekauft, aber ich hab leider noch keine Zeit gehabt, das irgendwie mal nennenswert in Betrieb zu nehmen. Ich hab mir mal dieses Dragon Dictate geschoppt.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist so eigentlich die...
Ist das nicht heute erst rausgekommen?
Dragon Dictate gibt's seit Jahren.
Dragon Dictate 3 ist dann heute rausgekommen?
Die Sendung wird für eine halbe Stunde erbrochen.
Da muss man updaten. Also wenn jetzt der Stream abbricht, dann wisst ihr wieso.
Das ist der Dragon Dictate 3 Download.
Ich guck erstmal, welche Version ich hab.
Ich hab 252.
Echt? Kommt einfach eine neue Software raus hier?
So Timmy, was ist denn jetzt hier weiter? Gibt es sonst noch, wo waren wir?
Wir sind immer noch beim iPhone.
Der Unique Selling Point.
Naja, also ich meine, vielleicht können wir nochmal zu den offensichtlichen Änderungen gehen, wenn wir mal um dieses Gerät herumgehen. Also die SIM-Karte nimmt weniger Platz ein, das ist klar, einen Ausschalter wird es nach wie vor haben. Dass der Headphone Jack unten ist. Wenn er denn unten ist.
Der ist unten.
Das Gehäuse ist es.
Ich bin mir da auch ziemlich sicher, aber wir müssen trotzdem noch so einen Disclaimer machen, weil wenn wir das jetzt einfach so nehmen und es ist doch anders, dann stehen wir doof da. Deswegen sagt man so, wenn.
Aber wir stehen doch auch doof da, wenn wir das in zwei Wochen sagen und es ist dann trotzdem nicht. Also ich meine, ob das...
Dann waren wir wenigstens überrascht.
Also beim FSDKlog gibt es ein Video, wie einer seins einschaltet.
Wie einer sein was einschaltet?
Dein iPhone 5. Also es bootet und er kann es dann nicht aktivieren.
Das soll ich ja gar nicht vorbereiten.
Diese Edel-Blogs, die kriegen auch immer so frühen Zugriff auf alles.
Von diesem vietnamesischen Blogger hatte er das wieder, der auch die neuen Kopfhörer schon hatte.
Hat der jetzt wieder mehr Zeit, der FSDK-Blogger?
Schon cooler, wenn der Anschluss unten ist, oder? Weil wenn auch hier so ein Spiralkabel dran ist, wenn das so nach unten fällt, anstatt erst nach oben und dann eine Bingo macht und dann das Kabel doch nach unten fällt, wär ja schon cooler, wenn es gleich unten rein steckt.
Ich find das, keine Ahnung.
Weil du so eine Hand hältst und oben immer noch dieses Ding ist, was dann doch aber nach unten hängt, ist doch blöd. Also bei den mini-weißen Kopfhörern ist das natürlich egal, die sind so dünn, aber wenn du da so ein dickes Ding irgendwie reinsteckst?
Also ich halte mein Telefon, wenn ich Kopfhörer drin hab, relativ selten in der Hand. Meistens hab ich das dann nur zum Podcasten, steck ich das Telefon auch in die Tasche.
Na, wenn du doch aber im Bett hast, dein Telefon, und du hast noch so dicke Sennheisers irgendwie auf dem Ohr.
Also wenn die zu dick sind, dann fallen die ja raus.
Weißt du, was das Problem eigentlich ist? Bestimmt. Also wenn du das Telefon so rum drin hast, in so eine Tasche reinsteckst, und du hast oben halt den Kopfhörer ausgehangen, weil unten an der Tasche das seltenen, also es gibt natürlich Taschen, aber bei meiner ist unten kein Loch für ein Headphone-Jack, dann ist das Problem, dass jetzt das Telefon klingelt, höre ich das nicht, weil die Speaker da unten in der Tasche sind.
Ach, und das Problem hast du dann plötzlich nicht mehr.
Und dann, wenn ich es umdrehe, dann sind die Speaker draußen, aber wenn die Kopfhörer drin sind, dann klingelt es eh nur über die Hörer, und nicht über die Lautsprecher.
Ja, man gewöhnt sich dann vielleicht...
Damn, scheiße, meine These ist...
Aber wenn du dann den Kopfhörer mittendrin rausziehst, weil du plötzlich aufgehört hast zu hören, dann...
Dann steckt es gleich richtig rum, genau, super.
Hokele hat sie da rausgefunden.
Also ich finde das unten total sinnvoll. Also Kabel unten macht einfach mal total Sinn.
Ist ja bei Menschen auch so.
Aber beim iPod Touch haben sie es ja auch schon seit Jahren jetzt so. Und die Erfahrungen, die sie ausreichend gewonnen haben, dass das auch sinnvoll ist. Und mich stört es extrem, dass das Kabel nach oben rausgeht, weil man hält es halt eigentlich immer in der Hand. Und das Kabel, was zu mir gehen soll, geht erst mal nach vorne. Das ist doch vollkommen gaga.
Wie gesagt, wenn du so ein dickes, schweres Spiralkabel reinsteckst, von so einem dickeren Kopfhörer, dann ist es auch nach oben eigentlich blöd, weil es ja dann eh wieder nach unten hängt. Also kann man es auch gleich unten hängen.
Wir können ja mal gucken, wo bei dem Nokia Lumia 920 an der Seite der Kopf kommt.
Und oben oder unten?
Tja, aber was jetzt das Tolle sein soll?
Oben in der Mitte.
An dem neuen iPhone weiß ich nicht. Was ist oben in der Mitte?
Schneller, mehr RAM.
Was da ist der Kopfhörer dran?
Was das Display ist, glaube ich.
Was ist beim Lumia oben in der Mitte?
Die sind ja so hinterher.
Du findest das größere Display nicht so spannend?
Doch!
Die Folder-Icons passt mehr rein.
Nee, ich find's einfach nur größeres Display, so quasi 4 zu 3 größer, hätte ich doof gefunden. Ich bin gespannt, wie das alles lösen mit Kamera, dass das immer doch Fullscreen ist und so was. Ich hoffe, dass es noch mit einer Hand zu bedienen ist. Das hätte man ja investigativ schon mal klären können, dieses Problem, ob das geht, ob man hier auch dann mit der Hand bis oben vernünftig hinkommt. Das finde ich bei diesen monströs großen...
Kommt auf die Hände an, ne? Ich glaube, ich habe da kein Problem. Ich kann ja mit meinem Daumen...
Ich finde es bei diesem sehr großen Android-Telefon schon... Es tut schon im Daumen weh. Das könnte hier gerade noch so gehen. Wenn das hier so oben 2 cm bis zum Rand komme ich noch problemlos. Dann bin ich damit... Dann sollen sie ein größeres Display machen. Ich sehe einen Haufen ungelöster Probleme, wie sieht die Tastatur aus, dann im Querbildformat und so was, dieses ganze Zeug, aber... Wahrscheinlich wären iPhones mit Tastatur eingeblendet sowieso nur im Hochformat benutzt. Also ich habe im Laufe der Jahre rausgestellt. Bestimmt auch so etwas, was wegen Steve nicht gemacht werden durfte.
Größeres Display.
Was ich ja wirklich geil finden würde, wäre, wenn sie mal den Durchbruch schaffen, da ein Akku reinzutun und den Stromverbraucher einen Tag zu legen, dass das Teil auch mal einen Tag hält.
Na wenn das doch jetzt größer ist, haben sie doch eigentlich auch ein bisschen mehr Platz dafür.
Also der Akku ist nach allem, was ich gehört habe, ziemlich exakt genauso groß wie bisher.
Was machen sie denn mit dem ganzen Platz? Also ich meine, die SIM-Karte ist kleiner. Das Telefon an sich ist physikalisch größer. Es müsste auch eigentlich alles für die Batterie übrig bleiben.
Na entscheidend ist ja nicht, wie viel Platz die Batterie einnimmt, sondern A, was sie zur Leistung in der Lage ist, und B, wie viel Strom hier entnommen wird. Und wenn sie jetzt auf die nächste Prozessorganisation gehen und wieder die Grafik-Power noch mal ins Unermessliche steigern, dann...
Aber bei gleicher Batterietechnik ist natürlich schon auch die Energie irgendwie pro Volumen ausschlagkräftig. Wenn da eine größere Batterie drin ist, hat die wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr...
Ja klar, aber ich mein, beim iPad, beim neuen, ist auch doppelt so viel Batterie drin, aber hast halt durch das neue Display auch gleich doppelt so viel Powerbedarf. So, jetzt, das steigert sich natürlich nicht so. Es wäre zum Beispiel zu hoffen, dass sie einen neuen Bildschirm haben, der nach wie vor Retina-Klimbim ist.
Aber schon halt ein bisschen größer.
Ja, aber vielleicht nur die Hälfte von dem Saft zieht. Also konkret, so ein Telefon hält keinen Tag, wenn man es benutzt. Das ist einfach die Realität.
Hast du so viel Zeit, dass du den ganzen Tag den Telefon benutzen kannst?
Ja, ich mach so zu viel Zeit, oder was?
Es gibt sicherlich auch mal Tage, wo ich nicht die ganze Zeit damit zugange bin, wenn ich hier viel am Rechner mache.
Liegt doch mal das Telefon jetzt aus der Hand, Tim.
Aber ehrlich, der Telefon geht noch voll für jeden Scheiß an.
Wenn ich mit dem Zug unterwegs bin, auf einer Vier-Stunden-Fahrt, kriege ich den Akku leer. Allein schon, weil ich das Teil ja auch noch als Hotspot für meinen Laptop benutzen muss.
Im Zug ist es wohl auch noch besonders gemein, weil er sich ständig umbuchen muss in den einzelnen Zellen.
Genau, wir sollen uns das Bahnthema nochmal gleich aufgreifen. Da gibt es noch ein bisschen...
Aber könntest du, wenn du mit dem Zug sitzt und es als Hotspot nimmst, nicht auch einfach die Sektose nehmen?
Das heißt, ich bin eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer dabei, dieses Gerät zu laden, zu jeder nur irgendwie erdenklichen Zeit. Also wann auch immer ich eine Steckdose in der Nähe habe, steckt das Teil auch dran. Also wenn ich unterwegs bin. Das ist eigentlich das erste, was ich mache. Ich steige in den Zug ein und versorge das Telefon mit Strom, weil ich weiß, dass wenn ich das nicht mache, ich mit irgendwie 18 Prozent aussteige und dann unter Umständen ein Navigations- und Kommunikationsproblem habe.
Kommunikationsproblem hast du auch.
Also bei meiner iPhone.
Freik, kauf dir doch mal so einen Battery-Pack, Mann.
Oder so einen Lumia 920.
Ich hab einen Battery-Pack, das heißt MacBook Air.
Nee, diese kleinen Sanyo-Dinger.
Ich hab eh mein Air dabei.
Na dann, was regst du dich dann auf?
Das heißt, ich reg mich auf, ich fände es einfach mal eine neue Qualität, wenn ich mein Haus auch ohne mein MacBook Air verlassen kann, damit irgendwie mein Gerät immer geladen bleibt.
Aber ohne MacBook Air bräuchte es ja schon mal keinen Hotspot.
Da hat der Huckel recht.
Also, your logic is flawed.
Ich sag nur, doppelt so viel Akku wäre ein echtes Selling-Argument.
Ja, doppelt so viel kannst du ja mal voll vergessen.
Weil, bisschen schneller, bisschen größerer Bildschirm. Was?
Wie soll denn doppelt ein Akku hinkriegen, mal so auf die Schnelle?
Indem sie zum Beispiel ein Display verwenden, was halt nicht so viel Saft zieht. Weil diese Retina-Teile einfach einen deutlich höheren Strombedarf haben.
Wenn es das geben würde, ja, dann hätten die es nicht schon längst gemacht.
Das machen sie mit der neuen Generation natürlich.
Aber doppelt, was? Doppelt ist gar nicht so easy jetzt, wo die Displays schon so einigermaßen seit ein paar Jahren irgendwie... Also irgendwann werden die Entwicklungsstufen auch immer ein bisschen langsamer.
So weit ich gehört habe, ist das die Erwartung, dass sie da noch den Stromverbrauch halbieren können bei diesen Retina-Teilen, weil die halt einfach noch ineffizient arbeiten.
Die Retinas brauchen ja irgendwie doppelt so viel Licht pro Fläche wie so ein klassisches Display. Und dann ist... Da ist gut.
Ich schmatze auch nicht.
Ich schon.
Und dann gab es ja so diese Geschichten, das war ja eine Breaking News bei, ich weiß nicht mehr, welcher ehemals seriösen Zeitung. Das neue iPhone wird ein um 2 Millimeter dünneres Display haben. Dass die ja irgendwie diese Touch-Sensor integriert haben direkt ins Display.
Du meinst, dass die eine Scheibe da weggelassen haben?
Dass sie eine Scheibe weggelassen haben. Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, das wieder ein bisschen weniger Licht schluckt.
Ja, aber nicht die Hälfte.
Ich weiß nicht, was da noch so alles draufklebt auf so einem Display, bevor das Licht um ein Auge erreicht.
Also mein Tipp, immerhin, wir haben jetzt einen streitbaren Punkt für diese Ankündigung gefunden, aber mein Tipp ist, die Akkulaufzeit wird wahrscheinlich einfach gleich bleiben.
Vielleicht so.
Vielleicht eine halbe Stunde länger oder so.
Aber was soll sich denn dann, ich meine, wo geht dann... Was ist dann neu? Ich meine, was ist jetzt neu? Außer, dass das Ding etwas länger ist. Und dass sie...
Ich weiß schon, worauf du hinaus willst. Sie brauchen natürlich irgendeinen... Sie können nicht so richtig für A's und O's sorgen, wenn sie sagen, übrigens, euer neuer Dog-Connector, euer bisheriger Dog-Connector-Krempel ist jetzt wertlos. Und übrigens, eure SIM müsste jetzt ein bisschen kleiner fallen. Und ja, wir haben ein bisschen mehr Pixel.
Was wahrscheinlich sich verbessern wird, ist die, wie heißt das, die Standzeit. Weil solange das Display nicht an ist, ist ja die zusätzliche Batterie, und die ist ja ein Stück größer, da um irgendwie...
Standby-Zeit?
Standby-Zeit, genau, um den Rest irgendwie aufrecht zu halten. Und das könnte sich dann schon ein bisschen verlängern. Oder auch telefonieren, dann ist das ein A-
und O-Feature?
Nee, denke mal nicht.
Also ich glaube, der neue Dog-Connector wird schon was werden. Also ich nehme an, der wird auch noch irgendeinen Feature haben, was wir nicht gesehen haben.
Na, Apple toppt ja immer, wenn sie eine Hardware nicht rausholen können, dann machen sie einfach irgendwas in der Software, was die anderen Geräte aber einfach mal nicht kriegen.
Na ja, es gibt einen Thunderbolt zu Dog-Connector-Kabel.
Also ich finde das neue Dog-Connector... Endlich, genau. Also ich finde das neue Dog-Connector-Kabel, das macht schon Sinn.
Klar, es macht Sinn, aber wäre das jetzt ein Kaufgrund für ein neues Telefon? Nein, nicht wirklich. Es ist schon eine Verbesserung für die Zukunft und okay, macht auch Sinn, aber das ist kein Kaufgrund.
Aber Apple hat doch bisher noch... Haben die jemals außer bei dem Retina-Display...
Haben die jemals einen Kaufgrund gemacht?
Na ja, ne, aber dass so eine Generation um so viel Biles besser hat... Die waren auch immer gerade so, dass immer alle gesagt haben, äh, ne, das Neue braucht man nicht.
Das Vierer hatte das Retina-Display und das 4S haben sie halt mit Siri so ein bisschen vor allen Dingen vermarktet, ne?
Schneller, besser, weiter...
Na ja, aber das iPhone 4... Also ich meine, ich bin hier der Einzelne mit einem 4S und ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich es mir privat gekauft hätte.
Ja, das hat schon seinen Grund, ne, weil das Vierer nämlich total geil ist, stimmt's? Okay. Tim hat auch noch vier, ne, oder, Timme?
Tim hat auch noch vier. Ich hab auch noch vier, ja.
Vier ist einfach rockenruhig.
Vier ist gut. Und, ähm, ich meine, das ist ja, wenn man damit hin... Ich glaub, das wird so eher so eine... Was ich noch... Glaubt ihr, dass auch NFC dabei sein wird oder nicht? Also, ich hab ja da so verschiedene widersprüchliche Gerüchte gehört, nämlich zum einen, äh, das geht ja gar nicht, weil die rückseitige Metallfläche ist ja gar nicht groß genug, um da so eine Antenne, so eine NFC-Antenne einzubauen. Aber bei den Prototypen, also bei den Wasserboards, ist wohl hier quasi oben vorne neben dem Lautsprecher...
Ja, ein Ausschaltknopf ist die NFC-Antenne.
Da ist dann so ein NFC-Chip wohl, also auf der Vorderseite. Na, es ist so ein Chip, der aussieht wie ein NFC-Chip. Und es gibt ein Apple-Patent, wo sie so ein iPhone 4 und wo sie ein NFC-Chip gerne anbringen würden. Und das ist exakt an der Stelle, an der sie es sich damals haben.
Ja, Patente haben die bestimmt reichlich für alles Mögliche, damit sie sich alle mit Karten oder, wie man sagt, alle möglichen Sachen offenhalten.
Ja klar.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass da ein NFC kommt.
Also ich gehe hier sozusagen auch nach vorne und sage, iPhone 5, no, NFC.
Also was ist auch eigentlich auf der anderen Seite mit NFC? Das würde man eh nirgends benutzen können, oder?
Das ist so halt so ein Infrastruktur-Traum, so Katze, Henne-Ei. Und ich glaube aber, dass Henne-Ei ohne Apple heutzutage nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und Payment ist glaube ich das Ding.
Ja, Payment ist das Ding, aber das muss man ja nicht zwangsläufig über NFC machen.
Und hat ja Apple mit diesem komischen Payback, oder wie hieß das so? Also da haben wir ja schon so ein bisschen sowas.
Ja, aber da NFC reinzupacken, wäre eigentlich nur logischer Nächster Schritt. Also im Augenblick machen sie es halt über QR-Codes, also über 2D-Barcodes.
Das Ding ist, ich höre von NFC schon echt jetzt eine ganze Weile, also als ich hier noch bei Artcom und Hawker und so, da ging das auch schon die ganze Zeit, NFC kommt und es wird die Zukunft. Und alle wollten NFC jetzt irgendwie auf jeden Fall auch auf ihre Roadmap schreiben und es ist jetzt zwei Jahre später, ich hab noch nicht ein einziges Mal NFC benutzt oder irgendjemandes benutzen sehen. Das ist jetzt natürlich auch meine Social Peer-Gruppe, aber it's not there yet. Und irgendwie hab ich auch so das Gefühl, das wird auch nichts mehr. Das ist so ähnlich wie diese EC-Karten mit diesem Chip drauf. Das ist auch so ein toller Traum gewesen, überall mit diesem komischen Geldkarten-Chip zu bezahlen, aber irgendwie fast, dass man bei McDonald's machen kann und dann war's das.
Ich hab das sehr viel genutzt. Bei der BVG konnte man damit z.B.
zahlen.
Klar, es ist da draußen, aber ich mein, dass das jetzt ein Home-Run ist und dass irgendwie die Kids ihr Kleingeld irgendwie...
Wenn man das vernünftig einsetzt, ist das ein Home-Run.
Ja, wenn man das macht.
Aber nur wenn die andere Seite auch da ist.
Wie viele NFC-Chips hab ich jetzt in meinem Portemonnaie drinne stecken? Ja klar, ich hab hier zum Beispiel auf meine kaputte 3FNOW-Karte-Marke klebt hier auf meinem Führerschein drauf. Dann hab ich hier noch...
Was ist ein NFC-Chip?
Na ja, was wird das sonst sein? Hab ich jetzt grad was durcheinander? Ist das hier nicht auch NFC, so eine Chipkarte?
Das sind alles RFID-Karten. Okay, dann hab ich grad was durcheinander. Irgendwo ist das natürlich alles in der Kategorie Funk-Chip und NFC ist halt dann wiederum dieser eine Standard, der dann eben ganz konkret auf diesen Bedarf verkaufen hin optimiert ist. Na, nicht nur. Immer, dass jetzt dann auch wieder...
Also ich denke mal, solange Apple da nicht richtig fett Geld mitverdienen kann, so mitverdienen vor allem, werden die da genau gar nichts machen.
Und das ist auch kein Feature, wo sie auf der Keynote sein können.
Selbstverständlich hat Apple ein Interesse da dran, der Payment-Transaktor zu werden. Das ist ja überhaupt keine Frage. Und dass das iPhone auf dem Weg dahin ist, das sehe ich auch. Nur die Frage ist, ist NFC diese Technologie? Und ich ehrlich gesagt, von dem, was ich so fühle, ist für mich eher so Bluetooth der Kandidat. Also Bluetooth 4.
Na, aber Bluetooth 4 braucht immer noch eine Batterie auf deiner Seite gleich. Aktive Stromversorgung.
Eine Batterie in deinem iPhone oder was?
Na, auf der entsprechenden Gegenseite.
Ja, die Gegenseite ist eine Kasse. Ich meine, die steckt am Strom mit 220 Volt.
Wenn du nur Payment machen möchtest, wenn du noch für andere Anwendungen gibts, also es gibt diese Bluetooth 4 Beacons, habe ich auch schon mal von erzählt, mit ihren großen Batterien drin, die ewig lange durchhalten und so. Aber die brauchen halt immer noch eine Batterie. Also dieses so ein kleines NFC-Chip, das ist glaube ich in der Produktion deutlich billiger und du kriegst es halt kleiner und dünner und billiger.
Ja, aber Bluetooth ist schon drin.
In so einem iPhone?
Also eher bauen sie Thunderbolt und iPhone ein.
Ja, es ist einfach da. Also du musst jetzt da gar nichts reinbauen, weil ist ja schon alles da. Es ist nur eine Frage der Software. Und natürlich der Gegenstelle.
Ja, dann könntest du es auch über Wi-Fi machen.
Für Bluetooth spricht, dass es eben in Bluetooth 4 eben auch protokollmäßig so upgraded ist, dass du eben nicht mehr so komplexe Peering-Prozesse brauchst, wie du das eben mit Bluetooth 3 noch gebraucht hast. Und W-Laden musst du ja nun gar nicht erst sagen. Ich meine, wenn du an der Kasse dich erstmal in ein W-Laden einbuchen musst, dann kannst du das einfach mal vergessen. Dann greifen die Leute zur Hosentasche und holen einfach ihr Bargeld raus, weil das funktioniert wenigstens. Ich meine, guck dir an, was schon für ein Trouble hast mit einer EC-Karte am Supermarkt. Ich meine, wenn die frisch ist, dann funktioniert sie zwei, drei Monate und danach musst du irgendwie vier, fünf Mal reinstecken und die Verkäuferin oder der Verkäufer darf dann irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen dran reiben, hauchen. Ja, das ist meine Experience. Ich meine, die Karten sind dann halt irgendwann auch echt ganz schön durch und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es immer total unproblematisch wäre. Und in dem Moment, wo du halt dein iPhone benutzen kannst, dafür, stellen wir uns einfach mal so ein Szenario vor, Supermarkt, was ja so ein typischer Fall ist, wo du irgendwie gerne elektronisch zahlst. Und jetzt versuchen wir einfach mal, was müsste quasi gegeben sein, wenn ein iPhone jetzt deine Brieftasche ist? So, da müsste die Kasse nachdem dein Betrag feststeht, erstmal deines iPhones habhaft werden. Du müsstest es sozusagen in dem Moment da in einen Bezahlmodus bringen. Also startest du da deine Bezahl ab? Oder, das ist irgendwie im OS drin, wäre die nächste Variante, weil Ab-Aufrufen ist ja auch so eine Sache.
Nein, ne, ne, App starten muss man ja schon. Ansonsten, wie soll es sonst gehen?
Na, weil das Telefon das irgendwie selber detectet.
Na, dann müssen die sich ja vorher, dann müssen sich ja Kasse und Telefon vorher schon kennen.
Naja, eben nicht unbedingt, sondern die Kasse schickt halt so ein Bezahl-Challenge raus.
An alle iPhones, die zufällig in der Nähe sind.
Das ist dann wieder ein...
Das funktioniert nur für den, der genau vor der Kasse steht.
Legen Sie jetzt Ihr Telefon...
Ja, na gut, da stehen natürlich noch mehr Leute vor der Kasse. Ich will jetzt noch gar nicht sagen, dass es das Tollste und Größte ist. Ich versuche nur mal diesen Gedanken durchzuspielen, was eigentlich realistisch passieren könnte und wie man das lösen könnte. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, die Kasse sendet sozusagen jetzt irgendwie bezahl mich und in dem Moment, wo du, kann ja auch sein, dass du einfach nur auf den Knopf irgendwie 5 Sekunden drücken musst und dann geht er in den irgendwie, wo kann ich was bezahlen? Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt alle ihr Telefon rausziehen, um deine Rechnung zu bezahlen. Das ist ja auch nichts, was jetzt sonderlich droht. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass irgendwelche Leute das Ganze bezahlen.
Nein, das ist ja nicht meine Sorge, aber wenn ich in der Kasse stehe und ich da nebenbei meinen Twitter-Stream lese, ich nicht dazu komme, weil er mich alle 10 Sekunden fragt, hey, möchtest du diese 20,38 Euro für den Herrn da vorne gerne bezahlen? Nein, ich bin ja immer noch nicht.
Du drückst halt irgendwie deine Taste einfach lang. Nur mal so als Idee. Vielleicht gibt es auch noch eine Bezahltaste, aber einfach nur du drückst hier auf deine Taste da unten oder machst irgendwie einen Quadruple-Click oder irgendeinen Kack. Ich weiß, dann ist Accessibility und Belegungen und Dinge müssen sich unter Umständen ändern, das ist jetzt nur mal so gedacht. Das OS schaut in dem Moment auf Bluetooth. Ist da was, was zu bezahlen gibt? Zeigt mir irgendwie den Receipt an und sagt hier irgendwie EDK 8974. Und dann sagst du einfach bezahlen. Fertig.
Ist da nicht besser, wenn sie diesen 3 Cent NFC-Chip einbauen oder das Telefon mal kurz vorbei wischen und alles ist gut?
Das ist doch genau das gleiche, bloß ohne NFC. Warum sollen sie einen Chip einbauen, den sie dann immer einbauen müssen, wenn sie den Chip schon haben?
Wofür haben sie einen Bluetooth-Chip eingebaut?
Na dafür zum Beispiel.
Ich dachte, den hätten sie für irgendwelche Feuchtig-Einrichtungen.
Ja, aber jetzt halt auch dafür.
Ist doch egal, wofür sie einen Bauen haben. Du glaubst, dass Bezahlen zukünftig Bluetooth ablaufen wird? Ich sage, ich halte NFC für wahrscheinlicher.
Ich sage, keines von beiden wird sich da zum Bezahlen im Supermarkt durchsetzen.
Bluetooth kriegen die alle überhaupt gar nicht auf die Reihe irgendwie.
Ich meine, wenn das jetzt mit diesem Passbook irgendwie sich kombiniert, etc., du dann auch gleich deine EDK-Gutschein ab irgendwie mit dabei hast, die du in dem Moment gleich einsetzen kannst und so, dann kriegt das schon Dynamik.
Dieses Passbook ist ja auch so ein Werbeding. Am Ende wird es wahrscheinlich keiner benutzen und wird so eine goldene Nummer wie Siri.
Oh, das wird genutzt werden.
Oh, okay, Claim-Schaude, bitte fürs Protokoll.
Passbook wird selbst von...
Gibt es das überhaupt irgendwie schon in Europa zum Beispiel?
Passbook, da muss sie nichts für geben.
Das kommt doch jetzt erst.
Das ist einfach nichts weiter. Also erstens gibt es das noch nicht, weil es gibt keinen iOS 6 bisher. Das ist nichts weiter, als dass du einen QR-Code an einer etwas leichter zugänglichen Stelle hast, dass du ihn nicht mehr in irgendeinem Mail bekommst mit deinem Boarding-Check-In, zum Beispiel beim Fliegen, sondern dass du ihn per Passbook bekommst. Oder sie können ihn auch in die gleiche Mail als Attachment dranhängen. Das ist der einzige Unterschied.
Kann man ja lange darüber streiten, weil es gibt es da noch nicht, da müsste man ein paar Wochen gucken.
Also ich sage, Passbook ist das neue Ping.
Also ich sage, Passbook in einem halben Jahr, Jahr wird das so weit. Also es wird eine Weile dauern, bis diese ganzen, weil das sind eher Institutionen, das sind so, wie gesagt, irgendwelche Fluggesellschaften oder Starbucks oder sowas, die sowas implementieren müssen.
Der Pizza Delivery Service.
Oder der Pizza, na payment ist es ja nicht.
Da ist kein Payment dabei?
Der Passbook ist im Augenblick eine reine Gutscheinkarte. Das ist kein Payment.
Da habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Es ist offensichtlich, dass das in eine Richtung von bezahlen geht. Aber es ist derzeit mehr ein, du kaufst dein Ticket und Passbook ist sozusagen der Ort, wo es ist. Und wenn du dann da hingehst, wo du es brauchst, dann ist es sehr leicht da ranzukommen, weil du halt alles an einem Ort hast.
Das heißt, ich zahle online meine Kino-Karte, die krieg ich zum runterladen, hab den Passbook, geh ins Kino, zeig mein Phone, hier Einschulkarte und dann geh ich rein.
Exactly. Mit so Klimbim, dass irgendwie die Abhalt merkt, oh, du bist jetzt auch an dem Ort, wo das Kino ist und dir das sozusagen schon auf deine Homescreen draufmacht, bevor du irgendeine Taste gedrückt hast.
Oder bei dem Kino kannst du halt auch sehr schön einfach, das Kino fängt ja gleich an, das weiß er, wann das Kino losgeht, alles klar, dann zeichne wir jetzt schon mal.
Also ich hatte ja schon, als das vorgestellt wurde, gesagt, dass ich das sehr interessant finde und meiner Meinung nach ist das Apples Art und Weise, diesen ganzen Payment-Kram vorzubereiten. Aber sie kümmern sich erstmal darum, ein Environment zu haben, mit dem du dich so vertraut machst, dein Ort, dein Bezahlort. Und irgendwann kommt dann das Bezahlen dazu. Und ich sag dir, das ist nichts, was von Hardware abhängt. Sondern das machen sie, wenn, dann mit Bluetooth und warum sollte es dann nicht Kassen geben, die, man ist sowieso alle Computer-basiert, da steckst du noch einen kleinen Dongle dran, das Ding Bluetooth fertig. Und dann ist das Ding bezahlfähig.
Also wie gesagt, ich sehe nichts, spricht nichts dagegen. Einfach in Zukunft die iPhones, ein FC-Trip einzubauen, gut, ist fertig. Aber werden wir sehen.
Wahrscheinlich kann man dann sogar über die Apple-ID bezahlen irgendwann.
Ja, natürlich kannst du das. Selbstverständlich, das ist das Ding. Du bezahlst dann eben darüber. In den USA könnte ich mir das vorstellen, dass es sehr schnell abgeht, weil da sind die Leute vollkommen gewohnt, mit ihrer Kreditkarte zu bezahlen. Hier ist das halt anders.
Eine Apple-Kreditkarte.
Na gut, so weit sind wir noch nicht. Das können sie dann auch irgendwann nochmal machen.
Kann man dann keinen Porn mit kaufen?
Ist durchaus denkbar, ja.
Du lachst mit einer American Express, ist das nicht möglich?
Sie brauchen gar keine Kreditkarte. Die Apple-Kreditkarte hast du schon in deiner Tasche. Das ist das iPhone, das ist die Apple-Kreditkarte. Nur, dass sie derzeit noch das Payment über Visa oder über Mastercard machen, aber irgendwann können sie die dann auch...
Und hast du dann aber nicht Angst, dass bei den aktuellen Angriffen, die es so gibt, oder immer mal wieder auch kommen so fürs iPhone, dass es nicht doch alles ein bisschen heikel ist so? Hast du nicht so ein bisschen Schiss, wenn man auch mal auf die Security-Seite betrachtet?
Ich wache morgens schweißgebadet auf, täglich.
Ja, jetzt vielleicht noch nicht, weil noch irgendwie...
Ja, natürlich ist das ein Thema, klar. Also, wie immer. Es wird spooky und es wird auch spannend zu sein, ob diese Technologie schnell greift. Und ich denke, dass die Leute auch eine extrem hohe Erwartung an Sicherheit und eine extrem hohe Erwartung vor allem an Zuverlässigkeit und Handhabbarkeit haben. Und deswegen hat's Apple an der Stelle auch nicht sinnlos eilig. Ja, und dass die anderen, die jetzt seit Jahren NFC schreien, sich um solche Faktoren groß kehren, glaube ich halt nicht. Und deswegen ist es auch kein Wunder, dass das alles noch nicht richtig greift, weil sie sich wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal über ein User-Interface Gedanken gemacht haben. Und meiner Meinung nach, das ist halt eine Vermutung jetzt von mir, ist Passbook Teil dieser Strategie, ein solches User-Interface urbar zu machen. Die Leute einfach daran zu gewöhnen, dass ihr Telefon auch so ein Ort ist, wo man Gutscheine, bezahlte Tickets und vielleicht auch irgendwann zu bezahlende Tickets drin hat. Dass du eine Reservierung hast und so weiter. Ich meine, häufig geht ja auch eben die Bezahlung ohnehin schon über das Internet. Das ist auch etwas, was man glaube ich nicht ganz außer Acht lassen sollte, dass dieses Bezahlen vor Ort Thing of the past ist. Also früher bist du zum Bahnhof gegangen und hast dir da ein Ticket gekauft und dann bist du gefahren. Heute hast du dein Ticket schon in der Regel ausgedruckt oder du kaufst es halt auch schon mit irgendeiner ab. Und immer mehr Dinge kannst du schon vorher kaufen. Nur diese Ad-Hoc-Sachen wie im Supermarkt oder eben so die Gelegenheitssachen, wo du kurzfristig vor Ort entscheidest, zu bezahlen. Das sind die einzigen Sachen, die noch über sind. Aber grundsätzlich geht das Kaufen eigentlich, also die Entscheidung an irgendwas teilnehmen zu wollen, Kinokarte, bestes Beispiel. Warum nicht schon vorher, wenn du eh weißt, dass du da gleich hingehst? Niemand zwingt dich dann die knappen Minuten, nachdem du deinen Parkplatz gefunden hast und dann da rein willst, auch noch damit zu verbringen, in so einer bekloppten Schlange zu stehen, nur um irgendwie etwas Geld zu zahlen, was auch schon problemlos mit deinem iPhone auf dem Weg dahin regeln kannst. Also deswegen denke ich halt auch, dass diese ganze NFC-Sache nicht so wichtig ist, wie sie viele leicht glauben, weil es eigentlich das Bezahlen der Vergangenheit ist.
Siri, shut up and take my money!
Naja, aber dieses Spontan an einer Kasse bezahlen, ich glaube, das wird weiterhin bleiben.
Willst du halt nicht über irgendein Login machen oder so was?
Aber an welcher Kasse?
Im Geschäft. Du bist im Geschäft und willst was bezahlen. Lebensmittel.
Ja klar, das ist das Supermarktbeispiel. Das ist halt so einer der Orte. Aber wie viele Orte gibt es wirklich? Ja, aber wie viele Orte gibt es wirklich so über den Tag? Wie viele deiner Payment?
Mittagessen.
Transaktionen, die du so pro Monat machst, machst du unmittelbar?
Tankstelle, Mittagessen, Einkaufen, also nicht nur Supermarkt, Drogerie, wir sind schon in der Apotheke, den ganzen Krempel, wohl halt nicht vorher. Weißt du, dann stehst du in der Apotheke und eigentlich wirst du mit dem Nasenspray und plötzlich hast du die ganze Tüte voll mit irgendwie. Nicht von dir auf andere schließen magst.
Was ich ja, wo es mir auffällt, ist ganz stark beim Bahnfahrt, also bei öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln. Weil, jetzt habe ich mir mal dieses Touch-and-Travel eingerichtet, aber so gerade in der Straßenbahn hier in Berlin ist das so, dass, also Scheine nehmen die ja sowieso nicht, irgendwelche Kartenzahlungen garantiert nicht möglich. Du kannst nur mit Kleingeld zahlen, dann steht meistens noch da dran, dass du nur passend zahlen kannst, weil ja gerade wieder mal jemand zu faul war, Wechselgeld da rein zu packen oder auch Angst vor Ausraub. Und wie oft, also das ist ein Gedanke, das ist einfach so, wenn ich mal, ich fahre hier zwei Stationen, hole ich mir rasch ein Auto, so ein Car-to-go-Auto, wo ich kein Bargeld für brauche, wo ich einfach nur meine Karte kurz davor halten muss und einsteigen und aussteigen, das wird von meinem Konto abgebucht, oder krempel ich jetzt die gesamte Bahnfahrt nach irgendwie Kleingeld rum und bettle meine also im Endeffekt, klar fährt man dann wahrscheinlich im 2 auf 2 schwarz, wenn man nicht sein Ticket bezahlen kann, aber ich will ja schon bezahlen, aber warum es die BVG einen so schwer macht, in der Bahn zu bezahlen, das ist...
Ja, und jetzt im Taxi kannst du dir mit My Taxi so auf Knopfdruck bezahlen. Auch ohne NFC im Übrigen.
Naja, aber dann ist man immer von diesem zentralen System abhängig, wo man sich erstmal vorher anmeldet und so und dafür ist dann, also ich meine, NFC ist...
Ja, da möchte Apple halt gerne das eine zentrale System sein, in dem du schon angemeldet bist.
Aber 30% für eine Taxifahrt an Apple, das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann können sie, aber das wird wahrscheinlich... Das ist die Frage, ob sie an der Stelle... Ist das so ein In-App Purchase?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist separat. Also du meldest dich bei My Taxi mit deinen Verbindlichkeiten an und dann...
Naja, weil das nämlich kein virtuelles Gut ist, was du da kaufst.
Naja, das ist kein Problem.
Und also auch der Supermarkt und die Apotheke und so weiter. Also diese ganzen Vorort-Einkäufe sind eben, fallen gar nicht unter diese Regelung und von daher ist das durchaus vorstellbar, dass Apple entweder Prozessen lässt oder selber prozesst.
Prozessen oder prozessen lassen, das ist ja die Frage.
Ich vermute mal, dass so, irgendwann werden sie in diesen Payment-Markt reingehen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das alleine machen werden, sondern es werden so mit, da wird irgendjemand von Visa auf die Bühne kommen und irgendjemand von American Express wird auf die Bühne kommen und wird das alles erzählen.
Oder Facebook-Credits.
Oder einen neuen Twitter-Credits.
Oder genau gerade nicht, weil Apple sich ja die Kohle nicht mit ihnen teilen will.
Nee, aber das haben sie, die wissen schon, was ihr mag. Also bei so Sachen wie, also mit den Providern, sie haben ja auch keinen eigenen Netzprovider gegründet bisher. Da gab es zwar öfters mal so die Gerüchte.
Aber das ist infrastrukturell, aber auch vielleicht nochmal ein anderer Aufwand.
Ja, aber ich meine, so Banken in allen Staaten dieser Welt zu gründen und das irgendwie mit dem Bankenrecht abzugleichen und so. Ich weiß nicht, ob Apple auf diesen Häsel Bock hat und auf die ganzen Steuerrechte. Eine Bank? Ich glaube nicht, dass Apple Banken hat.
Na ja, indirekt.
Hat nicht irgendwann mal sogar, gab es da nicht mal, irgendjemand?
Die haben eine Bank.
Ich sag nicht, dass die eine Bank haben.
Sagtest du nicht gerade?
Dennis.
Ach so, dass die Banken haben.
Nee, die haben keine Bank, aber... Ich meine, die sind so scheiße groß. Das, was eine Bank an Apple verdient, wenn die da hier den ganzen Apple-Shop-Business für die da betreiben, mehr oder weniger, hat Apple die doch dann geownt.
Eine Bank kaufen die sich doch aus der Portokasse.
Na ja, genau, mein ich doch. Also es ist doch jetzt nicht so schwer, für Apple irgendwie so eine bankähnliche Struktur hochzuziehen.
Aber da sind sie auf andere angewiesen. Weil da können sie nicht so durchmarschieren und den ganzen Markt übernehmen. Also ich glaube, das macht...
Du weißt, das haben die mit dem iPhone auch gemacht und mit dem iPad nochmal.
Ja, aber ich glaube, auf der Payment machen sie das nicht so komplett alleine.
Aber diese Summen, die du dann verdienst, sind doch immer nur Prozente von dem, was bezahlt wird. Wenn du das nochmal mit einem anderen teilen musst, dann lohnt sich doch das ganze Businesskauf noch.
Das machen sie doch die ganze Zeit schon.
Wo denn?
Na, du gibst ja hier, wenn du dein iPhone registrierst, bezahlst du ja auch über irgendeinen Drittanbieter nicht direkt an Apple. Du gibst ja nicht deine Kreditkarten. Also weißt du, du benutzt ja immer noch eine Kreditkarte und so weiter. Also es geht ja schon immer noch nicht direkt alles an Apple. Und die nehmen ja schon...
Ja, aber mit denen haben die ja auch kein Business zusammen. Aber wenn Apple sich halt anstrengt und da auch Arbeit reinsteckt, dann wollen sie auch halt die gesamten Prozente kriegen und sich das noch nicht teilen.
Ich glaube, den Schuh ziehen sie sich auch nicht an.
Die wollen keine Bank sein. Die sind... Also Apple, die wissen glaube ich schon, was sie sind und was sie nicht sind.
Also ich glaube, entweder machen sie das ganz alleine und ziehen durch und verdienen alles oder sie sagen sich, interessiert uns das Thema nicht und andere sollen sich kümmern. Aber sich mit jemandem zusammentun und teilen, glaube ich, das machen die jetzt nicht. Also ich würde auch sagen, das lohnt sich gar nicht.
Aber man muss ja nicht sehr groß zusammentun. Also das ist jetzt alles...
Na, das ist das, was ihr sagt, dass sie dann noch jemanden brauchen.
Ja klar. Nee, wir sagen, sie machen Payment nicht selber. Sie machen keine Bank. Aber es gibt da draußen schon Milliarden und Trillarden von Payment-Providern, die jeden Tag nichts anderes tun. Und das machen alle anderen auch. Und ich sehe da keinen Grund, warum Apple das nicht dann auch machen sollte.
Weil es ja ein Unterschied ist, ob du nur deine eigenen Sachen über Kreditkartenfirmen verkaufst oder alles Mögliche. Ist egal. Wir sehen schon, wir drehen uns ja im Kreis. Timme, du musst dir mal irgendwie einschreiten.
Na gut, kommen wir zurück zum iPhone, wie euer Rumor das heißt. Irgendjemand meinte ja, vielleicht heißt es gar nicht iPhone 5, sondern sie veröffentlichen 5 Produkte. Ja, das wär auch ein schöner Dreh.
Ja, ein iPhone und dann hier, hab ich gerade gesehen.
Das heißt doch New iPhone. Und dann kommen sie irgendwie mit iPod, Shuffle, iPod, Mini, 9 Mac Pro. Was ist noch? iPod Touch?
Und 13 Zoll Retina.
iPhone und iPad Mini.
Wäre eigentlich viel cooler, oder? Man hat nicht so einen iPhone 5 Scheißer drauf, aber die anderen Sachen.
Ja, aber ich glaub...
iPhone 4 ist 5. Warum nicht?
Nein, es umgedreht ist ja fast eine 5 auch.
Nee, so?
So, jetzt haben wir jetzt schon irgendwas gefunden, was uns dazu bringen könnte, diese Telefon zu kaufen, außer dass wir sowieso immer alles kaufen, was neu ist, außer das 4S.
Nee, aber was man bisher so hat, ist doch wirklich jetzt mal mehr neu als bei jedem anderen iPhone bisher, oder?
Also das iPhone 4 war glaube ich bisher, was die Novitäten betrifft, ungeschlagen.
Also es hat ein neues Gehäuse gehabt und ein Retina-Display.
Und Antennagate.
Und den eigenen Apple-Chip. Also das ist eigen aber. Ein Meilenstein der alles.
Definitiv nach der ursprünglichen Einführung der größte Sprung. Ob ihnen jetzt was ähnliches gelingt, weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, wie groß haltet denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass in iOS noch irgendeine Überraschung kommt, in iOS 6?
Ja, hundertprozentig.
Bestimmt, irgendeinen Eye müssen wir noch haben.
Ich meine, es gab jetzt auch schon wieder, wie so oft, länger keine Betas mehr von iOS 6. Das ziehen sie ja immer. Am Anfang gibt es ja dann diesen...
Die haben bestimmt wieder noch so Special Apps, die sie dann so ausbauen.
Genau. Jetzt wird das integriert, was speziell für das neue iPhone ist, damit das alles mit dem größeren Display vernünftig funktioniert und so was. Na gut, was kommt? Ich vermute, Passbook wird aufgewertet um irgendeine weitere Zahlmöglichkeit. Der erste muss ja Passbook überhaupt kommen. Passbook wird dann von Anfang an mit irgendeiner neuen Möglichkeit zusammenarbeiten. Ich glaube nicht, dass es Bluetooth ist, weil das hätten sie uns jetzt schon erzählen können. Das hätten sie schon servilisiert und sagen können, Passbook wird mit Bluetooth zusammen funktionieren, weil da ist kein neues Telefon für notwendig. Darum glaube ich, wird das ein Feature sein, das exklusiv fürs neue iPhone ist, wenn es kommt.
Ja, was dann vielleicht auch an irgendeinem Hardware-Feature hängt. Aber was sollte das sein?
Wie gesagt, NFC wäre so eine Option.
Ich sage, das passiert nicht. Aber das fällt uns doch was anderes ein.
Größeres Display wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Neuer Dog-Connector finde ich schon mal ganz...
Gibt es denn irgendwas, was ein anderes Telefon hat, was das iPhone nicht hat? Ich meine, so etwas mehr davon oder so?
Also die Nokia haben mir gestern Gelbe vorgestellt.
Heute, heute, heute, heute, heute.
Das brauchen wir, mehr Farbe. So wie bei den iPods. Ich will ein orangeses iPhone haben. Nee, das ist ja auch noch was. Also... Ein bisschen mehr Optik finde ich. Also ich meine, wie viele Millionen... 300 Millionen iPods... Okay, da sind die iPods mit dabei. Aber sagen wir mal, 200 Millionen iPhones und so. Wie viele iPhones haben sie verkauft? 200 Millionen, 150 Millionen irgendwie so in dem Dreh. Lass es 100 Millionen sein. 100 Millionen Geräte, die alle gleich aussehen, bis auf zwei Farben. Also das heißt, sagen wir mal, 50-50 sind das 50 Millionen schwarze und 50 Millionen weiße. Wie sieht denn das aus? Ich will ein bisschen mehr Individualität.
Dann klebt dir doch hinten einfach eine schöne Folie drauf.
Weißt du, in einer U-Bahn, dir dein iPhone runterfällt, dann bücken sich 50 Leute, weil sie denken, das ist ihres. Die anderen 50 sagen, der hat ein weißes.
Aber warte mal, bist du der mit einem iPhone 52?
Glücklicherweise fällst du keine Bahn.
Ja, ein Airbag wär mal cool, ne? Wenn sie Airbags einbauen würden.
Ich glaub, dass der Dock-Connector noch was Neues haben wird, von dem man noch nichts ahn. Also was ich zum Beispiel glaube, dass, oder was ich ein bisschen hoffe, ist, dass der rauskriegt, an welchem Netzgerät er gerade dranhängt. Also was ich, das neue iPhone, Quatsch, das neue iOS hat ja diesen Schlaf-Modus, diesen Do-Not-Disturb-Modus, ich schlafe jetzt. Nee, nicht Powernap. Also wo Klingelton abgeschaltet wird und alle Notifications abgeschaltet wird und nur VIPs dich anrufen können und sowas alles.
Der Kramp, ja.
Was man im Augenblick zeitbasiert einstellen kann. Ich würd's cool finden, wenn ich, wenn das iPhone einfach weiß, dass es, ah, ich wurde jetzt gerade an das Ladegerät gesteckt, was im Schlafzimmer sich befindet. Also geht der Max gerade Bubu machen. Und darum geh ich in den Schlafmodus. Und wenn ich morgens aufwache und das Telefon wieder abziehe, dann wacht er wieder aus auf dem Schlafzimmer.
Und dann steckst du deinen Radio wecker und dann...
Du hast immer Ideen, Max.
Was denn? Und schlimm.
Also ich kann dir auch gleich sagen, warum das nicht geht.
Warum nicht?
Weil die Netzteile keine Identifikation haben. Da kommt einfach nur...
Noch nicht.
Und selbst wenn. Ich nehme mal einen Netzteil mit auf Arbeit, lasse das andere wieder da liegen.
Ich hab da eins fest hinter dem iPhone angeschlossen. Also wieso sollen die denn keine Identifikation haben? Dann sollen sie einfach eine Identifikation einbauen.
Wozu soll sie eine Identifikation haben?
Dafür sowas zum Beispiel.
Aber wenn du vergisst ranzustecken, dann wirst du nicht geweckt oder was?
Dann geht es halt nicht in den Schlafmodus. Dann werde ich halt geweckt, wenn eine Notification kommt.
Okay, überzeug mich. Gar nicht. Noch irgendwelche Vorschläge, wozu dieser Dock-Connector...
Du hast ja ein Telefon nicht nachts, du machst das ja noch ein paar Tage zu einer Bahn.
Nein, ich lade die auch nachts die ganze Zeit.
Thunderbolt.
Weil mich irgendwas hasser ist, als wenn mein Telefon nicht 100% geladen ist. 100% ist der einzige entschädigte Zustand.
Dann musst du ungefähr 100% deines Lebens hassen.
Nee, ist halt einfach...
Kauf dir so ein Sanyo.
Ich hab das schon, ich hab das gekauft, ich benutze das nicht.
Ja, so eine Art Obsession.
Ja, machen wir ein gutes Angebot, ne?
Wenn du es nicht brauchst, ist es für dich ja anscheinend nichts wert.
Wenn du nichts dafür zahlen willst, ist es dir nichts wert.
Lass uns in der Mitte treffen.
Genau, das ist so was, was auch noch ein bisschen von NFC spricht. Also da gibt es ja, was ich gar nicht so schlecht finde, das gibt es bei irgendwelchen Android-Telefonen, dass man sich ins Auto in die Halterung, das in der Halterung vom Telefon, so ein NFC-Ship klebt, sodass dann das Telefon weiß, dass es jetzt im Auto ist und sich in Auto-Modus automatisch schaltet. Und dann schlau genug ist, sich mit allen Inhalten dazu perren und Bluetooth einzuschalten und so dieses ganze Zeug. Ich glaube, da ist schon so einiges, was man entweder über das Kabel oder über... Kann man alles mit Bluetooth machen? Na klar, da hat niemand mit Bluetooth.
Naja, weil es keiner braucht.
Ja, weil du auch im Auto sitzt, wo sitzt denn dieser Bluetooth-Chip dahin, Pappen? Wie, das braucht keiner. Es braucht niemand, dass er sich automatisch ins Auto einsteigt und sich das Auto pärt mit der Freisprecherin Richtung. Ich glaube, das brauchen schon Leute.
Ja, aber das kannst du halt über Bluetooth machen. Da musst du jetzt nicht nochmal ein Ändernd-Chip da reinbauen.
So, jetzt haben wir den Satz schon mal wiederbeholt. Das macht aber niemand mit Bluetooth. Warum macht es niemand mit Bluetooth?
Weil du brauchst... Weil es keiner braucht. Ja, wer das jetzt das, wonach alle schreien, dann könnte man es damit ja auch machen.
Ach so.
Apple sollte also nur Sachen einbauen, nach denen die Leute schreien.
Weil um Himmels willen nichts...
Oder schreien werden.
Können wir vielleicht mal...
Das ist ja die große Kunst bei Apple, dass die Sachen erzeugen, wo die Leute nach schreien werden.
Also ich glaube, dass dieses Anschlusskabel mit den wenigen Pins ist natürlich insofern eine Abkehr. Wie viele Pins hatte das alte richtig viele? 30, 20?
Da war ja noch Firefly mit dabei und so weiter.
Genau, da ist halt eine ganze Menge Legacy.
Das kippen sie natürlich jetzt alles.
Ja, aber es war mal da.
Das kann USB 3, das neue iPhone.
Ja, das wird eine Garantie USB 3 haben. Das wäre ich mir total sicher.
Ich mir nicht. Aber manchmal wäre es schon ganz cool, wenn es mal ein bisschen flotter irgendwie so...
Ja, aber der Macbook hat kein USB 3.
Ich meine, dass USB eigentlich der wichtigste Betriebsmodus ist, dieses Dock-Connectors, ist auch klar. Also wenn jetzt so Devices da rangehen, dann gehen sie da als USB-Device ran. Primär. Sie tun es halt in der Kapselung dieses Dock-Connectors und das Ganze eben noch mal unter der Hoheit von irgendwie Apple-sanktionierten Verhalten. Aber wenn du da zum Beispiel Audio-Devices anschließt, dann machst du das halt mit USB. Du kannst da auch Standard-USB-Audio-Devices über einen Adapter anschließen, die dann mehrere Kanäle haben und Pipapo. Und warum sollte das auch nicht so sein? Die erfinden ja auch nicht unbedingt das Rad neu, sondern sie geben ihm nur einen anderen Mantel. So, jetzt haben sie aber auch eine andere Erscheinung. Sie lassen viele Kabel weg. Die Frage ist, ist dieser Bus dann in irgendeiner Form sehr viel anderes als so einen USB plus X Serialkabel? Und ich glaube eher, dass es sowas ist. Dass sie alles, was sie meinen, noch parallel signalisieren zu müssen, was eben nicht in USB selber reinpasst, dass sie das da eben auch rüber mitfahren.
Na Video ist halt die Sprangelfrage.
Geht das nur noch per Airplay oder geht das auch immer dieses Kabel noch drüber?
Video ist in HDMI.
Ja oder VR oder was auch immer.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich? Das aktuelle 4S kann das?
Das kann HDMI.
Das kann HDMI, aber das 4 kann es nicht.
Das 4er kann es nicht, ja.
Und macht das irgendjemand, dass irgendjemand sein iPhone mit HDMI irgendwo anschließt, wenn es auch Airplay gibt?
Also ich hab's bisher...
Nö.
Ich glaub auch, dass das so ein komplett überflüssiges Feature ist.
Also ich find, so ein Apple TV als... Also ich meine, andere Adapterkabel für irgendwelche Android-Telefone mit HDMI, die kosten... Entweder liegen sie bei oder die kosten so im Bereich 30, 40 Euro. Dann zu sagen, dann mach mal 90 Euro draußen, dafür hast du ein kabelloses HDMI-Kabel in Form eines Apple TVs, finde ich jetzt nicht schlecht. Also ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass jetzt da wahnsinnig viel mehr über die Luft kommen wird einfach. Wie sieht's denn aus mit irgendwelcher dynamischen WLAN-Koppelungen? Also was ja im Augenblick wirklich noch extrem schmerzhaft ist, ist ja so dieser ganze Airplay-Bereich. Man muss im selben WLAN sein, man muss sich vorher einwählen, dann muss man dieses Gerät das set-upen. Da hab ich ja mal von diesem Zeppelin Air hab ich ja hier auch schon ein bisschen rumgeschimpft, wie furchtbar das alles ist und wie schlecht das einzurichten ist. Und dann braucht man einen Webbrowser und der funktioniert nur mit Internet Explorer oder weiß der Teufel was, dann muss man das ins WLAN hängen und Ethernet-Kabel und wirklich alles schmerzhaft. Wie wär's denn, wenn sie dafür einfach mal vernünftiges hätten? So was wie AirDrop für AirPlay. Steckt sogar schön im selben Namen drin. Und dann halt irgendeinen Nahfunkmechanismus, damit die sich vernünftig set-upen können. Also eigentlich so was, wie jetzt Google mit diesem, wie hieß es, Nexus Q vorgestellt hatte, so dieses Halt kurz sein Telefon dran und das Setup ist da. So was in der Richtung damit einzubauen.
Dieser Q ist noch nicht mal erschienen.
Der wird doch nicht erschienen.
Den haben sie gleich wieder geschrottet.
Aber diese Idee, ich halte mein Gerät dran und dann ist das Setup gemacht, ist trotzdem gut. Das kann man auch per Bluetooth machen, wenn du unten bist. Aber ich finde diese Möglichkeit, dass wenn man sich so ein Gerät kauft, so eine Hi-Fi-Anlage kauft, dass man nicht extra noch einen Ethernet-Adapter sich kaufen muss, um das anzuschließen.
Ich weiß nicht, dieses ganze Rangehalte, das ist doch auch wirklich...
Wie willst du es denn sonst machen? Was ist denn die Alternative?
So was wie AirDrop für AirPlay, das finde ich gut. So, du sagst jetzt hier...
Na, ohne ranhalten. Einfach so halten, wie sonst auch.
Draufhalten.
Na, im Netz, im WLAN.
Aber du musstest ins WLAN rein kriegen.
Ja, dann halt Bluetooth. Mein Gott, das funktioniert bei der Wii mit Bluetooth 4 nicht. Das ist doch mein Punkt. Da gibt es Methoden, schnellere Verbindungen herzustellen. Und das mag noch nicht fertig sein und das mag auch noch nicht zu Ende gedacht sein. Aber ich glaube, bevor Apple irgendeinen weiteren Wireless-Standard auch noch mit einbaut, da vergeht einiges.
Es ging mir gar nicht mit dem Standard. Ich wollte nur sagen, das muss einfacher werden.
Ich wollte nicht mit dir reden, sondern mit Dennis.
Ach so, dann dreht man Dennis weiter.
Die bauen kein NFC ein.
Hey, ist doch nur noch eine Woche. Gucken wir einfach das nächste Mal und dann wird's schon.
Es regt euch mal ab hier.
Bleibt mal locker, Jungs.
Trinken wir noch ein Bierchen hier.
Euch ist klar, dass wir das Ding nicht vorhergesagt haben, was das iPhone 5 ausmacht, ne?
Haben wir noch nie.
Ah, das würde ich jetzt so nicht sagen.
Weißt du noch, als du das erste iPad vorhergesagt hast und gesagt hast, dass es ein Loch in der Mitte haben wird?
Ein Loch in der Mitte, so wie ein Bagelgerät.
Malerei-Palette.
Vorhersage würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Das war deine Vorhersage.
Das war nicht mal eine Vorhersage. Das war, dass ich mir das vorstellen kann.
Dir ist damals auch schon nichts eingefallen.
Ich wollte nur sagen, wir hatten das große Ding, glaube ich, noch nie hier.
Das ist ja gut so, weil so ein bisschen Überraschung will man ja schon noch haben, oder?
Ich habe Time Machine vorhergesagt.
Habe ich keine Erinnerungen mehr dran, das ist nicht passiert.
Beim iPhone 4 hatten sie es in der Hand, das finde ich das Geile daran, und haben alle nicht rausgekriegt, dass das hier die Antenne ist, der Außen, der Rahmen drumrum. Da war ja Gizmodo, hatte ja das iPhone 4, ihr erinnert euch sicherlich noch, und haben so, was sind das hier für schwarze Kanten? Kann man da den Akku jetzt rausnehmen aus dem nächsten iPhone und so was? Und dann stellt sich Steve damals noch auf die Bühne und lacht sie ein wenig aus, so ihr hattet es schon in der Hand, und ihr kommt nicht auf die Idee, dass das die fucking Antenne sein könnte. Und ich vermute, dass es entweder mit dem Dock-Connector oder auch mit diesem bestehenden iPhone, jeder hätte es schon sehen können, es lag schon mehr oder weniger da. Es ist natürlich noch ein geiles Software-Feature, aber es ist auch ein kleiner Chip auf dem Gerät in irgendeiner Form, oder im Kabel, oder wo auch immer.
Ich weiß, was sie noch bewerben könnten, das sind doch die Lautsprecher-Ausgänge, die Löcher sind ein bisschen größer jetzt, oder? Die werden bestimmt mit bessere Audio-Qualität bewerben. Hatten sie aber glaube ich auch schon mal gemacht.
Jetzt mit Bose-Mini-Speaker.
Genau. Die haben uns da zusammengesetzt und dann zeigen sie lauter Bilder von ihren Räumen, die so schall-isoliert sind, wo sie alles testen und zufügen. Schall-illusioniert.
Und die dann so einer da sitzen und die ganze Zeit nur Beethovens 9.
hört. Und dass es jetzt ja nochmal wieder, dann zeigen wir ein paar Kurven nochmal, wie um 40 Prozent besser ist.
Meinst du nicht, dass die eher sagen würden, ne, neue Kopfhörer? Habt ihr die neuen Kopfhörer gesehen? Die, die so rumgegeistert sind? Haltet ihr die für plausibel, dass die jetzt kommen?
Links, links, links.
Ich brauch links.
Ich hab die gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, könnte mal der Chat...
Aber Apple-Kopfhörer haben mich schon echt noch nie interessiert. Sie hatten noch nie wirklich tolle Kopfhörer und ich glaube, sie werden jetzt damit auch nicht anfangen.
Ich benutze sie häufiger, als ich sie leiden mag.
Als du sie gerne würdest, ja.
Ich meine, wenn die echt sind, dann... Warum nicht? Wenn die gut ins Ohr passen, das ist für mich immer entscheidend. Komisch ist, dass die sozusagen hier so an der Seite und vorne irgendwie...
Ja, ich bin auch skeptisch.
Ich glaube, das, was du gerade für die Seite hielt, ist das vorne. Ich glaube, dass man die so relativ flach reinpackt, ist meine Vermutung.
Da kommt die Musik raus.
Ja, aber an der Seite ist ja auch noch so ein kleines Loch, als wären das eines der Bass und das andere sind die Höhen.
Vielleicht ist das andere ein Mikrofon und das Ding hat Noise-Cancellation.
Nee, nee, das geht ja ins Ohr rein. Siehst du, der... Der Steg... Der Kabelsteg geht ja außen lang. Also den steckst du denn nicht in den Ohr.
Guck, aber warte, da wo rechts steht, das heißt, wenn du den so reinsteckst, ist ja das dicke Ding, was da offen ist, schon nach vorne. Da ist bei mir im Ohr aber irgendwie nichts, wo der lauschen könnte. Also ich nehme mal an, dass es... Der Bass muss das dann sein, oder? Was wir jetzt so ein bisschen getrennt haben.
Subwoofer?
Sozusagen, ja.
Oder die Ansaugstupsen für Luft.
Guck mal, bei dem Bild da oben, da kann man sogar dahinter, dem Gitter, zwei runde Löcher erkennen, oder? Das ist wahrscheinlich der erste Drei-Wege-Kopfhörer der Welt, wird Apple bewerben. World's First und Steve wird aus dem Grab steigen.
Aus dem Grab tanzen wird er.
Grooven. Und wird das Ding persönlich vorstellen. Das wird er sich nicht nehmen lassen.
Oh weia.
Du meinst, die haben den dann in so einer Krypt da irgendwie aufgebahrt in so einem Glassack?
Meinst du eigentlich? Da hat sie es so monetisieren lassen?
So ein Schnürrwittchen-Sack und wird dann immer rausgefahren.
Der wäre das eigentlich das Ding, dass er sich hier auch nicht momifizieren lässt. Sagen wir mal, dass sie hier so einfrieren. Wie heißt das?
Kybernetisieren.
Stimmt, der hätte schon an jeden Scheißdreck geglaubt.
So Futuramakram und so. Nach dem Motto, es kann sein, dass ich jetzt gestorben bin, aber ich mache auch noch mein nächstes Comeback. Steve im Schneewittchensack. Ja, wird irgendwann mal wieder so Friam-mäßig wieder aufgetaut.
Aber wenn das die neuen Kopfhörer sind, dann ist doch wirklich eigentlich jedes Detail an diesem iPhone neu. Das ist neuer, als das iPhone neu war, als es auf den Markt kam. Weil da waren die Kopfhörer und das Netzteil schon alt.
Das ist richtig, das ist eigentlich alles neu, bloß man kennt es halt schon. Es ist ja irgendwie so Yesterday.
Es ist ja wie Zeitung lesen, ne? Die Nachrichten fahren gestern schon heute.
Es ist wie ins Kino gehen, da weiß man auch, was im Film passiert. Die Welt geht unter, Schiff geht unter. Irgendjemand verliebt sich und guckt sich trotzdem an. Es macht auch Spaß.
Es gibt auch Filme, die das nicht tun.
Da kann man dann hingehen, geht man mit seinen Freunden hin und sagt, guck mal, ich weiß, da kommt jetzt das iPhone 5 und es hat neue Kopfhörer.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Kamera noch mal toller und größer und schneller und weiter. Und Pippa Po, keine Ahnung. Lass uns über was anderes reden. Ich glaube, iPhone 5 ist jetzt durch das Thema. Das brauchen wir auch nächstes Mal gar nicht mehr ansprechen.
Nie wieder!
Jetzt, wo unser Podcast rauskommt, wird Apple sowieso failen, weil niemand mehr wird es jetzt kaufen.
Ja, genau. Lass uns lieber über die wichtigen Sachen reden.
Lass uns ja ein bisschen über Max reden.
Was Kleines Unterhaltsames für zwischendurch vielleicht?
Wollen wir noch diesen WDR-Bericht bashen?
Nein, nein, nein, der ist so schrecklich. Bitte keine Aufmerksamkeit schenken. Sonst gucken mich das Leute noch an. Hier, guck mal, da habe ich im Internet gefunden. Irgendwie war einer auf der IFA und hat irgendwie die tollen Notebook-Innovationen. Ich paste in den Chat. Hast du gesehen? Klick mal da den Link. Hat die tollen Notebook-Innovationen von der IFA geklickt. Das ist ja auch wirklich...
Gab's doch auch mit dem...
Also jetzt auf der IFA, also auf der IFA ist Davo eigentlich und so weiter. Also die Innovationen und so.
Ja, die IFA, die Laptops, das Bild kennen wahrscheinlich schon alle. Also jeder stellt jetzt irgendwie so ein Gerät vor, was irgendwie im entferntesten Mal an ein MacBook Air erinnern könnte vielleicht. Also selbe Klappmechanik, selbe Tastaturfarbe und halt irgendwie alles in Silber.
Nur aus Plastik.
Da gab's doch schon mal so ein Bild, wo die so vorm iPod alle Tablets, dann vorm iPad alle Tablets und nach dem iPad alle Tablets. Und ist ja nochmal genau das Gleiche.
Über Tablets können wir nochmal reden. Über dieses Windows 8-Kroxel, was da rumgerennt.
Das ist ja wirklich...
Sony hat ein Windows 8 Tablet mit x86 Prozessor. Also was das mit diesem x86 und ARM soll bei Microsoft, ich verstehe es nicht, warum sie sich dieses Ei legen, sich da selber die Konkurrenz ins Haus zu holen. Ja, ja, welches nimmt man jetzt? Nimmt man das billige mit ARM, was aber leichter ist und der höhere Akku hat, oder nimmt man das schnellere, was teurer ist, aber der Akku nicht lange durchhält. Und Sony hat ein Tablet vorgestellt mit Recovery-Taste. Also wo du am Gerät, am Gehäuse eine Taste hast, die dir ein Notsystem bootet, damit du wieder dein Windows 8 im 2re Zoll wieder herstellen kannst, wenn du es dir zerschossen hast. Und das, finde ich, deutet doch mal krass darauf hin, wie wenig sie das verstanden haben. Oh Gott, was ist das denn? Und dann gab es irgendwo, ich glaube, bei The Verge dieses eine Video, wo sie die ganze Bedienung probieren, und dann probieren sie dieses Office, was ja angeblich für Touch optimiert ist, mit dem Finger zu bedienen, und es geht einfach überhaupt nicht. Und um dann das Display zu drehen, also diesen hochkanten Modus zu haben, muss da in die Systemeinstellungen gehen, Monitore aufmachen, muss da Rotation einschalten, dann dreht er sich halt in die andere Richtung, dann kannst du das mal kurz in der anderen Richtung benutzen. Also sie haben offensichtlich auch keinen Beschleunigungs... Wahrscheinlich ist das um alten Windows auch nicht so leicht beizubringen, dass ich das Display einfach mal drehen kann.
Und...
Aber Windows 8 ist schon jetzt ein voller Erfolg, hat heute der Microsoft-Deutschland-Chef auf der IFA gesagt, weil 30 Geräte angekündigt, noch keins verkauft.
Das ist... Was?
Was ist da jetzt toll dran?
Na, 30 Geräte angekündigt.
Hat gesagt, wir haben zwar noch keins verkauft, aber das ist ein Vollerfolg.
Sie haben noch keins verkauft, aber jetzt schon, obwohl sie noch kein Gerät verkauft haben, ist es ein voller Erfolg. Windows 8 Tablets?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Windows 8...
Das ist auch so ein... Erregt mich nicht.
Erst mal abwarten, erst mal deliveren lassen, ja.
Ja, das erregt mich nicht.
Mich erregt ja auch Apple nicht. Ich war sogar in einem Apple Store und ich war nicht erregt. Ich war in Dresden und hab mir mal den Apple Store angeguckt in so einer Mall.
Der ist hässlich, ne? Hast du dir der Kopfhörer getauscht?
Nee, komischerweise halten die jetzt.
Ach.
Ja, ist erstaunlich.
Hat so nach dem 400. von dir keinen Bock mehr.
Jetzt haben sie ihm mal die funktionierende Version gegeben.
Ja, die gehen jetzt nicht mehr so viel kaputt. Irgendwas haben sie gedreht. Nee, ich hab hier so ein kleines Lüfterproblem. Aber sie hatten dann leider keinen Lüfter da und konnten den nicht tauschen. Jetzt haben sie ihn gereinigt und mal gucken, ob das hilft oder so. Ich hab irgendwie gemerkt, wie mich irgendwie nichts in den Arsch gezwickt hat, als ich in diesen Laden reingegangen bin.
Vielleicht hast du auch einfach alles.
Wir müssen einen neuen Podcast starten, das geht so nicht weiter. Irgendwas, was modern und hip ist.
Das ist auch alles voll mit iPads und so und dann halt noch ein paar Laptops und ein Mac Pro steht da.
Ja, iPad hat dich auch schon nicht so richtig angemacht, ne?
Nee, weil... Naja, ich mein, das ist halt toll für die Leute, die mit einem Computer so nicht klarkommen. Aber ich komm ja klar mit einem Computer.
Ich hab einen coolen Newscase jetzt für das iPad. Ich benutze das gerade quasi täglich. Ich wär jetzt am Gitarre lernen, wieder ganz fleißig. Und da gibts so halt... Ich hab jetzt so eine Webseite gefunden, wo es halt online Lessons gibt, so richtig schön Videos, HD und so weiter. Geht auch auf dem iPad. Kann ich später auch noch ein bisschen mehr zu meinen tollen Gitarrenexperimenten erzählen. Aber da sitz ich halt oft so mit der Gitarre rum, will halt nicht den Rechner, weil der mir irgendwie zu fett und zu klobig und so unflexibel ist. Und mach dann halt die Videos auf dem iPad an und stell mir das dann in die Ecke. Und es gibt ja auch Notenständerhalter, hab ich gesehen, fürs iPad. Da kann man dann prima theoretisch sich das irgendwie... Nee, kannst du dir auch... Ja, eigentlich ja stimmt, oben da, wo das Notenblatt aufliegt, da kannst du es ja auch schon reinlegen. Nee, für den Mikrofonständer gibt es auch iPad-Halterungen, sozusagen.
Ja, aber auf die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen, dass man ja auch so ein Notenblatt...
Nee, aber genau, da lass ich halt einfach die Videos abspielen, hab halt irgendwie Gitarre in der Hand nebenbei und dann irgendwie, das kannst du halt auch mal aufs Sofa werfen und so weiter, das ist so mein, ja, dafür ist es echt gerade ganz brauchbar. Oder auch sowieso hier so Tabulatur für Gitarren und so weiter, da so auflassen und...
Ja, aber so als Mobil, also ich nimm's halt nicht mit. Ich nimm's einfach nicht mit.
Ich flieg aber zum Beispiel am Wochenende nach Barcelona zu einer Rubikonferenz und irgendwie hab ich vor, hab ich vor leicht zu reisen und hab überlegt, ich nehm eigentlich nur mein iPad und mein iPhone mit und lass ihn recht schnell gleich zuhause, weil auf Konferenzen bin ich sowieso nicht so der Notebook-User und unterhalte mich da eher mit Leuten, wenn dann, und dann hab ich mehr Platz im Rucksack für...
Ja, wenn du MacBook Air 11 Zoll hättest, dann ist die Entscheidung eine ganz andere. Ich meine, wenn ich nur so einen Drumm da hätte wie du...
Das ist aber auch kein 11 Zoll.
Aber ich finde, im Urlaub ist das iPad... Ich hab beides. Ich hab mein 13 Zoll MacBook Air im Urlaub mit gehabt und mein iPad und ich hab MacBook Air nicht einmal wirklich auch nur aufgeklappt. Weil das ist die Sachen, die ich machen wollte, nämlich Lesen, ein bisschen Mailkommunikation. Das geht auf dem iPad alles entweder besser, also so Lesen und so ein Zeug, oder gut genug. Und das iPad funktioniert für mich nach wie vor total fantastisch. Und zum Arbeiten nutze ich mein MacBook, klar, aber darüber hinaus...
Wenn man keine Attachments kriegt oder verschicken muss?
Na, hängt davon ab, was es für Attachments sind. Wenn es Bilder sind oder JPEGs. Ich weiß nicht, was du zu Attachments kriegst. Mag sein, dass du...
Na ja, man kriegt so komische Dateien.
Ja, aber die macht man halt im Urlaub oder so nicht auf.
Wieso macht man die im Urlaub nicht auf?
SIP-Dateien kann man auch...
Du machst dann vielleicht anders, aber wenn ich Urlaub mache, dann hab ich eigentlich keinen Bock so richtig auf...
Aber was spricht denn dagegen, eine SIP-Datei am iPad aufzumachen?
Na, weil dann da ganz viele Dateitypen sind und die muss ich mir mit zehn verschiedenen Programmen mir angucken und die will ich irgendwie schnell mal in den richtigen Ort mit meinem Dropbox reinpacken und muss dann immer darauf vertrauen, dass gerade dieses obskure Dateiformat von Dropbox dann auch annonciert wird, dass man das da hinschieben kann und dann so das da uploaden, dann musst du es da noch moveen in so einem 5-stufigen... Es macht mich einfach wahnsinnig. Sachen, die ich irgendwie in zwei Sekunden erledigt habe, die dauern auf dem iPad lange bis sind komplett unmöglich.
Deswegen fang ich damit gar nicht erst an. Genau, wenn ich arbeiten will, nehme ich einen Rechner, aber wenn ich in den Urlaub fahre, oder Konferenzen, will ich nicht arbeiten. Deswegen finde ich es immer ganz befreien, den Rechner gar nicht erst mitzunehmen.
Als Konferenzgerät ist das iPad fantastisch, weil man nicht großartig Zugklappen einstecken, sondern man kann es einfach unter den Arm nehmen. Ich finde diesen Nexus 7 Formfaktor total geil. Habe ich gar nicht darüber erzählt. Das ist eine fantastische Größe für so etwas, weil man es noch wirklich gut in einer Hand halten kann, ohne irgendwelche Fakten. Man hält es irgendwie besser in der Hand als ein deutlich größeres iPad. Dafür ist es ganz fantastisch. Ich finde, das iPad hat sehr viele gute Einsatzzwecke. Ich nutze es immer sehr gerne.
Ja, hat es. Aber wenn ich überlege, was ich mitnehme, nehme ich das Gerät mit, mit dem ich alle Fälle abdecken kann. Und das kann ich nicht mit dem iPad.
Genau.
Elfzoll ist eine geile Maschine. Ich habe auch festgestellt, dass das neueste Gerät tatsächlich sogar mit 8 GB RAM zu kaufen ist. Ich habe erst ganz flapsig gesagt, wenn sie mal 8 GB anbieten, dann mach ich auch ein Upgrade. Dann habe ich erst festgestellt, dass sie das schon anbieten.
Das habe ich dann doch nicht gemacht.
Hast du ein bisschen Credibility gelost? Der hat Street Credibility im Apple Store gelost. Dann hätten sie dir wieder die billigen Kopfhörer gekämpft. Ach so, der hat ja gar keine Ahnung.
Poser.
Ja, 8 GB im Air, das wäre noch schön. Das hätte ich auch gerne.
Ja, gibt's. Aber das Problem ist, wenn ich jetzt eins kaufen würde, dann bieten sie dir halt auch die 512 GB SSD Option an. Und die kostet dann nochmal 500 Euro extra. Das heißt, wenn du das rechts unten Modell kaufen willst, kostet es halt 2000 Euro.
Was kostet ihr denn?
Adel verpflichtet, ne?
Ja, ist ein bisschen too much für ein kleines Upgrade. Dann warte ich dann doch lieber noch ein bisschen. Noch Themen. Ich könnte mal was erzählen hier, was euch wahrscheinlich nicht interessiert. Na ja, Max vielleicht. Ich weiß nicht.
Könnte mich, was könntest du erzählen, was mich interessieren würde?
Das ist die Frage.
Ja.
Wir sind alle sehr gespannt.
Ja, eigentlich gibt es nicht viel zu verkünden, aber es geht voran für die Leute, die sich da vielleicht Gedanken drum machen, dieses Podlove-Plugin irgendwie.
Ja, doch, das interessiert mich tatsächlich ein bisschen.
Ich bemühe mich, das ja voranzutreiben. Und da wird jetzt auch seit einem halben Jahr dran geschraubt. Und ich sag mal, we are getting there. Also ich hab jetzt meinen ersten Podcast auf die aktuelle Alpha-Release umgestellt.
Welchen denn?
Den Lautsprecher. Ich dachte mir, wenn es dazu Komplikationen kommt, das ist so das leidensfähigste Publikum, was man sich denken kann in der Hinsicht.
Weil die hören wollen, wie deine Erfahrungen damit sind?
Vor allem, wenn sie nicht mehr hören können, wie meine Erfahrungen sind, weil es nicht mehr funktioniert. Also wenn ich da den potenziellen Zuhörern und Twitter-Followern solche Probleme kommuniziere mit Feeds und so weiter, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich am besten verstanden. Deswegen habe ich den als erstes genommen. Außerdem ist es der Podcast, der jetzt noch am wenigsten unterschiedliche Feeds hat, etc., Auf jeden Fall habe ich das jetzt installiert und ich hoffe, dass das funktioniert. Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass wir jetzt so ganz kurz davor sind, den gordischen Knoten dann auch endlich komplett durchzuhaben. Es bleibt noch eine kleine Sache. Falls uns irgendeine Hardcore-Wordpress-Spezie zuhört, so jemand, der mal so richtig da in die Codebase reingeschaut hat und da viel mit Modulen und so weiter rumhackt, wenn irgendjemand eine Methode kennt, wie man diesen kurzigen WordPress, was ja wirklich so ein Dreck ist, wirklich unglaublich, beibringen kann, nicht den URLs von Custom-Posts noch so ein Präfix davor zu ballern, da wäre ich dann für Erkenntnisse sehr dankbar. Was habe ich gerade gesagt? Die Übersetzung ist, wenn man, also dieses PodLav-Plugin macht halt einiges anders als die anderen Plugins. Unter anderem sind halt dann die Podcast-Einträge, die Episoden sind sogenannte Custom-Types. Also nicht wie das so die meisten anderen Plugins machen. Man nimmt so einen normalen Blog-Artikel und dann hängt man da irgendwas ran und schabt das alles so in den Feed und dann ist das irgendwie so ein bisschen Post-Podcast-artig, sondern wir sagen irgendwie, das ist was anderes und das steht quasi neben diesen Blog-Beiträgen. Sieht im User Interface dann von der Bedienung im ersten Blick sehr ähnlich aus, wird aber eben unterschieden. Und aus Gründen, die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann, besteht halt dieses WordPress darauf, das URL-Schema, was halt für die Artikel gilt, dort zwar auch durchzusetzen, aber dem immer nochmal so einen Präfix davor zu ballern. Slash, irgendwas und dann kommt der andere Kram. Also mit einigen Worten, man hat nicht die volle Kontrolle über die URLs, die man gerne haben möchte. Aber vielleicht kriegen wir das noch gelöst. Ansonsten funktioniert es schon ganz nett. Und ja, das wird dann echt cool. Das heißt, es gibt dann hier auch, auf der Metaebene gibt es dann sozusagen, wenn dann alles mal umgestellt ist, ich hoffe, das wird dieses Jahr noch fertig werden, gibt es dann auch irgendwie ganz viele neue Feeds und ganz viele Formate, die sich alle quer verweisen untereinander und annoncieren.
Endloses Podcastvergnügen.
Ganz viele Hörer, die sich beschweren, weil sie ihre Podcast nicht mehr laden können.
So eine Vermutung.
Das weiß ich nicht, woher du die Vermutung nimmst jetzt.
Wär mehr sehen. Vielleicht geht ja auch alles gut.
Ja, nee, das ist schon alles unter Kontrolle weitgehend und ich bin da eigentlich sehr zuversichtlich. Ich kann ja noch nicht dazu raten, das auszuprobieren für Production News. Noch nicht ganz da. Aber wenn es beta ist, dann könnt ihr alle anfangen.
Okay, wenn ich meinen imaginären Podcast dann umstelle, sag ich Bescheid.
Genau, dein imaginärer Podcast.
Kann ich das in meinem WordPress auch integrieren, wenn ich gar keinen Podcast habe, dann kann ich sagen, hier, mit...
Macht mir nicht Sinn.
Jetzt schon auf Podlove umgestellt.
Ja, jetzt schon mit Podlove-Support. Dann bin ich so ganz vorne an der blutenden Kante dran.
Ja, das kannst du machen, wenn du so rumposen willst und irgendwie den Eindruck erwecken willst, wirst du so...
Wenn du im Apple Store die besseren Kopfhörer haben willst.
Ganz, ganz vorne.
Nee, aber wer, sagen wir mal, darüber nachdenkt, einen Podcast aufzusetzen, es wendet sich jetzt primär vor allem erstmal so an die Leute, die jetzt so gerade dabei sind, ein neues Projekt zu starten.
Migration ist nicht so gut?
Migration ist nicht ganz einfach, sagen wir es mal so. Also da machen wir uns viele Gedanken darüber, aber der Unterschied ist zwischen dem Podlove-Plugin und so was wie Podpress oder Powerpress ist der, dass so das Podlove davon ausgeht, dass du alles wohl geordnet machst. Also es gibt ein klares Namenschema in den ganzen referenzierten Dateien. Also wenn du Episode X hast, dann hast du da so einen Namen dafür und aus dem leiten sich dann alle Dateinamen ab. Alles liegt im selben Verzeichnis mit irgendwie einem bestimmten Suffix und einem bestimmten Extension, sodass ich sagen kann, ok, jetzt kommt der Podcast mit dem Code sowieso, also dem Slug sowieso, und daraus errechnen sich automatisch alle URLs aller Dateien in allen Varianten. Du kannst halt irgendwie 20 Feats machen, aber du musst nicht 20 URLs reinpasten, wie du das bei den anderen Plugins machen musst. Und wenn du halt später mal auf einen anderen Server umziehst und die URLs ändern sich, dann änderst du das an einer Stelle und es ist sofort für alles geändert. Das ist so der Komfort an der Stelle. Und ganz viel ist automatisch und das mit dem Downloading klappt irgendwie viel besser. Und der Webplayer wird auch immer cooler. I'm looking forward to a great experience.
Was ist der nächste Mittwoch im Live-Podcast? Dann stiehlt der Apple die Show. Guckt sich keiner mehr die Keynote an.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch eine Überlegung. Vielleicht starten wir auch gleich mit der Nummer 5.
Jetzt in länger.
Und wir werden auch dieses Jahr nochmal ein Developer-Meeting machen. Es gab ja im Frühjahr eines, wo sich so 20 Leute getroffen haben. Haben wir hier drüber gesprochen? Ja, da haben wir drüber gesprochen.
Bestimmt haben wir da drüber gesprochen.
Genau, aber da haben wir halt danach drüber gesprochen und nicht davor. Jetzt rede ich mal davor.
Und nicht danach?
Das wird im November. Danach halten wir das Maul. Dann kriegt jeder sein NDA in die Hand und dann ist Schluss. Genau. Das ist kein Podcast-Camp, keine Meet-and-Greet-Veranstaltung, kein Bar-Camp oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Sondern es ist ein knallhartes Meeting, wo es einfach um Entwicklung geht, wo Leute hinkommen, die in irgendeiner Form ein Interesse haben, diesen ganzen Podcasting- Softwarebereich nach vorne zu bringen, die entweder schon was getan haben, in dem Bereich irgendwie unterwegs sind, die also Plugins gemacht haben, Publishing-Software gemacht haben. So Leute wie Auphonic werden wieder da sein. Hier der Astro, der Bit.Love gemacht hat, etc. podcast-client-developer. Und die, die halt jetzt noch nicht da waren und da noch nicht angedockt sind, wenn ihr also in irgendeiner Form Podcast-Software macht oder Podcast-Software zu machen, ein sehr großes Interesse habt und da Lust habt, euch mit anderen, die in dieser Richtung entwickeln, euch zu vernetzen und vor allem auch gemeinsam über Standards zu reden, Formate, Protokolle, Konventionen, etc. über Feeds diskutieren, also alles, was diese ganze Podcasting-Infrastruktur dieses Ökosystem technisch voranbringt. Dann könnte es sein, dass ihr da auch daran teilnehmen wollt. Das Ganze findet in Berlin statt am 10. und 11. November. Wer Interesse hat daran teilzunehmen, der möge mir doch bitte eine Mail schreiben und schreibt einfach, was euch so treibt und was ihr so im Sinn habt. Ja, habe ich das jetzt gut rüber gebracht?
Ich glaube auch die Hörer. Ich hatte vorhin schon den Dreher drin mit Potluff und Bitluff. Dann kam ja hier deine Nachbarin vorbei, die auch erst mal Potluff und Bitluff vertauscht hat. Hier im Chat sind auch alle schon ganz schön verwirrt und steigen nicht mehr durch. Also du musst da mit der Namensgebung, da musst du irgendwas noch machen. Du kannst ja irgendwie...
Zu viel Liebe. Potluff 3.
Wenn ihr Probleme habt, zwei Worte, die sich an zwei Stellen zu unterscheiden, dann seid ihr auf jeden Fall keine Zielgruppe. Sowas würde einem Developer nicht passieren, ne?
Nein, niemals.
Dafür haben wir ja Cold Completion.
Ich hatte letztens so einen Bug, da haben wir eine Stunde lang diskutiert. Wir haben ja iOS und Flash Clients und einen Backend. Wir haben ja das Backend von schon einem bestehenden Spiel neu geschrieben. Dann gab es da so einen Namen, also das einer hieß Timer Boost und das andere hieß Add Timer Boost. Im Client heißt das eine More Timer Boost und das andere Golden Time Boost. Und die Referenz, also es gibt irgendwo eine Erklärung, was was ist, aber im alten Backend war es über Kreuz implementiert, also einmal verdreht. Wir hatten es halt richtig gemacht. Das iPhone Klein hat das eigentlich richtig gemacht, so wie es halt auch dokumentiert war. Und der neue Flash Klein hat es richtig gemacht, aber es hat am Ende halt nicht so funktioniert wie das alte Backend. Das muss natürlich so funktionieren, als alte Backend, der alte Flash Klein. Dann haben wir eine Stunde lang versucht, diese Namenskonfusion aufzudröseln, weil es in der Datenbank dann nochmal anders hieß mit den gleichen Worten. Und ich sagte dir, nenn deine Dinge irgendwie klar und eindeutig und unverwechselbar, dann hast du den ganzen Arsch weniger Probleme. Aber Tim spielt schon wieder sein iPhone leer. Ohne Kabel, da sind wir auch gleich.
Dein Akku ist unter 100 Prozent!
Aber dann kann ich ja noch kurz die Pause nutzen, weil irgendwie ganz viele Leute ja ganz aufgeregt waren, ihr wahrscheinlich auch. Ihr wollt ja unbedingt wissen, bestimmt wie meine Gitarrenschrauberei ausgegangen ist.
Total, ich will mal noch jemand was zu trinken.
Ich hab doch meine Gitarre aufgeschraubt.
Du hast deine Gitarre gepimpt mit irgendwelchen neuen Abnehmern oder und so weiter.
Genau, also letztes Mal hab ich mir, glaube ich, von Plan erzählt, dann kamen sie ja an und dann hab ich irgendwie angefangen, meine Gitarre auseinanderzuschrauben, war erstmal total schockiert.
Ach stimmt, du hast gesagt, die kamen an, aber an dem Abend hat sie keine Lust mehr. Genau. Und alle dachten sich, was ist das für ein Nerd?
Na nee, die kamen an, dann musste ich erst mal podcasten. Das war das Problem quasi. Und ich hab's dann nicht noch abends nachts gemacht. Das stimmt wohl. Jetzt hab ich's gemacht. War halt auch total das Gitto in dieser Gitarre. Also alles so total schnodderig zusammengelötet. Also ich war auch kurz davor, da wirkte ich noch mal einmal kurz zu sagen, ach fuck it, ich mach's ganz neu. Andererseits wollte ich ja auch bald wieder Gitarre spielen, dann hab ich mich doch wieder zusammengenommen und es dann nur mit den Abnehmern belassen. Und es hat funktioniert. Und ich hab ja vorher mit dem Rechner aufgenommen, so ein paar Akkorde gespielt, um dann zu gucken, was der Unterschied ist, wenn ich jetzt die neuen Pickups reinbaue. Und ich sehe da irgendwie, der Pegel, der rauskam, doppelt so groß. Also quasi vorher war 0,5, danach war es 1,0. Also ich hab ja meine... Also...
Die Einheit?
Du siehst ja den Pegel, was weiß ich, wer der Pegel ist. Aber du siehst halt die Balken da hoch und runter tanzen, oder du siehst das Spektrum im Audio-Player. Und ich hab meine Gitarre immer auf vollem Volumen gehabt. Dann hatte ich die auf vollem Volumen, dann war sie doppelt so laut quasi. Ja, im Prinzip schon lautstärke, ja. Also, oder Pegel halt. Und... Also war schon mal krasser Unterschied sozusagen, und die klingen tatsächlich auch... Besser, na. Also das war schon mal voller Erfolg. Ich kann sozusagen jedem, der eine billige Klampfe hat, die scheiße klingt, empfehlen, sich mal ordentliche Pickups zu kaufen.
Und... Ist es immer noch billiger als eine teure?
Jaja, auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Also ich hab natürlich das jetzt auch... Also nee, nicht natürlich, bin ja blockfaul, aber ich hab's mal geblockt jetzt alles. Also könnt ihr hier in meinem Blog auch nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher sehen. Da gibt's auch ein Bild, wie die Gitarre offen ist. Und für den Bastler in Dennis, dann muss jetzt Tim gleich mal kurz nochmal klicken. Weil, warte, das Coole war halt, ich wusste ja nicht, wie man das zusammenlötet so richtig. Und es gibt zwar so einen Guide auf Thomann, wie man Pickups austauscht, aber das ist bei jeder Gitarre so ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Und da gibt's einen Hersteller für Pickups, seymourduncan.com ist so ein ganz populärer Third-Party-Hersteller, ist halt so ein Opa aus den USA, der mit ganz viel Liebe diese Abnehmer selber bastelt. Und da gibt's für jede erdenkliche Gitarrenkonfiguration die Schemen, also die Circuit Schema sozusagen. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, ich hab zwei Tonabnehmer, ein Volume Knopf, zwei Tonregler und so weiter. Und du kriegst ein passendes Diagramm dazu. Dann gibt's die mit 5-Wege-Schalter, mit 3-Wege, mit 2-Wege-Schalter und auf der Webseite, wenn man sich also neue Pickups kauft, deine Gitarre aufschraubt, denkt, oh Gott, oh Gott, dann kann man bei simoduncan.com sich das passende Schema dann zum Reinlöten aufrufen. Voll cool! Und wenn ihr euch einfach Pickups kauft und denkt, ey, ich schraubt jetzt einfach auf eine Latte aus dem Baumarkt und probiere mal selber eine Gitarre zu bauen, dann könnt ihr im Prinzip auch damit sozusagen rausfinden, wie ihr die verdrahten müsst und wie ihr die an die Potis anschließen müsst, um Volume und Ton regeln zu können. Also das war eine der schönen Entdeckungen im Netz.
Wenn es mit dem Internet und Computern alles nicht mehr wird, bauen wir eine Gitarre, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, das ist voll das geile Nerd-Thema. Da kann man so viel dran machen. Gitarre-Schrauben war auf jeden Fall schon mal voller Erfolg. Und ich hab natürlich in meinem kleinen, weil das mit den Pickups und so, ich hab mir auch noch einen neuen Verstärker gekauft, weil ich war so in dem, ich lern jetzt wieder Gitarre und dann mach ich erst mal so ein Gadget-Kaufrausch, erst so den neuen Tuner, dann die neuen Pickups, dann noch einen neuen Verstärker dazu. Wie gesagt, alles im Blog referenziert. Das hat mich irgendwie erst mal wieder voll nach vorne gebracht. Und dann eben diese Webseite, die ich meinte vorhin, ich hab's nicht erwähnt, wie heißt das? jamplay.com heißen die. Und das ist echt ganz cool, das ist so Gitarre lernen so ein bisschen 21. Jahrhundert mäßig, weil ich hatte immer das Problem, ich hatte immer einen Gitarrenlehrer, aber da war das immer so, okay, einmal die Woche treffen für eine Stunde und ich hatte zum Beispiel ganz oft, hat es mir nicht gepasst an dem Tag, oder die Stunde war einfach viel zu wenig. Ja, und dann irgendwie so sagt er ja, du der nächste kommt gleich, muss jetzt mal los und so. Und das hat irgendwie nicht so in meinen Plan gepasst. Und da ist es so, die haben halt echt viele Lehrer und tausende Videos und dann ist es so, es gibt halt Phase 1, die Basics, und wenn dir der eine Lehrer nicht passt, dann gibt es noch 10 andere, die auch die Basics unterrichten. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen auch, wenn du mit einem besonderen, mit einem Typ, oder mit einem Typ Lehrer oder mit einem Typ Unterricht nicht klarkommst, hast du immer noch 10 andere Varianten von dem gleichen Material quasi. Und das ist echt total super. Und wenn du halt so ein richtiger Lernleut bist, dann guckst du dir trotzdem einfach alle an, weil die es natürlich alle ein bisschen was anderes auch trotzdem erklären oder auf andere Art und Weise. Und kriegst dann halt irgendwie so alle Tricks und Kniffe irgendwie so mit.
Also sind Videoaufzeichnungen?
Die sind auch in HD, also so richtig schicke Qualität. Sie haben auch immer Supplementary Material, also so ein bisschen Noten und alles, was sie da so spielen. Geht wie gesagt auch auf dem iPad praktischerweise. Und sie haben auch Live-Sessions, also eigentlich zu jeder Tageszeit, wenn ich da reingucke, ist auch gerade einer am Webcasten und am Chatten, und du kannst denen auch noch Fragen stellen und so. Und das Ding kostet halt 15, also es gibt eine Trial und das kostet 15 Dollar im Monat und du kannst einfach beliebig viele Videos angucken. Also ich hab da bestimmt schon gigabit... Und dann Phase 2 ist halt so verschiedene Styles. Und dann geht's halt so los mit Blues, Rock, Surf, was auch immer. Und Phase 3, das interessiert dich vielleicht sogar auch ein kleines bisschen, da geht's dann um Recording und Studio-Technik zum Teil auch. Also sie erzählen ja zum Beispiel auch, wie man eine Gitarre, eine E-Gitarre ordentlich aufnimmt. Wo man das Mikro vor den Verstärker hält, wie man den Sweetspot vor dem Lautsprecher findet für das Mikro, wann man einen Kondensator, wenn man ein dynamisches Mikro nimmt. So ein bisschen Recording-Basics. Also das ist so richtig einmal komplette Breitseite zum Thema, ja. Und das fand ich schon auch echt ganz cool.
Geiles Business-Modell.
Ja, und das gab es halt vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht. Es gab immer die ganze Zeit diese schlechten YouTube-Videos. Und dann dachte ich mir halt jetzt eben, als ich in diesem kleinen Gadget-Gitarn-Kaufrausch war, vielleicht gibt es auch mittlerweile mal eine ordentliche Seite, wo man sowas machen kann. Es gibt auch noch eine andere, die heißt gitartricks.com. Aber irgendwie fand ich die vom Preis-Leistungsverhältnis einfach erstmal total mega super awesome. Ich pack auch mal hier noch den Link zum Blogpost in den Chat, da könnt ihr auch noch mal genauer nachlesen, was ich da eigentlich angestellt habe und wie meine Gitarre aussieht und was für einen Verstärker ich hab.
Hat eigentlich mal jemand bei der Garageband, gab es auch mal eine Zeit lang diese Videos, diese Lernvideos?
Ja, die habe ich mir auch alle angeguckt. Aber da hatte ich tatsächlich zum Beispiel das Problem, dass der Typ und sein Style, wie er das so erzählt hat, das war mir so schnarchig. Das war so super, super, super... Ich weiß nicht, es hat mir zu lange gedauert.
YouTube ist ja voll mit so Videos, wo so Leute Farbölmischungen da in so einen Topf reingeben und dann so ihre Gitarren da einmal kurz reintunken und wieder raus und dann so super spacige, oily Formen dabei rauskommen. Ich weiß gerade nicht, wonach man suchen muss.
Das würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, denn ich hab ja so eine ganz billige Gitarre. Aha, Youporn kommt hier gleich als Autos und Chests.
Na ja, das war bei NSFW ganz vorne.
Wollen wir uns das hier auch nochmal angucken?
Rein betriebene, rein geschäftlich.
Ich hab ja so eine billige Gitarre und bin ja am Flättersparen für eine neue quasi. Und da gibt es halt zum Beispiel welche, die noch gar keinen Lack haben, so wie die da unten, dieses fünfte Ergebnis, die halt nur gebeizt sind und das heißt, wenn du die dann selber noch so ein bisschen irgendwie... Ja, ey, Flättersparen, das dauert noch eine Weile. Aber ich meine, das ist jetzt cool auch mit den neuen Pickups, so ist es nicht. Tja, Oili, Gitarre gibt es nicht so schnell, ne?
Ich muss mal gucken, ich müsste das eigentlich auch irgendwo in meiner Historie haben.
Vielleicht war es doch bei Youporn.
Kann natürlich sein.
Dass man den geilen öligen Gitarren bestimmt.
Ja, geile ölige Gitarren, die sind jetzt bereit. Auf dieser Line. Ich guck ja allen möglichen Scheiß, aber irgendwie war ich da unheimlich.
Drogen nehmen und rumfahren, aha.
Ja, müsst ihr selber mal suchen. Ich finde das auch noch irgendwie wieder.
Zum Thema Gitarren-Update. Dann auch eine richtig große News für... Aber ich habe noch eine richtig große News für euch. Online Banking-Applikationsnutzer. Denn eine neue Version von Outbank ist rausgekommen, die jetzt auch reichhaltige, mannifaltige Exportoptionen anbietet soll.
Ach, tut. Sogar mit einem ganz coolen User-Interface. Schau mal, so sieht das aus.
Da kommt dann irgendwie einfach ein bisschen gelbe Farbe hier, ein bisschen da.
Herr Prittler, wir sind hier in einem Podcast. Das kann niemand sehen. So sieht das aus, das hilft nichts.
Hab ich ja gerade gesagt, da wird die gelbe Farbe jetzt hier irgendwie so dezent an so manche Punkte da, diese Wassergeschichte, Wasser-Öl-Mischung, keine Ahnung, was da wirklich drin ist.
Okay, das sieht ja schon mal schwer ölig aus auf jeden Fall.
Und dann mit so einem Stäbschen wird das Ganze so ein bisschen in Form und Position irgendwie gebracht. Dann wird einfach nur noch der nackte Gitarrenkörper genommen.
In das Öl getaucht.
In das Massageöl.
In das Öl eingeführt.
Ich kann das jetzt hier gerade nicht so richtig beschleunigen, aber ein bisschen so blub.
So, und dann nimmt man hier so die Gitarre dann einfach den Korpus da so rein und taucht den so ganz langsam nach unten, so ohne zu zucken, quasi so in einem konstanten Gang.
Das ist ja eine Sauerei, also weil dann ist ja auch der ganze Innenraum, wo du nachher die Pickups und so reinschraubst, erstmal so komplett ölig.
Ja, da gibt es jetzt keine Alternative. So, und wenn dann die Gitarre ganz versenkt ist, schwenkst du es so ein bisschen hin und her, damit dann die Farbe irgendwie...
Das sieht ja scharf aus.
Wahrscheinlich, damit die Farbe oben aus dem Weg ist. Und schon hat man eine hässliche Gitarre. Geil!
Ich habe auch schönere Varianten gesehen. Da gibt es irgendwie tonnenweise. Aber du hast halt sozusagen nur eine Versuche.
Und vor allem kann man das ja auch nicht nur mit Gitarren machen, sondern auch mit allem anderem Scheiß. Fahrradrahmen oder... Oder Pizzas.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es das iPhone 5 mit 12 Painting-Katzen.
So, Dennis, was ist bei dir so in ZFS-Land passiert? Netatalk...
Netatalk gibt es wieder mal eine große Schweinerei.
Die nächste große Netatalk-Schweinerei.
Es gibt ja diese Version 3.0.
Was ist denn diese Woche bei Netatalk?
Das haben wir von ihm berichtet und der Frank Lahm, der das macht, hat aber irgendwie noch einen Bug. Deswegen geht es unter Freebies den nicht. Und für seine NAS-Kunden, an denen er Support verkauft, da gibt es auch Netatalk P1, P2, also Patchlevel bis Patchlevel 4 und da sind die Bugs auch gefixt. Und weil es GPL ist, wird da seinen Kunden, denen er das verkauft, auch irgendwie den Sourcecode drüber schieben. Aber ansonsten tut er diesen Sourcecode nicht raus und deswegen gibt es wohl irgendwie Netatalk, Patchlevel 4 nicht einfach so im Sourcecode. Und ich finde das für eine Open Source Software eine ganz schöne Schwennerei. Aber es ist wohl rechtens, weil die GPL sagt, du musst den Kunden oder den Leuten, denen du das Binary gibst, auch den Source geben. Da er mir kein Binary gegeben hat, muss er mir auch keinen Source geben. Das ist aber ein bisschen scheiße, finde ich. So ist es.
Was kostet denn die Zahlversion?
Ja, das ist halt für Nassese, für irgendwelche dicken Kunden, keine Ahnung, für die 1000 Euro, die da bezahlen. Na, ich finde es trotzdem ein bisschen arschig, wenn man sich dann überlegt, dass man selber dann auch ab und zu irgendwie da, na nicht Patches, aber kleine Sachen hinschickt. Also ich jetzt nur eine einzige ganz kleine, aber andere bestimmt und dann irgendwie das aber nicht, weiß nicht, ordentlich released wird.
Das stimmt.
Find ich das halt schon ein bisschen...
Geht der denn damit halbwegs offen um oder?
Ja, der hat das ja letztes Jahr schon mal gemacht. Da brauchte man das neue Netatalk, die neueste Version, die mit Leihen halt funktioniert hat. Sonst ging das irgendwie nicht. Und das hat auch nur an die NAS-Kunden irgendwie gegeben.
Ach, das hat er doch gemacht, um die NAS-Kunden dazu zu...
Ja, weil die halt, weil es halt Open Source ist, immer nur genommen haben und benutzt haben. Und der hat kein Fennich gesehen, weil es ist halt Open Source. So, dann hat er es halt irgendwie eingeschränkt und den Source nicht mehr rausgerückt, damit die mal bezahlen. Und dann gab es aber auch Riesenaufschrei. Und dann hat er am Ende irgendwie mal einmal auf GitHub geschoben oder einem Typen den Source geschickt. Und der hat es dann auf GitHub gestellt. Aber jetzt läuft es mehr oder weniger schon wieder so. Wenn ich es nicht gefunden habe, dann macht das einem nicht gerade leicht, dass man diesen Source findet. Und ich finde, da macht Open Source keinen Spaß mehr. Also, ich finde das scheiße.
Ist ja nicht Open Source dann.
Ja, nicht mehr sollte ich. Aber laut, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, laut GPL, wie gesagt, ist es rechtens, er muss nur den Leuten, denen er irgendwie das binary verkauft, auch den passenden Source dazu geben. Also er kann das so machen.
Und die dürfen ihn aber auch frei weitergeben?
Die dürfen ihn frei weitergeben, ja. Aber ich müsste jetzt irgendwie so Buden anschreiben. Ich kenne sogar einen, der bei so einer Bude arbeitet und müsste ihm sagen, ey du, rück mal raus hier.
Da fragt man halt hier so im...
Und dann könnte ich es auch releasen gleich sofort. Also so gesehen ist jetzt der Aufruf. Ich weiß nicht, ob mein Kumpel jetzt dazu hört, hier aus Hamburg, ne? Also hier, mach mal. Schieb mal Netatalk 3.0 Patch Level 4 bitte raus. Oder mindestens drei, weil da ist der FreeBSD-Patch mit drin. Weil sonst kriegen wir alle nicht das neue Netatalk, wo Support drin ist, dass diese Scheiß-Punkt-Apple-Double-Dateien, die fallen nämlich jetzt weg bei dem Netatalk 3.0. Die störten ja schon seit 20 Jahren oder wie lange? Oder schon immer? Seit Menschengedenken eigentlich nerven sich die Leute dran an diese Apple-Double-Dateien. Und die fallen jetzt weg. Und wir haben nichts von, weil wir haben es nicht. Und das geht mal gar nicht.
Wir prangern das an.
In diesem Zusammenhang, wo wir gerade bei Unix-Dateilsystem sind, ich hab jetzt auch mal mein erstes ZFS-Filesystem selber, eingerichtet. Hat gerade mal so eine Platte frei, die mir gerade so gestorben ist. Also wo mal wieder das HFS so richtig schön gewonnen hat. So eine Backup-Platte, wo so das Time Machine jetzt so regelmäßig drauf rumgerödelt hat. So eine 640 Gigabyte-Platte. Damals noch aus einem Mac Pro, so eine Original-Platte.
Also jetzt auch keinen Scheiß. Doch.
Also wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall keinen Firmware-Konflikt, der jetzt irgendwie noch da mitspielen könnte.
Ich glaub, die Zeiten sind vorbei, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich auch. Ist ja auch egal. So wie auch immer, die hatte ich jetzt noch so über. Da dachte ich mir so, okay. Also die hat sich dann erstmal mit Fehlern gemeldet. So und dann bin ich so mit Disc-Utility rübergegangen, hab gesagt Repair und danach war es irgendwie erst mal so kaputt, dass das gar nicht mehr mounten konnte.
Das HFS jetzt.
Das HFS, genau. So ging das dann irgendwie hin und her. Dann hab ich es noch dreimal repairt und dann konnte das irgendwann mal auch kurz mounten. Und dann hatte ich dann auch wie alle Daten weg, war jetzt nicht so schlimm, weil es war eh nur das Backup und das Original war ja noch live. Aber man hat ja auch gerne diese Historie dann manchmal. So und dann hab ich halt mal hier Cevo genommen, installiert.
Und schon war die Platte wieder sauber und nichts mehr drauf.
Ja, aber was halt cool war, irgendwie kaum war dieses Fallsystem drauf. Ich hab dann mal angefangen, mal Daten drauf zu kopieren. Da kam dann halt zwischendurch so irgendwie so eine Growl-Notification hoch. Ah ja, übrigens, da war jetzt grad ein Check, so ein Fehler. Ja, ich mein, die Platte hat wohl irgendwie einen Schuss.
Ja, aber du wolltest es mal wissen.
Ja, aber das ZFS merkt das wenigstens. Ja, das ist irgendwie so das Ding so. Du kopierst da Daten drauf und so. Ich mein, das OS hat jetzt nicht groß gemeckert oder so. Hat das irgendwie draufgeschrieben und so. Aber ich kann zumindest davon ausgehen, dass dieses Dateilsystem das auch gemerkt hat. Ich hab dann irgendwie nicht so richtig, ich hab dann so irgendwo im Konsol-Log auch diesen Hinweis gefunden. Nur so jetzt so eine richtige Erklärung, was da jetzt war und wo das war und was das jetzt konkret bedeutet und welche Maßnahmen er dann in dem Moment ergriffen hat. Die hab ich jetzt nicht gefunden.
Na, wenn es nur eine Platte war, kann er ja keine Maßnahmen mehr ergreifen, weil du hast keine relevanten Daten. Also sind die kaputt und dann war's das.
Ja, aber beim Schreiben?
Beim Schreiben checkt er nicht, ob es angekommen ist. Das würde zu viel Performance kosten. Das macht das ZFS nicht. Gibt es auch keine Optionen für oder irgendwie so. Sondern es gibt nur das Scrub-Commando, damit kann man der ganzen Platte oder dem Pool sagen, wie auch immer, dass er nochmal das durchchecken soll, ob alles okay ist. Aber du kannst nicht nach dem Schreiben nochmal testen, ob es wirklich angekommen ist. Das Feature gibt es nicht.
Okay, für mich wäre es auf jeden Fall mal hilfreich gewesen, zu wissen, welche Datei hat das jetzt betroffen? Was ist die Konsequenz davon?
Das ist ja leider nur die Silver-Version rausgekommen von dem Cevo. Da sollten ja eventuell noch bessere Versionen rauskommen, wo sie sowas vielleicht angeboten hätten. Aber ansonsten muss man da natürlich wieder ins Terminal gehen. Und dann macht man Zpool Status minus V. Und dann müssten unten die Dateien angezeigt werden, die kaputt sind. Ansonsten, wenn man nur Zpool Status macht, dann sagt er einfach nur, wie viele Checks und Errors und wie viele Hardware Errors oder was auch immer da so kommen. Und dann sieht man nur die Zahl an sich. Und manchmal sind ja auch, wenn du nur eine Platte hast, also Metadaten werden ja doch redundant geschrieben bei einem Zpool, dann manchmal kann sie es fixen. Wenn es aber deine Daten direkt betrifft, dann ist da nichts mehr zu retten.
Also hier steht No known data errors.
Ja, da ist ja auch alles, wie ich sehe, okay. Das kann nicht die Platte sein.
Das ist die Platte.
Ja, aber das ist alles okay.
Ja, was soll ich dir sagen?
Die sagt ab und zu, dass da was nicht gelesen werden konnte?
Nee, es war einfach, während ich da draufschrieb, kam dann halt irgendwann...
Ach so, beim Schreiben schon hast du... Okay, dann schreibt er die kaputten Sachen jetzt gar nicht. Das kommt nicht mal an sozusagen.
Naja, eben, vielleicht hat er sich dann einfach gleich einen anderen... Ach so, meinst du, er überprüft nicht beim Schreiben? Ich weiß es nicht, ich kann es nicht beantworten.
Na, er will schreiben, die Platte sagt, ne, ist nicht. Und dann hast du natürlich auch keine Fehler drauf, weil die Daten gar nicht erst geschrieben wurden.
Aber die Daten sind drauf.
Ja, dann, dann mach doch mal Z-Pool, Scrap und dann, wie heißt denn dein Ding da, Dein Pool, The Freak Show, wie, mit Leerzeichen? Dein Pool heißt mit Leerzeichen, ja? Du bist aber auch echt hart am Nehmen, ne?
Naja, wenn, dann richtig.
Also ich hab da so eine Regel, im Finder baller ich ihm alles vor die Füße, was geht, mir ist egal, die haben sich zu kümmern. Aber im Terminal mach ich alles ohne Spaces, weil du hast nachher auch den Ärger, musst alles in Anführungszeichen machen.
Was soll ich ihm jetzt sagen? Den Pool als Pfad angeben, oder was?
Nein, den Poolname gibt man immer ohne. Also du gibst nur den Namen an jetzt.
Okay.
Und nur den Namen heißt in deinem Fall jetzt, eigentlich, ich hab's noch nie gemacht mit...
So, Scrap einfach. Und jetzt?
Jetzt machen wir Z-Pool Status. Dann müsstest du sehen, dass er sich jetzt da durcharbeitet, genau. Ist er schon fertig?
Ist ja nicht groß.
Also 146, ja ist schon fertig. Er hat nichts gefunden, genau.
Und wer dachte, dass unser Gespräch noch langweiliger werden könnte?
Jetzt ist sozusagen alles super. Ich werd damit mal ein bisschen dran...
Spiel aber ein bisschen was dran.
Wir können ja in der Zwischenzeit ein paar News vielleicht aus app.net erzählen.
News aus app.net!
Na wieso? Da geht's voran.
Da gibt's jetzt schon mehr Kleidens für als für Twitter.
Von instantrimshot.com eine sehr nützliche Webseite.
Nachdem ich mir letztes Mal so massiv vorwerfen lassen musste, dass ich ja nur negativ sei, hab ich mir jetzt auch so einen Scheiß-Account gekauft. Flattert mich mal ordentlich dafür, damit ich auch mal jemand, der so ein bisschen not so bad ist...
Wenn er mich flattert, kaufe ich mir auch so einen Account. Und wenn er mich nochmal flattert, dann hör ich auch auf dort Scheiße zu schreiben.
Bist du da auch 3-4-3-Max?
Genau. Ich bin der, der dir die ganze Zeit über app.net schimpft.
Naja, muss er jetzt auch. Du hast dich ja festgelegt. Du kannst ja jetzt nicht deine Meinung ändern.
Und seien wir ehrlich, es gibt auch wirklich keinen Grund dazu.
Was?
Seine Meinung zu ändern.
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Dann würde man ja... Guck mal, das ist ja schon 64 voll, weil da geht ja richtig was ab.
Ich hab schon 165. Der frühe Vogel fängt den Wurm und wie Pavel dann meinte, das heißt auf jeden Fall, dass der Wurm besser im Bett bleiben sollte.
Kennst du auch den anderen Spruch? Die zweite Maus fängt den Käse.
Auf jeden Fall kann man jetzt nicht... Das ist nicht so geil.
Das muss nicht immer der erste sein. Manchmal ist zweiter besser.
Der erste ist in der Falle.
Es gibt auch schon den ersten...
Aber das ist ja in der Praxis dann meistens auch so.
Es gibt den ersten iOS-Client auch dafür schon.
Ja, der ist aber wirklich unerträglich, oder? Ich bin gleich noch ein bisschen positiv.
Das ist bestimmt voll super.
Es gibt immerhin schon mal einen. Es gibt auch irgendwie Integration in diese Buffergeschichte, die ich noch nicht so richtig ganz verstanden habe. Aber das ist auch irgendwie so ein Bookmarking-Abspeicher-Merk-Dienst.
Also ich finde, wenn man hier schon 100 Dollar ausgibt für so Accounts bei einem Twitter-Klient. Dann kann man auch noch die 100 Dollar für einen Apple-Developer-Account in die Hand nehmen und sich App installieren. Der ist nämlich wesentlich besser. Also der ist nicht gut, aber der ist besser als dieses Reno irgendwas Ding.
Genau, Reno heißt das so was.
Also der App geht so halbwegs. Da muss man sich halt den Quellcode auschecken. Ist eigentlich auch gar nicht kompliziert. Also könnt ihr auch mal im Simulator ausprobieren, weil da braucht man ja auch nichts für Zahlen. Da legt man sich einfach Xcode runter im App Store und checkt das Github-Repository aus. Dann kann man es immerhin mal im Simulator probieren. Und wenn einem das dann gefällt und wenn man das alles hinbekommen hat, dann kann man noch die nächste Stufe machen und sich so einen Apple-Developer-Account kaufen.
Folgisch mal dem Max hier. Mal gucken, wie seine Rante rein... Aber man kann so mit 256 Zeichen ranten.
256, das ist so... Das fühlt sich irgendwie schon ein bisschen merkwürdig an, oder?
Gibt es irgendwo eine Information, wie viele User da mittlerweile drauf sind?
Gab es nicht diese Stats da von letztem Mal?
App.net-Status?
Ja, die sagen ja nicht, wie viele es insgesamt gibt, sondern immer nur wie viel... Ja, wie hieß denn das? App.net-Stats, ne?.com Ja, genau.
Muss auch erstmal laden.
6,8 Kilo Posts Today.
Ich glaube, da erinnert sich nicht wahnsinnig viel so im Laufe der Zeit. Aber so längerfristige Statistiken gibt's da nicht, oder? Es gibt immer nur so über den Tag. Ich weiß nicht, dass wir nicht mal die Entwicklung von dem Dienstag gucken können. Also ich verstehe immer noch nicht, was das jetzt eigentlich genau sein soll.
Es ist ein Ort, an dem Developer sich Apps für diese Plattform ausdenken.
Für Twitter-Client-Kopie. Also bisher sehen die alle aus wie Twitter.
Für eine Social-Media-Plattform.
Na ja, die kurze Tweetsart und Follower.
Natürlich sieht das jetzt erstmal alles aus wie Twitter. Das ist natürlich das, was alle wollen. Etwas, was ist wie Twitter. Microblogging hat einfach gewonnen. Das ist irgendwie die Art der Kommunikation, die einfach alles, das würde ich nicht sagen. Mir würden jetzt schon 1000 Features für Twitter einfallen, die halt Twitter jetzt nicht einbauen will. Weil das ist vielleicht ja auch schon getan. Und die könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass die eben hier kommen.
Aber wenn es eine Plattform für Entwickler ist, warum bieten sie einen Internvener-Account an?
Das sind die Leute, die die Idee fördern. Man nennt das Crowdfunding.
Und warum drückt man da nicht einfach allen einen Developer-Account in die Hand?
Weil sie halt auch diesen expliziten Support wollen von Leuten, die auch an ein Modell glauben, was Nutzer finanziert ist. Und das kannst du natürlich nur dadurch erreichen, dass du diesen Nutzer in dem Moment auch finanzieren lässt. Und würden sie jetzt eine Million Leute, die irgendeinem bekloppten Hype folgen, auf diese Plattform lassen, dann wäre die wahrscheinlich innerhalb von wenigen Minuten komplett down und würde irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr funktionieren.
Die muss man halt langsam wachsen lassen.
Also kostenlos können sie es ja nicht machen. Das war wirklich das einzige Versprechen, was sie gegeben haben, dass sie sagen, kostenlos geht nicht. Das ist ja die Basis, auf dem das Ganze passiert. Kostenlos darf nicht sein, weil dann bist du das Produkt. Das ist ja das Versprechen, mit denen an den Markt gegangen ist.
Das Versprechen ist, dass sie ein Modell haben wollen, was sich nicht von Werbung finanziert. Das ist das Versprechen, was sie abgegeben haben.
Aber die Sache ist ja, wenn sie halt sagen, ok, Developer-Accounts sollen halt schon langfristig eher teurer sein als normale User-Accounts, dann ist es ja schon schlauer, das gleich von Anfang anzumachen, als hinterher zu sagen, ja pass auf, erstmal zahlt ja alle nur 50 Dollar und hinterher kosten die Developer. Also teurer machen, nachhinein ist immer blöder, als im Nachhinein noch mal billiger machen.
Ja, billiger geht immer und vor allem...
Ich finde, teurer geht auch immer. Also ich meine, man kann, wenn man zuerst sagt, die Early Adapter kriegen es billiger und danach wird es teurer, finde ich, ist absolut gerechtfertigt. Also wärst du halt früher dabei gewesen. Hier Pinboard, das gesamte Geschäftsmodell basiert ja darauf. Also da ist ja der Preis bestimmt sich hier nur darüber, je früher da dran bist, dass du billiger kriegst das. Und der Preis steigt mit jedem Verkauf.
Ja, ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir da noch keinen Account geholt habe.
Ja, war schon spät dran.
Nein, das heißt einfach so eine Plattform, wo andere Leute dann halt irgendwann sich es nicht mehr leisten werden, da zuzukommen.
Also du trittst lieber zurück, damit nachher jemand anders das ein Zeitbilliger kriegt.
Nee, mich hat das einfach nicht interessiert. Aber an Pinboard finde ich was anderes geil.
Also ich finde, es ist relativ wenig los. Jetzt wird mir immer vorgeworfen, dass ich ja nur den falschen Leuten followe, wobei ich dann auch wenn ich frage, wem kann man denn so followen und so und gibt doch mal Tipps, werden einem Tipps gegeben, aber das ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr developmentlastig. Wobei jetzt dann...
Oh, welch Wunder, es ist eine Developer-Plattform.
Naja, ich finde schon, dass so eine Plattform... Irgendwo müssen sie ja mal sich hin entwickeln. Irgendwann müssen sie ja mal sagen, wir sind jetzt, jetzt lassen wir andere Leute rein. Oder wir wollen hier interessante Leute haben und nicht nur ein paar tausend Nerds, die die ganze Zeit darüber schimpfen, dass ihre Programme abstürzen, in denen sie gerade basteln. Und ich finde, damit sollte man frühzeitig anfangen. Also entweder man macht, man probiert ein Social-Network aufzubauen, dann sollte es halbwegs Social sein, oder man macht ein API, dann sollte man sie ausschließlich für Entwickler machen und nicht für irgendwelches dahergelaufenes Volk.
Sie bauen kein Social-Media-Network, sie bauen eine Social-Media-Network-Plattform.
Es ist gleich, dass das Plattform hinten dran hängt. Also es ist trotzdem, dann bauen sie eine API für Entwickler, dann sollen sie keine Kunden reinlassen.
Max, ich bin mir sicher, dass du mit deinem Ansatz viel mehr Erfolg haben wirst als Abnet. Deswegen geben wahrscheinlich auch so viele Leute gerade Geld aus. Ach so, der klare Beleg, dass du recht hast. Ich weiß gar nicht, was du für ein Problem hast. Da probieren jetzt Leute was aus, viele Leute wollen mit ausprobieren, finden die Idee klasse und probieren es einfach aus. So, das ist das, was da stattfindet. Es ist schwer, sich nach drei Wochen ob man auf dieser Basis eine Ökonomie schaffen kann, auf der eine Plattform ist, die offen für Developer ist. Das sollte dich doch echt interessieren. Dein komischer Twitter-Client auf dem iPad, der wird ja wahrscheinlich demnächst von Twitter verboten, weil er irgendwelchen Regulatorien nicht entspricht.
Was deutet darauf hin?
Naja, was deutet darauf hin? Indem sie dir vorschreiben, wie du einen Tweet anzuzeigen hast und wenn du in deiner App das gerne anders machen wollen würdest, musst du halt ihrem Pfad folgen und es gibt genau keine Unterscheidungsmöglichkeit von einer anderen ab, die das auch irgendwie anders machen möchte, aber nicht kann, weil dir vorgeschrieben wird, wie sie den Tweet zu malen hat. Ich meine, das ist doch nur wirklich bekloppt.
Also ich finde das, was Twitter da im Augenblick macht, nicht gut, aber bisher habe ich noch keinerlei Einschränkungen dadurch gehabt.
Ja, aber ist doch schon ein bisschen blöd, wenn du voll abhängig von denen bist. Noch interessierst du nicht, weil du nicht genug irgendwie von deinen Apps verkaufst oder was die kosten. Aber irgendwann merken sie, alles klar, der verkauft da 100.000 Dinge, alle benutzen nur dessen Software und nicht mehr unsere. Jetzt drehen wir die Daumenstrauben zu. Das ist schon immer diese blöde Abhängigkeit, ist schon ein bisschen doof.
Du kannst halt nicht mehr als vielleicht 26.000 Kunden haben und dann ist halt Schluss.
26.000?
Du darfst halt irgendwie 100.000 User-Tokens haben. Wenn ich mich da anmelde, sind schon mal 15 weg.
Ja, dann sollte man darauf achten, dass du dich nicht anmeldest.
Ja, aber es gibt auch andere Leute, die gibt es natürlich auch. Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass das jetzt wirklich diese Zahl auf 100.000 bezahlende Nutzer skaliert, sondern es sind halt weniger. Und warum sollte man in eine Plattform investieren, die einem keinerlei growth lässt?
Gut, also du hast jetzt ausführlich gesagt, warum man in Twitter nicht investieren sollte. Okay, kann man hinnehmen, kann man anders sehen. Aber das spricht doch in keiner Sekunde für app.net. Also warum, wenn man fragt, was ist eigentlich das Tolle an app.net, wieso kommt dann immer die Diskussion sofort, Twitter ist scheiße? Das war doch gar nicht die Frage.
Das ist einer der Gründe, klar, das ist der Grund, warum das Projekt gestartet wurde, weil Twitter scheiße ist und weil Facebook scheiße ist. Deswegen, das ist der Grund, warum das überhaupt losgetreten wurde. Es hat ja alles angefangen mit diesem Blogpost von dem Dalton Caldwell, als er da irgendwie bei Facebook war.
Also nicht dessen Idee ist toll, sondern andere Ideen sind scheiße und darum wird ihm Geld gegeben.
Nein, ich finde seine Idee gut, weil genau das finde ich halt, dass Twitter das auch macht. Übrigens, nachdem wir uns letztes Mal darüber unterhalten haben, hat hier irgendjemand auf Twitter eine Umfrage gestartet, nämlich dieses, wer würde für Twitter bezahlen? Der auch mal retweetet hier mit dem Movamax-Account. Da gab es irgendwie 294 Rücklaufe. Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht sonderlich repräsentativ. Und da wurde gefragt, was wärst du bezahlt, was wärst du maximal bereit für einen Twitter-Pro-Account zu zahlen? Welcher A, werbefrei wäre, B, mit beliebigen Ups benutzbar wäre und C, eine richtige Suche beinhalten würde?
Ich hab an dieser Umfrage einen Fehler entdeckt.
Einen?
Also mindestens einen, und zwar der Wesentliche, der für mich leider diese ganze Umfrage ein bisschen wertlos macht, nämlich ist die Frage, für welchen Zeitraum die überhaupt nicht stellt. Geht das jetzt für ein Jahr, für einen Monat, für einen Tag?
Ich schätze mal...
Da steht ja auch kein Preis, so gesehen ist es doch egal.
Ja doch, da stehen irgendwelche Zahlen, die man für Eurosummen halten könnte.
Ich meine mich erinnern zu können, dass der Tweet von einem Jahrespreis, also von einem Monatspreis sprach. Aber das ist eine gute Frage. Hi John, du hörst uns doch wahrscheinlich gerade zu.
Du meinst, da würden Leute 10 Euro im Monat für Twitter bezahlen?
Ja, ich habe 5 angeklickt.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen den Balken und den Prozentzahlen hinten? Ich kann das nicht, verstehe ich nicht.
Leaks. Das ist einmal als Balken und einmal als Prozentzahl dargestellt.
Aber die Prozentzahlen da hinten sind ja voll gering und der Balken ist aber der größte.
Wieso der Balken ist bei 22 Prozent und der längste Balken bei 3 Euro. Das haben 66 Leute angeklickt.
66 beim zweiten Balken. Nein, das ist alles verrutscht da, verstehe.
Die Balken und die Zahlen sind jetzt nicht auf der gleichen Höhe. Also 1 Euro pro Monat. Ich gehe jetzt mal von pro Monat aus.
Weiß aber nicht, ob die Leute, die das angeklickt haben, davon ausgegangen sind.
Bitte?
Vielleicht haben die Leute ja auch gedacht, 15 Euro im Jahr sind sie bereit auszugeben.
Ja, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen...
Das ist ja ein Problem. Wenn alle gleich sind, wäre ja gar kein Ding. Aber...
Vielleicht war das ja eine Frage ganz eindeutig drinne.
Ja, ich glaube, das...
War das die Frage?
Ich hätte jetzt schwören können, es ging um pro Monat, aber ehrlich gesagt, du hast recht, das steht hier nicht drin.
Erzähl doch mal über den Inhalt und dann kann man...
Ja, versuche ich ja die ganze Zeit. Also ein... Dollar, Euro?
Das ist doch auch egal.
Also sind Leute bereit für Währungseinheiten, für Zeiträume an Twitter zu verweisen?
Es sind.
Und nur 2% stellt diese Umfrage vor einen weiß nicht.
Oh Mann.
Wie viel würdest du denn bezahlen?
5 Euro im Monat, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken. Und ich hab überlegt, ob ich auf 10 klick. Aber da fehlt mir dann sozusagen in der Frage fehlt mir noch so ein D und ein E. Ja, so ein Sachen, die da auch noch sind. Also ich hätte in den 10 Euro würde ich halt auch noch Statistiken haben wollen. Also ich würde sozusagen so ein Pro-Account haben und ich will da natürlich auch eine richtige Auswertung von was auch immer sie da auswerten haben wollen. So ein Dashboard mit irgendwie einem möglichen Klimm Bimm, mit hier dieser Tweet, so viele Retweets, was du sonst halt über irgendwelche externen Dienste zusammen klicken und klimpern musst. Und ja, dann halt auch irgendwie so Unlimited, was weiß ich, ohne Beschränkungen, mit wieviel Tweets man halt schicken kann etc. Das war jetzt nicht so wichtig. Also ich interpretiere das jetzt einfach mal so, dass das irgendwie Euro pro Monat ist. Vielleicht stimmt das ja alles nicht, aber ich würde mal sagen, okay hier heißt es im Chat heißt es in Euro und monatlich. Okay, also ist es das wahrscheinlich? 1 Euro 16%, 2 Euro 18%, 3 Euro 22%, 5 Euro 20% und dann 10 Euro, da geht es dann runter, 3% 15 Euro 2% und nichts 16%. Ja, da kann man jetzt halten davon, was man will. Das könnte bedeuten, dass das nur die Leute geklickt haben, die unbedingt zur Kenntnis geben wollen, dass sie auch bereit werden, was zu bezahlen und den Rest hat es nicht interessiert, mit so einem Kram mitzuspielen. Aber ich glaube halt auch, dass es schon dafür einen Markt gibt. Das muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass so eine Aussage unter dem Hintergrund zu sehen ist, dass es eben Twitter ist, wo man eben auch kostenlos mitmachen kann. Und ja, da muss man mal sehen, wie das bei Abnet sich so entwickelt. Aber Spammer haben es auf jeden Fall schlecht auf der Plattform.
Dafür werden aber geknackte User-Passwörter eine Menge wert sein.
It's all about trade-offs.
Also ich finde, diese ganze, was Twitter da mit der API macht, finde ich tatsächlich auch eine ziemliche Katastrophe. Da muss ich ja leider eingestehen.
Twitter ist raus aus dem Club der coolen Kids.
Man muss aber sagen, dass Twitter an anderen Stellen nach wie vor gut ist. Und dass es so, was diese Verteidigung angeht, irgendwelche Tweets, die gelöscht sind, nicht nochmal an die Polizeibehörden oder als FBI ausliefern zu müssen.
Ja, aber ich meine, sie schmeißen jetzt irgendwie so Accounts wie diesen Twist-Account raus.
Keine Ahnung, was der Twist-Account ist.
Der Twist-Account ist ein Account, da kannst du ihm folgen und sagst ihm irgendwie, wo du bist. So, ich in Berlin. Und dann sagt er dir, übrigens, heute Abend kannst du die ISS sehen. Um dir und die Uhrzeit irgendwie, sieht prima aus. Das wirst du gut erkennen können, weil er fliegt gerade über dich rüber. So was macht Twist. Und jedem, den es interessiert, erzählt Twist ISS. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie der Status gerade ist, aber da gab es halt irgendwie die Ansage von Twitter, ja, du bist irgendwie spammy und dich wollen wir jetzt hier nicht mehr haben.
Gibt's? Vielleicht steht ja da mal ein bisschen Erklärung dazu.
Interessant. Noch gar nicht geklickert. Ja, aber ich meine, mit solchen Sachen beschäftigen sie sich halt jetzt auch. Und da frag ich mich halt ernsthaft, was sie eigentlich wollen.
Naja, ich meine, dass sie jetzt count, die tendenziell, dass sie endlich mal anfangen, was gegen Spam zu machen.
Ich meine, Leute, denen was schicken, die dem folgen.
Naja, die die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Ad-Replies zu schicken, irgendwelchen Leuten, ist nicht weit von dem entfernt, was die meisten Spambots machen. Und wenn sie da jetzt nicht den allerbesten Mechanismus für haben, dann kann das durchaus mal aussehen wie ein Spam-Account. Also insofern würde ich ihnen da jetzt nicht direkt böse Absicht unterstellen. Sondern die haben einfach gesehen, dass ein Account, der ein unglaublich hoher Rate Ad-Replies an Leute rausschickt, vielleicht ist da, das wird wohl ein Spam-Account sein. Und das wird wahrscheinlich der Methodik dafür sein im Augenblick, was jetzt nicht sonderlich gut ist. Dann haben sie halt erstmal den Account gesperrt. Das würde ich jetzt als Kollateralschaden und nicht als böse Absicht bezeichnen. Also ich finde, dass, wie gesagt, das was die API angeht, Twitter tatsächlich sich jetzt im Augenblick gerade ziemliches Ding leistet, aber in anderen Bereichen sind sie nach wie vor gut. Punkt. Und ich finde so dieses app.net, also so die Alternative dazu zu haben, okay, ich habe hier eine API, mit der ich wirklich alles machen kann, aber dafür habe ich halt zumindest im Augenblick und auf absehbare Zeit eine massiv geringere User-Basis, muss man die Entscheidung treffen, was man will. Wenn man in den Club mit den vielen Leuten oder wenn man in den Club mit der potenziell besten Soundanlage.
Ja, aber das würde auch heißen, dass ich nie wieder was anderes als Töte entwickeln könnte, weil alle natürlich erst mal klein anfangen müssen, also man muss schon noch eine Weile Zeit geben.
Ja, das stimmt auf jeden Fall, aber dadurch, dass sie Geld nehmen wollen, also das...
Manche werden sie immer klein bleiben.
Nicht zwangsläufig klein, aber kleiner als andere Dienste.
Kann auch Vorteile haben.
Ja, kann's. Also muss man halt mit diesen... Wenn man da, wenn man auf app.net mit den Usern total glücklich ist und sagt, das sind die Leute, denen ich folgen will, und sonst niemand, und dann wird's bestimmt über kurz oder lang nochmal OKEA Clients auch dafür geben, weil im Augenblick muss man auch leider sagen, ist das alles nicht doll. Also ich meine, ist alles jung und noch nicht weit und sowas, aber so tweet... Also ich würde sagen, das ist noch nicht mal am nativen McClient auf eine Ansatzweise dran, was ich da im Augenblick so sehe. Also hier, wie heißt das MoApp und was ist das andere? Appetizer finde ich beide nicht gut.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch wirklich jetzt...
Es ist drei Wochen alt.
Ja, es ist drei Wochen alt. Das haben wir jetzt oft genug gesagt. Trotzdem kann ich sagen, ich finde es im Augenblick noch nicht gut.
Ist doch noch nicht gut.
Und ob das noch was wird, wir werden sehen. Ich bin skeptisch, aber...
Ich lag Twitter nicht auf meine Party ein. Ja. Außerdem ist es natürlich eine offene Plattform, wo es auch sehr interessant wird, wenn halt so Payment mit reinkommt. Also Flatter will auch Abnet unterstützen demnächst. Sind wohl schon irgendwie dran. Und wo halt so eine Infrastruktur, die auch offen ist für Payment-Wege, könnte sich halt auch interessant entwickeln. Im Gegensatz zu Systemen, wo du halt sicher davon ausgehen kannst, dass der dann gleich so einen Zuckerberg vor der Nase sitzt und sagt irgendwie so, na meinst du nicht, dass die das auch irgendwann mal anfangen werden?
Ich meine, wenn sie feststellen, wo das Geld zu machen ist, dass sie dann einfach schwenken?
Du meine, also, weißt ja, wie das ist mit den Vorhersagen, besonders wenn sie die Zukunft betreffen. Ich sehe jetzt derzeit keinen Anlass, das jetzt als das Kernproblem anzusehen. Ich meine, sie sagen, sie bauen eine Plattform für Entwickler, die genau eben offen sein soll und genau eben diese Limitierungen nicht haben. Ich meine, du sagst jetzt, ah, die haben das vor und meinst du nicht, dass sie genau das Gegenteil von dem verfolgen? Kann ich nicht sagen, ob sie genau das Gegenteil machen.
Nee, ich sag nicht, dass sie zwangsläufig...
Twitter macht nicht unbedingt genau das Gegenteil von dem, was sie ursprünglich getan haben, aber sie machen halt bestimmte Dinge nicht. Und, äh, wo sie vorher so keine direkte Aussage zu gemacht haben und jetzt entscheiden sie sich halt, auf diesen Pfad zu gehen, was anderes zu sein, als dass sie wahrgenommen werden. Für uns ist das halt eine Kommunikationsplattform und für sie ist es halt...
Die längste Pralline der Welt.
Ähm, zum Thema Pinboard kann ich noch sagen, also auch wenn man Pinboard nicht benutzt, aber man muss echt unbedingt at Pinboard folgen. Weiß nicht, ob du das tust, aber der Typ hat echt die schärfsten Rahns. Das ist so, allein seine Tweets zu lesen, hab ich schon erwogen, irgendwie vielleicht den Dienst zu kaufen, wenn ich mal Zeit hab, mir das mal genauer anzuschauen, ob ich das noch für irgendwas gebrauchen kann.
Pinboard nutze ich den ganzen Tag über. Das ist so ein bisschen meine... Ich bin großer Freund von Ipsos Zensette. In Kombination auch gerade mit Pinboard. Also ich sammle Links für die diversen Podcasts, sammle ich Pinboard, weil eigentlich jeder Client sowohl auf dem iPad als auch auf dem iPhone als auch auf dem Mac dafür eine Integration hat. Also es gibt eine Chrome-Erweiterung. Reader hat Pinboard-Integration. Sie haben eine E-Mail-Adresse, an die man zur Not senden kann. Hier Pocket, Instapaper haben alle Pinboard-Integration. Also wann immer ich irgendwo was lese und spannend finde und hey, das könnte doch mal was sein. Tweetbot hat leider keine Pinboard-Integration. Genau, da muss ich immer die E-Mail-Adresse nehmen.
Aber was macht Pinboard genau?
Es sammelt deine Links.
Als Delicious-Klone angefangen.
Genau, hat so ein bisschen als Delicious-Klone angefangen. Ich glaube sogar die API war kompatibel. Und dann schmeißt du dann in Links rein und vertext die. Und ich habe jahrelang nicht verstanden, wofür das gut sein soll. Und das halt an einer zentralen Stelle im Netz halt von allen Clients aus zu benutzen. Das ist erstmal so ein Vorteil. Zum zweiten gibt es da sowas, das hat ja Google leider irgendwann mal gekillt beim Google Reader. Da gab es ja die Möglichkeit, dass man anderen Leuten folgt. Also was andere Leute geschert hatten, also es gab ja im Google Reader die Möglichkeit, Artikel zu scheren. Das kam dann, das konnte man dann abonnieren und konnte so die Sachen folgen, die andere spannend fanden. Das gibt es bei Pinboard sowas in der Richtung auch. Also du kannst deine Feeds public machen und dann können andere Leute die abonnieren. Dann kann man das auch als RSS-Feed abonnieren. Ich hab mir nochmal, das muss ich vielleicht nochmal veröffentlichen, so mal als Node.js-Experiment habe ich mal so einen kleinen eigenen Server gebaut, der dann noch den, also der oben die Zusammenfassung von Pinboard reinschmeißt und dann unten den Full, also den kompletten Artikel nochmal da drunter packt, sodass man das alles schön auch im iPhone lesen kann. Also es hat so ein bisschen einen Hauch von sozialen Features, dass man von anderen Leuten die Sachen abonnieren kann und in Kombination mit Ipsys, Senset kann man dann sagen, wenn ich irgendwas in Pinboard linke mit folgendem Tag, dann schmeißt das doch mal direkt in Facebook rein. Oder dann packt das in Twitter. Oder dann legt das hier noch ein Evernote-Dokument. Oder weiß der Teufel was. Und das ist eine Kombination, die so alles in allem schon echt ganz geil ist.
Und was machst du damit?
Genau.
Was um jetzt jetzt auch? Up-Net-Integration.
Hab ich gesehen. Nutz ich sogar, es ist für mich so die einzige Chance, also nutze ich hier, ich hab dieses Push-Over. Heißt doch so, oder? Diese App, mit der man sich push, also prowl mit Geschäftsmodell. Oder wie auch immer. Also dass man so Fursch-Notifications von beliebigen Apps bekommen kann. Und damit lasse ich mir meine App.net-Notifications an mein iPhone schicken. Kommt irgendwann sogar an. Also es ist leider sehr laggy. Also so dieses, wie man es von Twitter kennt, dass man eigentlich darüber chatten kann, davon ist es weit entfernt. Es sind mehrere Minuten, die vergehen, bevor man so eine Nachricht bekommt. Aber, also wenn man bereit ist, zu improvisieren, dann kann man und 100 Dollar für einen Apple-Developer-Account in die Hand nehmen, dann kann man eine OK App.net-Experience auf dem iPhone hinkriegen. Auf dem Mac finde ich es noch relativ katastrophal.
Du bist jetzt schon wieder bei app.net. Ich dachte, wir waren bei Pinboard.
Ja, ich war zwischendurch bei Pinboard, genau.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe das jetzt einfach mal, weil der so cool twittert.
Was kostet es denn gerade?
Das ist ein Typ, ne?
Das ist ein Typ, ja, ja. Der hat neulich mal getwittert, was sein neuer Server so kostet.
9,88 Dollar.
Mal gucken, ob ich meine Pinboard-Mail finde, was ich damals dafür ausgegeben habe.
Es gibt normale Accounts und Archival-Accounts.
Am 25. November 2010 hab ich meinen gekauft. Bestätigung der Zahlung. Also ich hab 6,73 Dollar bezahlt.
Das heißt, wenn man 25 Dollar im Jahr zahlt, dann speichert er einem auch noch die ganze Seite dazu ab und nicht nur den Link. Ich dachte, das macht er jetzt sowieso. Das heißt, man muss 25 Dollar zahlen.
Nee, das muss man nicht. Da kannst du auch nur die Bookmarks speichern.
Ja, aber dann weiß man ja immer nicht, was drin war, wenn es weg ist.
Das stimmt.
Das ist schon ein cooles Feature. Ich hab ja bei meinem Versuch, einen Bookmarks-Service zu schreiben, der dann durch eine neue Beschäftigung bei VUKA wieder geendet hat, hab ich ja letztendlich Screenshots gemacht.
Screenshots?
Von den Webseiten.
Wie hast du das gemacht?
Mit Phantom.js.
Ah, okay.
Das war dieses...
Das gibt's immer noch. Das wird auch fleißig weiterentwickelt.
Ja, ich hab irgendwann mal vor Ewigkeiten, also wirklich schon lange, lange Zeit, eine Lösung gesucht dafür. Und da war ich dann so weit, einen Headless-X-Server irgendwo aufzusetzen, in dem dann irgendein Browser läuft.
Mit Qt und so. Also Phantom.js ist mittlerweile, die haben auch alle meine Bugs gefixt, weil ich hab natürlich meinen Shortcut-Service dann ordentlich gegen alle möglichen URLs getestet und dann ist das halt bei manchen URLs abgekackt, weil es zu lang war und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hab ich mal nach ein paar Monaten, nachdem ich schon längst hier aufgehört hab, dran zu bauen, mal nachgeguckt, an den Bug-Tracker waren die Bugs alle gefixt und dann hab ich es nochmal ausprobiert und ja, siehe da, also der kriegte dann tatsächlich so gut wie alle Webseiten ordentlich gepasst. Man kann es auch schöne Optionen sagen, so irgendwie, ja, mach gleich hier cutten und warte noch ein paar Sekunden, dass sich auch wirklich alles aufgebaut hat, weißt du so, dass die Seite auch wirklich vollständig initialisiert ist und so, wenn sie sehr JavaScript-lastig ist und so. Und da hab ich dann quasi das so gemacht, Klicksteil hab ich hier im Bookmarklet, kommt so die URL an, dann wird da so ein Rescue, also so in der Queue ein Job gestartet, der dann mit Phantom.js einmal das abholt und auf den Web-Server legt und dann, ja, ging mir das ganz gut. Aber die ganze, also ist halt die Frage, aber der wird wahrscheinlich dann so die Seite als HTML-Web-Archiv, was auch immer, hoffentlich speichern, weil JPG, so ein Screenshot machen ist ja das eine, aber wenn du den Text dann auch so richtig schön raus kopieren, pasten und links klicken kannst und so.
Klingt ja eigentlich so, als ob das die gleiche Lösung im Wesentlichen wäre. Du brauchst ja eigentlich nur so Phantom.js nehmen und dann die Seite aufrufen und dann gucken, welche Netzwerkverbindungen kommen und die dann halt wegzuspeichern.
Also mit Phantom.js kannst du da auf jeden Fall noch einiges machen. Screenshots ist nur die eine Variante.
Wenn man eine API braucht, um Artikel wegzuspeichern, dann hab ich hier, also hab ich ewig lange gesucht. Ich hab probiert hier, also es gibt ja so diese Reader und Instapaper und so haben ja alles dieses, wir können den Artikel aus der Seite extrahieren. Und das ist ja so ein Voodoo-Zauber, weil da muss man wirklich, das ist ja nicht irgendwie leicht zu erlernen, Technik, sondern muss man mit hunderten Seiten ausprobieren und so. Und das ist ja echt viel, viel Arbeit. Und ich hatte auf keinen Fall Bock, das selber zu machen. Ich hab mir dann mal von, wie heißen sie hier gleich, die diese Couch als Icon hatten, diese Readability, die auch in Safari integriert waren. Die haben ja irgendwann mal ganz, ganz früher ihren JavaScript-Readability-Parser rausgeschmissen, der ist leider unglaublich schmerzhaft. Was ich jetzt dafür entdeckt hab, ist Diffbot, das ist ein Webdienst. Und der hat, also es gibt hier irgendwie wie viel? Bis zu 10.000 API-Calls pro Monat sind kostenlos. Bis zu 50.000 kosten 20 Dollar, also jetzt nicht die Welt. Und das ist, da schmeißt man eine URL rein und kriegt je nachdem, was man angefordert hat, entweder JSON oder XML zurück. Kann auch sagen, ja ich hätte da gerne auch Kommentare mit dabei in einem separaten Dataset. Ich hätte gern HTML mitbildern, ohne Bilder, was auch immer. Also man kriegt das Faf-Eiken der Seite, sehe ich gerade. Man kriegt noch einen Versuch der Zusammenfassung. Habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mal angeguckt, was die taucht, also wo sie dann irgendwie so eine automatische Zusammenfassung der Seite und auch auf die Beine stellen. Ist ganz geil.
Ich habe auch noch einen schönen Webservice, den ich empfehlen kann. Und zwar für alle, die so Infrastruktur betreiben und wissen wollen, was Sache ist. Da ist ja Logging so ein ganz großes Thema und jeder, der vielleicht schon mal einen Webserver hatte, der viel zu tun hatte und den Fehler gemacht hat, das Log-File auf die gleiche Maschine auf Platte zu schreiben, wird dann vielleicht festgestellt haben, dass die IO von der Kiste so ansteigt, also die IO lasst, dass dann ja die Maschine kurz vorm Stillstehen ist, weil das Schreiben auf Platte dann halt so viel Performance zieht quasi. Und ein Weg, der ganz gängig ist, um das Problem zu lösen, ist dann Syslog zu benutzen. Man setzt sich einen eigenen Logging-Host auf und schickt quasi alles Log-Material, was man so hat, einfach direkt mit UDP an die Log-Maschine weiter und die aggregiert das und schreibt das in einen Fall, sodass dein eigentlicher App-Server nicht beeinträchtigt ist. Und dann gibt es einen tollen Webservice, der heißt papertrail.com und da kannst du praktisch auch direkt von deinem App-Server oder von deinem Log-Host oder wo auch immer mit Syslog deine Log-Files alle dahin schicken. Sie haben auch einen eigenen Demon, der, falls du halt Sachen hast, die nicht nach Syslog loggen, also die einfach in einen File loggen, guckt sich der Demon das Log-File an und schiebt das nach papertrail.com.
papertrail.com ist es nicht.
Nee, warte, Paper doch, das heißt papertrailapp.com, sorry. Und die aggregieren deine Log-Files und du kannst da drin suchen, du kannst so Time-Snippets sagen, du kannst zum Beispiel ja ein User hat gesagt, gestern so gegen zwei ist bei ihm die App gecrashed, kannst du halt sagen, ok, zeig mir mal alles so um zwei Uhr rum. Aber das ist noch nicht das Coolste, sondern das Coolste ist, du kannst nach Dingen, die du suchst, diese suchen, kannst du speichern und kannst da drauf Alerts oder Events setzen. Zum Beispiel sagen wir mal, in deinem Code hast du beim Payment, wenn da ein Error beim Payment kommt, willst du rausloggen, Payment Error und ein Stack Trace oder was auch immer. Und dann kannst du eine Suche auf Payment Error machen und kannst sagen, ok, immer wenn das passiert, dann schick mir eine Mail, schick mir eine Jobber-Message, schick eine Notification auf Pager Duty, was auch immer die Welt geht, unterdrück den roten Knopf. Du kannst es nach Libratometrics schicken, das heißt, du kannst automatisch aus Lockfall-Events auch Graphen generieren. Also Libratometrics ist so ein schicker Webdienst, um Graphen für alles Mögliche an Metrics selber zu bauen, sehr schnell und effizient. Und du kannst halt direkt aus deinem Lockfall über Paper Trail eben auch für Events Graphen malen. Der Trial-Account ist auch super offenherzig, sag ich mal. Ich glaube, du kriegst 5 GB Lockfall-Storage pro Monat kostenlos. Und wenn man mit seiner App, also wenn ihr gerade irgendwas baut und ihr wollt so irgendwie Lockfall und vollen Durchblick haben, wenn ihr es schafft, in einem Monat 5 GB Lockfall zu generieren mit euren wahrscheinlich noch wenigen Usern, dann solltet ihr eure Logging-Strategie nochmal überdenken. Aber prinzipiell, also ich hab's jetzt hier in unserem Development-System und wir haben gerade 38.000 Events gelockt und irgendwo zeigen sie einem dann an, wie viel das so kosten würde. Oder wie viel ich noch frei erwarte. Ich hab 1% jetzt mit diesen 38.000 Events bisher verbraucht. Das ist jetzt Development, da sind jetzt gerade mal 200 User drauf.
Was würdest du denn empfehlen? Also ich hab ja da auch für Tabula Tapsa, ich hab mich ein bisschen auf die Suche gemacht nach, womit macht man denn eigentlich so eine schöne statistische Auswertung, dass man sieht. Also gibt's natürlich so das Nahelie- Also ich hab hier RPG, war so das erste, was ich probiert habe. Das ist unglaublich einfach, weil das ist, also das ist wirklich krass, weil man muss eigentlich nur seinen DNS-Eintrag ändern. Man lässt einfach jeglichen Traffic über die laufen. Und die suchen das dann alle nach Get und Post und Put-Request, wird das dann alles schön aufgetrennt und du kannst es dann bei denen vorne machen und brauchst dich wirklich um gar nichts zu kümmern. Du kriegst Automatical-Respense-Teils zurück. Hat den Nachteil, die können keinen HTTPS, oder jedenfalls nicht in den billigen Versionen. Und die können, wenn du ein Websocket hast, dann wissen die natürlich nicht, was das ist. So dauerhafte Verbindung. Und sie haben keine Preise auf der Webseite stehen. Ich hab mal gefragt, was würde denn euer Dienst so kosten, wenn ich was brauchen würde?
Welcher Dienst war das nochmal?
Die machen auch diese APG-Konsole. Dafür sind sie glaube ich ganz bekannt.
Na ja, ein New Relic ist halt noch so ein ganz klassischer Kandidat dafür.
Also was ich gerne hätte, wäre, ich schmeiße hier ein paar Events rein und nachher am besten mit einem schönen Clicky Bunty Interface kann ich mir dann schöne Statistiken zusammenführen.
Okay, wenn du Events rein tun willst, dann ist Liberator Matrix halt tatsächlich schon... Wie schreibt sich das? Warte, ich pack mal das hier in den Chat. Die sind auch extrem günstig. Also wir bezahlen da echt wenig und schieben da echt ganz schön viel Stuff rein. Und was du da machen kannst, ist, kannst du über eine schicke API oder mit den vorhandenen Plugins für alles Mögliche, so Ruby, PHP, was auch immer, gibts Implementationen, kannst du Events rein schicken und das werden on the fly automatisch dazu Graphen generiert. Also du musst gar nicht drüber nachdenken, okay, ich will jetzt diese Grafik haben, sondern du fängst einfach an, Events mit einem bestimmten Namen zu senden und kriegst dafür eine Matrix. Und das ist eigentlich schon mal so für... Du willst bestimmt welche Events schon mal genau richtig. Das heißt, das könnt ich schon mal empfehlen für die Sache. Und wenn du halt so profiling willst für deine Request und so weiter, dann ist halt zum Beispiel New Relic so auch so ein klassischer Kandidat. Die supporten halt nicht alle möglichen Sprachen, aber vielleicht ist was dabei. Also New Relic, die gibt's schon super lange. Die haben halt als Rails-Laden vor allen Dingen angefangen, aber die haben über die Zeit auch noch ein paar andere Sachen mit dazu genommen. Und die haben schon sehr ausführliche Reports, wie lange bestimmte Web-Actions dauern und so weiter und so fort. Und ich glaube, sie haben mittlerweile auch eine API, wo du eben auch Custom Stuff reinschieben kannst. Aber das ist so die beiden, die ich auf jeden Fall selber benutze.
Bei APG war wirklich so, ich hab die so. Ich konnte leider längst noch auf eurer Seite finden, was der Dienst kostet. Ja, lass uns doch mal telefonieren.
Ach ja, das hasse ich auch immer. Wenn die gleich so einen Skype-Call mit dir haben wollen. Ja, und wenn du jetzt irgendwie willst, die Enterprise Edition, die ist auch super.
Ich war ja ganz früher mal bei Pixel Park. Und die haben ja auch für große Bude wie Barmer und Luft, ne, Lufthansa weiß ich gar nicht, Barmer, Allianz und Zeug, irgendwie auch Webservices angeboten. Und wenn es irgendwie, glaube ich, um die Webseite selbst ging, waren die nicht so groß, wie die jetzt. Ich habe ja die Preise jetzt nicht mitbekommen, aber du hörst ja sowas der Kunde, wo er sagt, ja, nee, zu teuer und bla bla, auch wenn du die Preise nie gehört hast. Aber wenn es um die Analyse von den Logfiles ging, also damals auch, wie wenig das auch immer gewesen ist, bei den Parajusana 1998 und so weiter, wenn es um diese Analyse ging, dann haben die bezahlt, Summen ohne Ende, weil da waren die richtig geil drauf, hinter schön auswerten und wer wann klickt hat und von wo nach wo und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und das ist schon unglaublich. Also da haben die mehr ausgegeben als für die ganze Seite selbst.
Aber ich hatte mal eine Projektmanagerin, die früher bei Pixel Park war und die meinte so, ja, ja, also damals, ja, da kamen die dann halt so an und die hatten alle keine Ahnung vom Internet und dann wollten die auch so eine Webpräsenz haben und dann haben wir halt gesagt, 14 Millionen Mark und dann haben die gesagt, ach ja, ja wirklich, ja, na gut, aber wir wollen ja schon so eine Webpräsenz haben, na gut. Und im Hinterzimmer, reichten sie die Coke-Tabletten oder so? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Selbstverständlich nicht.
Nicht während ich dabei war.
Weil wir haben immer nur Minze geraucht.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie in so geringen Mengen Coke konsumiert haben.
Dass es noch auf ein Tablett gepasst hätte.
Tja, man muss nur frech sein.
Und vor allen Dingen früh dran sein, ne?
Inzwischen ist es eine ganz kleine Bude in der Bergmannstraße.
Tja, wir können ja mal hier irgendwie auch mal andere Preise aufrufen, ne?
Ja, stimmt hier. Ihr seid nur das Produkt und gar nicht die Kunden.
Ja, wie findet ihr das, hm?
Wie viel werdet ihr denn bereit, für Mobile-Maximum etwas zu geben?
Sonst gibt es nämlich hier Werbung. Den ganzen Tag.
Ich mein, wir haben jetzt gerade schon Web-Services gefeatured. Wir haben Bayreuth der Hell schon gefeatured.
Ja, ich meine, guck mal hier, wie die den Chat benutzen.
Guck mal, wie die Kaufkraft auf unserem Grafen nach oben geht hier von Hörerschaft. Tim hat ja sein Hörer-Meter in Kaufkraft-O-Meter der Hörerschaft umgestellt. Das heißt, wir sehen jetzt auch, wenn ihr auf Amazon und im Apple Store gerade klickt. Ja, aber das ist doch eine schöne Umfrage. Wie viel wären die Leute bereit, für Mobile-Max zu zahlen?
In Euro, in Monat?
Wenn wir nichts anders machen als jetzt. Einfach nur so.
Wenn wir nicht mehr ins Mikro schmeißen.
Wenn wir nicht mehr über Kalender und über Apptasken hin und her.
Das macht doch den Reiz aus.
Und einen Vader-Filter gibt es dazu.
Oh ja, das Premium-Paket. Jetzt neu mit Vader-Filter und Schmatz-Filter.
Ich glaube für den Vader, da zahlen die Leute für.
Tja, wir wissen es nicht.
Je nachdem, wer mehr zahlt, das ist vor jeder Sendung, wer mehr zusammenkriegt, wird mehr gewedert oder weniger gewedert. Man kann Themen mit Geld bewersen.
Wer Gnase zahlt, ich zahl nix.
Das ist ja eine aktuelle Behauptung, die stimmt ja so auch gerade.
In diesem Moment zahl ich gerade nix.
Er hätte ja schreiben müssen, ich werde nix zahlen für Mobile Max. Aber so, habt ihr recht?
Oh, und schon wird der Chat hier leer.
Ich verpleihe das so nicht.
Das ist bestimmt nur so ein bedauerlicher Netzblatt, der da gerade stattfindet. Es ist nicht die Ratten verlassen, das ist eben ein Schiff.
Wo bin ich gegen die Netz-Split-Taste gekommen?
Hab ich schon erzählt, dass ich gestern im Batman-Film war? Nö. Nichts boilen. Überhaupt gar nichts. Aber da brauchen die sich nicht wundern, wenn keiner mehr ins Kino geht. Warum? Na, das war so was von schlecht. Achso, nee, da lade ich meinen Movies lieber runter.
Habt ihr noch ein bisschen Süßigkeiten drin?
Nee, ich hab grad alles voll hier.
Kino find ich auch schrecklich. Ich geh auch sehr ungern ins Kino mit Leider.
Also irgendwie macht's doch bei den kleinen Filmen viel mehr Spaß. Da ist mir dann auch egal, ob der Film so gut war oder nicht so gut, weil es sind irgendwie vielleicht auch unbekannte Regisseure, Debütarbeiten und so weiter. Aber von so einem Batman-Movie, war bestimmt wieder mal der teuerste Film aller Zeiten, da erwarte ich, dass es irgendwie nicht nur auf dem Bild kracht, sondern auch in meinem Kopf. Also, dass irgendwie was passiert so emotional. Aber es kommt überhaupt, weiß ich nicht.
Du bist so abgestumpft, Dennis, mittlerweile.
Ja, das ist schlimm, oder?
Ich hab mir neulich Brave im Kino angeguckt. Da musste ich am Ende weinen.
Das ist aber echt ein süßer Film.
Das ist mit dieser rotharigen... Genau, mit dieser Pixar-Film. Den hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Pixar hab ich auch die letzte Zeit nicht so verfolgt. Rotharige Mädchen, so was mit Fantasy-Mittelalter mäßig, so mit Bogenschießen.
Mit der mega krassen Haar-Animation.
Und krassen, schottischen Akzent.
Ich dachte, der kommt erst noch.
Nein man, war schon alles.
Der ja kommt noch.
Die ist schon alle oder was? Gibt's keins mehr.
Alles ist schon weg. Auf Ebay gibt's noch für Liebhaber Preise.
Ich such dir den Link raus. Ja, ohne Heart.
Ohne Heart, das kann man sich dann wirklich mal...
Die Frage ist, kann man den Film irgendwie...
Bei Apple kannst du den bestimmt auch im iTunes Store.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der dafür schon alt genug ist. Also ich hab den...
Irgendwie gibt's den noch nicht so richtig.
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Noch keine 5 Jahre alt, dann kann man das nicht online bereitstellen. Das sind so viele Daten, die müssen die erst mal übertragen bekommen.
Aber ich glaub, der läuft noch im Kino. Den kann man sich noch gut im Kino angucken.
Haben wir ja gerade schon gesagt, Kino ist out.
Da kann man auch 3D gucken und so.
Super 3D, geil.
Wie ist es denn eigentlich... Wir sind jetzt hier schon so im miscellaneous Teil.
Wir müssen noch auf ein paar knallharte Themen kommen.
Oh, das riecht ja krass hier.
Dennis, du als alter Apple-Experte. Ihr Kommentar zum Judy-ID-Hack.
Ach so, du meinst jetzt ja nicht, das verstehe ich nicht von jeder Seite, was die da ändern, sondern jetzt diese FBI-Geschichte.
Genau, oder was auch immer. Also angeblich sind da irgendwie eine Million was auch immer, Judy-IDs. Anonymous, Anonsec, wer auch immer. Irgendeine Anonyme Security-Bande, hat also angeblich nach offiziellen Zeugenaussagen einen Laptop von irgendeinem FBI-Agenten geangelt und da waren angeblich ganz viele Apple-Judy-IDs vor 10 Millionen oder so was? Irgendwie drauf gespeichert und diese Judy-IDs ermöglichen es wohl am Ende.
Das sind nicht Apple-Judy-IDs, sondern iPhone-Judy-IDs.
Und iPad auch, die Besitzer quasi zu identifizieren und dann auch irgendwie zu tracken.
Also Judy-ID müssen wir erstmal kurz erklären für die Anfänger-Zuhörer, machen wir mal kurz. Also Judy-ID steht, glaube ich, für Unique Device Identifier. Das heißt, jedes iPhone hat so eins und jedes Programm kann sich diese geben lassen. Und das ist auch für alle Programme immer das Gleiche. Und auch wenn du dein Telefon löscht und wieder neu machst, ich glaube, dann kriegst du exakt die gleiche Judy-ID. Zumindest solange du dein Telefon so benutzt, hast du die gleiche. Das heißt, du kannst, wenn du zum Beispiel zwei Apps hast, zwei komplett unterschiedliche Apps, oder sogar zwei verschiedene Firmen, die lesen beide die Judy-ID aus, wenn die ihre Daten marken, dann merken sie, dann könnten sie genau rausfinden, alles klar. Der hier und der hier, das sind exakt die gleichen Typen, weil die haben ja die gleiche Judy-ID. Und so kann man halt prima Leute tracken. Und ich glaube, es wird auch ganz doll stark viel bei den Werbedingern benutzt, damit man Leute halt genau weiß, welche Apps sie benutzen und so weiter und so fort.
Genau, das ist um über App-Grenzen hinweg, weil es gibt nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, da ist ja Apple schon relativ hinterher, es gibt nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, Leute über App-Grenzen hinweg eindeutig zu identifizieren. Und das ist natürlich was, worauf die Werbeindustrie total scharf ist, dass du das A, der hat vorhin halt dann auch WhatsApp benutzt, jetzt benutzt er das und das, also er hat erfundene Beispiele, dann habe ich ein besseres Profil und dafür will ich die Person eindeutig identifizieren.
Und brauchte man diese UDI-ID nicht bis vor kurz noch auch für die Push-Notifications?
Na die wären dafür benutzt, du brauchtest sie aber nicht. Ich habe jetzt noch nie was mit Push-Notifications.
Also Push-Notifications, eigentlich musst du da nur dir Zertifikate für deine abgenerieren und die mitbundeln und auf deinem Push-Notification Provider musst du das Gegenstück da mit installieren, damit du mit dem Apple Server reden darfst und dann war es das aber auch eigentlich schon.
Du musst von dem User irgendwas sammeln, da wird irgendwas generiert.
Sie generieren halt Tokens für die Devices.
Das macht Apple aber für dich.
Genau.
In dem Moment, wo ich sage, ich will das hier abonnieren, dann kriegst du irgendwie...
Genau, also in der App sagst du ja bitte, ich hätte gerne Push-Notifications, dann holt sich das Gerät quasi von Apple so ein Device-Token, das schickst du dann deinem Push-Notification-Provider, den du selber hostest, und das reichst du dann Apple weiter. Und dann weiß Apple wiederum, an welches Device sie das schicken müssen. Aber diese Tokens werden wirklich auch erst, die kriegst du erst, wenn du da auf den Schalter drückst. Und die werden noch alle zwei, drei Wochen oder so werden die erneuert.
Du musst auch regelmäßig nachfragen, ob das überhaupt aktuell ist, weil es kann ja sein, dass der User deine App schon längst wieder gelöscht hat. Und du musst auch deine Listen aktuell halten. Das machst du, indem du regelmäßig mal Anfragen an Apple stellst, je nach dem Motto, wie es ist.
Also in dem Prozess kriegt man die Duty ID nicht. Sprich, die einzige Möglichkeit, wie diese Liste eigentlich erstellt werden kann, ist das Apps, die aus dem OS quasi erfragt haben, weil es ja diese Möglichkeit gab, und die dann einfach weggeschickt haben.
Genau, das ist ja auch lange gang und gäbe. Oder sie könnte halt auch direkt von Apple kommen, theoretisch.
Ich frage mich, warum hat Apple überhaupt die UDID angeboten? Also warum war die überhaupt abfragbar? Wofür war das gut?
Also sie steht natürlich da oben noch drin. Wahrscheinlich war einfach nichts dagegen. In iTunes steht sie ja drin. Da hast du ja gerade vor dir, in deinen iTunes. Genau, also um so einen Developer-Account anzulegen.
Dafür war die zum Beispiel da, genau. Und manchmal willst du ja schon wissen, ob dein User irgendwie immer noch der gleiche ist und so weiter und so fort. Aber es muss halt eben nicht die exakt gleiche ID sein, wie was ein anderes Programm benutzt. Also ich wollte es ja nur für mein Programm so eine ID haben. Aber Apple hat halt an alle Programme die gleiche gegeben. Und das war halt ja, bisschen zu viel des Guten eigentlich. Wobei man da auch.
Wie ändert sich das jetzt bei iOS 6?
Es gibt einfach die Abfrage nicht mehr. Ich glaube, der tatsächlich, also bisher gab es da halt einen Befehl für, mit dem du die ID abfragen konntest. Und der ist erstmal deprecated. Ich weiß nicht, ob er dann schon raus ist, aber auf jeden Fall werden sie auch bei der AppStore-Submission einfach testen, ob du den entsprechenden Call aufrufst und wenn du ihn aufrufst, dann ist das halt ein Ablehnungsgrund.
Das heißt, Programme, die schon existieren und die du noch auf deinem Phone hast, die können es halt weiterhin benutzen, aber Apple wird keine neuen mehr zulassen. Genau. Keine Programme, die es noch benutzen, wieder zulassen. Haben die aber auch schon vor, wann war das letzten Herbst, oder so gesagt?
Ja, ja, es ist schon ewig.
Hatten wir hier auch schon mal so. Aber was Hucke jetzt erzählen wollte, das war jetzt erstmal kurz die UDID for Dummies. Was Hucke erzählen wollte, ist, dass hier Lulzac, Antisac, Blutzac irgendwie genau meinten, dass sie von einem Laptop eines FBI-Mitarbeiters irgendwie eine Million...
14 Millionen. Viele.
Inzwischen nochmal neue Daten, glaube ich. Aber sie haben wohl eine Datenbank mit iPhone runtergeladen und davon haben sie aber nur die UDID und ich glaube, den Gerät und Namen veröffentlicht. Die normalen Namen und irgendwelche anderen Daten waren auch noch dabei, aber die haben sie halt vorher weggelassen. Oder von einigen. Doch, man kann das ja runterladen.
Ja, aber sie haben nicht von allen Usern diese Daten gehabt überhaupt. Also von einigen haben sie noch Namen und weitere Daten. So einen OSAFT hätte ich auch gerne noch.
Ich auch einen OSAFT.
Und angeblich auf Hacker News war ja dann gleich am gleichen Tag oder am nächsten Tag hat ja einer dann gleich durchgegrappt nach Gerätennamen und hat dann auch angeblich gleich Obamas iPad gefunden. Und hat das dann mit einer anderen Tracking-Datenbank abgeglichen und hat dann angeblich rausgefunden, dass Obama als letztes irgendein Fishing-Game gespielt hat. Also nicht Fishing mit P, sondern mit F.
Catch the Republican.
Also das ist das halt, was man dann mit tun kann. Wenn du die Idee hast und du weißt jetzt, Tim Petlarfs iPad ist in der Liste drin, dann kannst du dann auch in anderen Datenbanken, die sozusagen diese UDID benutzen, um die Usage-Daten zu sammeln, damit nachgucken.
Hier OpenFind oder wie auch immer die ausgesprochen werden, dieses Gaming-Netzwerk. Die haben offensichtlich auch eine API, wo man per Get-Request eine UDID reinschmeißt und so alles bekommt, was die so über dich wissen. Also so Facebook-ID. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie die mal eben so abstellen können, diese API, und ob sie das schon getan haben. Aber so ist auf jeden Fall eine lustige Sache. Jetzt natürlich die Frage, wo ist das hergekommen? Also es gab zuerst halt die Gerüchte, dass Apple diese Daten dem FBI gegeben hätte. Sowohl Apple als auch das FBI haben dementiert, was im Zweifelsfall sicherlich jetzt nicht das allerbeste Dementi ist, was man irgendwo kriegen kann auf dem Planeten.
Aber noch besseres Dementi gab es vor dem FBI, als die Lulzeg, Anonzeg, was auch immer z.B. Leute gesagt haben, dass sie es vor dem FBI Laptop haben, hat das FBI einen Tag später gesagt, also, ne, das wäre nicht so oder es gibt keine Beweise dafür, dass es so wäre. Das war so die Aussage bei der Pressekonferenz. Also eigentlich nein, aber selbst wenn gäbe es keine Beweise dafür, so nachdem man schon...
Angiez-Eckies-Nee-Typen.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Chance ist auch nicht schlecht, wenn das da so 14 Millionen UDIDs sind, teilweise mit Namensdaten, teilweise ohne, teilweise mit dem und dem, dann könnte das auch wirklich gut sein, dass das einfach so eine Datenbank ist von so einem Werbenetzbetreiber.
Ist wahrscheinlich so.
Die dann halt in irgendeiner App halt noch den Namen abgefragt haben, dann haben sie die Daten halt noch, Geburtsdaten mit dazu, Kreditkarten nochmal, was man halt so braucht.
Ja, dann ist natürlich schön, gleich noch ein bisschen Wind beim FBI zu machen. Macht man sich auf jeden Fall Freunde.
Falls das FBI die überhaupt jemals hatte, diese Daten.
Nee, aber ich sag auch, als Hacker-Gruppierung, dann auch nochmal, also wenn man es von so einem Ed-Netzwerk oder so was hätte, dann zu sagen, ja wir haben es vom FBI übrigens nur noch ein bisschen Wind zu machen, damit die auch so richtig gut gelaunt sind, wenn die das nächste Mal Anti-Sec oder sowas lesen. Das wäre auf jeden Fall ein schlauer Schachzug, könnte man schon mal so sagen.
Das ist, naja.
Mit anderen Worten, man weiß nichts genaues, aber die Bedrohung jetzt, die von dieser Datei ausgeht, ist jetzt auch nicht gerade besonders umfangreich, oder?
Naja, also es gibt halt so Blogposts, ich kann das halt nicht einschätzen, inwieweit das jetzt wirklich stimmt, also angeblich kann man auch Geolocation von dem User und man könnte also auch irgendwie die Apps und was auch immer, was man da nicht alles könnte.
Ja, aber nicht dynamisch, sondern zu dem Zeitpunkt, wann auch immer das gewesen ist, wo sie diese Daten eingesammelt haben.
Tja, das müssen wir mal dem WDR sagen, ne? Was die jetzt sozusagen daraus machen.
Nein, nicht dieses scheiß WDR-Report.
Naja, wieso? Ich mein, die haben doch echt die Schreckung. Die haben schnauzebärtige Security-Leute in Karo-Hemden, die tatsächlich in der Lage sind, vorher gejailbreakte iPhones vor laufender Kamera sich mit SSH einzuloggen.
Und angeblich auch noch am nächsten Tag hat doch der eine gemeint in den Kommentaren, dass auf dem Laptop war der 22. Auf dem iPhone war der 23. andersrum.
Jaja, es ist also so dilettantisch zusammengefakt, dass es einen schon blutet.
Aber wir sagen euch nicht, wo es den zu sehen gibt, weil der war so schlecht, dass wir euch gar nicht damit...
Ach, das weiß doch jeder.
Genau, da müssen wir gar nicht drauf verlinken.
Doch, da verlinken wir trotzdem drauf, weil das gebietet ja sozusagen schon die Transparenz. Es war schon echt unfassbar, was sie sich da zusammen gelogen haben in diesem Bericht.
Vor allen Dingen, ich hab diesen Bericht auch teilweise gesehen, dass direkt dahinter durch Zufall ein Bericht kommt, in dem erwähnt wird, wie wichtig es ist, dass man einen Virenscanner auf seinem Telefon drauf hat. Auf seinem Smartphone hat. Hast du nicht, oder was? Nee, ich hab immer noch keinen. Ich bin ja auch Hacker.
Also ich hab mir ja hier...
Hacker-Angriff, genau so.
Ich kleb mir manchmal den Schnauzband an und zieh mir ein Karo-Hemp an.
Dr. Virus frei installiert auf dem iPhone und das sagt immer, dass alles voll super wäre. Hat auch nur 40 Dollar gekostet.
Und wie teuer ist dir das Monthly-Update für die neuen Virendefinitionsdateien?
Na, ist das ganz billig.
Bei Sicherheit sollte man keine...
Das kostet nur einen Bruchteil. Es sind noch nur 8 Dollar und man kann auch mal einen Monat überspringen, ohne dann im nächsten Monat 16 zu zahlen. Also es ist wirklich billig und die machen wirklich gute Angebote.
Und kann man gleich mit In-App-Purchase sich die neuen Virendefinitionsdateien runterladen?
Klar.
Wer ist das Programm noch gleich?
Doktor Virenfrei.
Vielleicht sollten wir ja sowas haben.
Okay, dann können wir die Sache ja dabei belassen. Wir fühlen uns alle total sicher, denn Steve's Geist schwebt nach wie vor über uns. Allein, wie dem Schneewittchen sagt, entweichende Aura beschützt uns.
Ich fand das ganz geil, der Hausmeister im UDK-Gebäude, weißt du noch, der Typ mit dem Bart, der hat doch irgendwas gemacht, weil er zu dusselig war, hat er einen Brand da in Gang gesetzt und von dort an wurde er nicht mehr Hausmeister oder so genannt, sondern Unsicherheitsbeauftragter stand dann an seinem Türschild. Das fand ich eigentlich sehr schön. Sie haben ihn nicht irgendwie rausgekantet, sondern okay, so pass mal auf, ernstes Wörtchen und jetzt ab zur Strafe hängt da jetzt Unsicherheitsbeauftragter an deiner Tür.
So als Metallschild, also nicht so mit dem Stift, sondern...
Ja, es war schon gedruckt, aber es war so Papier in so einem Plastikhalter.
Ja, ich habe auf jeden Fall Feedback bekommen nach meiner Geschichte von der Campus Party und diesem O2-Info, sozusagen, was die Problematik betrifft, Netz im Zug zu bekommen. Das konnte ich auch heute wieder schön testen, so zwischen Leipzig und Berlin. Da würde man auch gut auf der Strecke gelassen, sozusagen.
Damit sie auch morgen noch auf der Strecke bleiben.
Die Kernaussage war ja im Prinzip die, naja, die Provider sind ja gar nicht schuld, weil die Bahn diese notwendigen Repeater nicht einbaut oder wenn sie sie einbaut, eben erst, wenn mal wieder so ein Sanierungszyklus durch ist, etc. Und das kann ja alles dauern. Außerdem stammen halt viele noch aus der Zeit, wo es Viac Intercom nicht gab und da wären ja da irgendwie diese Frequenzen nicht drin. Jetzt habe ich Rückmeldungen bekommen von einem Vögelchen, die das so ein bisschen aus Bahnperspektive beleuchten. Ja, ich kann da jetzt genauso wenig zu sagen, wie wahr das ist, aber das...
Genauso wenig wie zum Zustand des Apple Stores in Berlin?
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall, sagen wir mal, eine recht detaillierte Schilderung der Umstände, sodass da schon ein gewisser Einblick sicherlich existiert. Es ist natürlich jetzt auch schwer zu beurteilen, inwiefern die da einfach die ganze Zeit nur mit Wattebäuschen hin und her schmeißen und sich gegenseitig der Verpeilung beschuldigen. Aber die Aussagen waren in etwa wie folgt, ICEs 1 und 2 sind spätestens seit ihren Redesigns nicht mehr auf dem Stand von vor 15 Jahren, sondern haben neue Repeater bekommen. Das hat mich jetzt zurückgeworfen.
Erstmal wieder ins Pult ran, Robin.
Ja, also diese Kernaussage, es gäbe noch Repeater, jetzt Viag Intercom nicht kennen.
Der ICE3 hat die neuen gleich schon von Anfang an bekommen.
Jetzt sind sie auf dem Stand von Viag Intercom. Na super.
Wann kriegen sie 3G, wenn LTE da durch ist?
Jetzt lasst mich das doch erstmal erzählen. Die Liste ist ein bisschen länger. Die ICE2 wiederum wurden relativ konsequent erneuert. Wegen dieser ganzen Schneekaos-Geschichte waren die eh alle in den Werkstätten und da haben die dann auch gleich Repeater geschraubt. Aber auch in den letzten Re-Designs wurden keine UMTS-Repeater eingebaut, sondern eben nur GSM, weil sich die vier Netzbetreiber angeblich nicht darauf einigen konnten. Die Bahn hätte das aber gerne gemacht. Einigen heißt so viel wie auch bezahlt, weil die das deren Interesse, also es ist natürlich in beiderseitig Interesse, aber ich glaube der Deal ist schon so, ihr liefert das, weil das ist ja jetzt auch Technik, die muss existieren, spezifiziert sein, gebaut werden, beauftragt werden, etc., Aber offensichtlich konnten sich die Netzbetreiber, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, nicht einigen. Das ist natürlich, jetzt hätte ich fast gerne gesagt, lässt tief blicken, Lalle, lässt es nicht tief blicken, aber es ist beunruhigend, dass man sich auf sowas nicht einigen kann. Ruhewagen haben übrigens keine Repeater, also diese Handyruhezonen, die sind ein sehr schlechter Aufenthalt für jemanden, der Daten haben will, weil man sich da sozusagen nochmal so voll im Feridation-Käfig befindet und die Handys da halt nochmal extra schnell alle werden, weil die dann versuchen, ganz stark zu funken, weil sie ja kaum was empfangen.
Oder es komplett aufgeben, weil sie eh keinen Empfang haben.
Oder weil sie kein Akku mehr haben. Also dann gehen die Telefone schneller leer. Und letztlich bauen sie halt einfach das ein, was die Netzbetreiber eben kaufen. Das ist so die Antwort aus Bahnkreisen, sag ich mal. Und da kann man sich natürlich jetzt fragen, stimmt das? Und wie sehen das die potenziellen Vögelchen in Mobilfunk unternehmen? Das würde mich ja jetzt mal wirklich mal interessieren.
Du meinst, sie könnten ja mal so einen Harnkampf machen.
Ja, also ich meine, wenn es da...
Hundertste Sendung!
Falls irgendjemand was dazu weiß... Falls irgendjemand weiß, was darüber, wer sich da mit wem... Ich weiß nicht, aus welchen Gründen einigen konnte. Ich meine, nicht einigen heißt ja auch, also ich meine, die heißt es, die konnten sich nicht einigen oder man konnte sich nicht einigen. Keine Ahnung, worauf konnten sie sich nicht einigen, auf die Kosten konnten sie sich nicht einigen, auf die Standards, auf die Frequenzen. Ich weiß es nicht. Tatsache ist, dass alles irgendwie blöd. Und wahrscheinlich ist man besser damit bedient, wenn man einfach 3G ausschaltet an seinem iPhone und einfach konsequent nur auf Edge setzt. Also lieber dauerhaft stabil verstärkt repeatetes Edge, was dann mehr oder weniger konstant ist, als ein Telefon, was die ganze Zeit hin und her schaltet, in 3G immer wieder versandet, nichts liefert etc.
War das nicht so, dass man im iOS 5 gar nicht mehr 3G explizit ausschalten konnte?
Das war beim iPhone 4S nicht mehr möglich, ist aber seit dem letzten Update meines Wissens wieder möglich. Da war mal was. Du konntest das beim 4S nicht machen, aber ich glaube, im letzten Software Update, oder einem der letzten, du hast noch ein 4S, da kannst du einmal nachgucken, ob du diese Option noch hast, aber ich glaube, du hast sie.
Wie sieht das denn ab nächster Woche aus? Hoffentlich dann mit, wenn wir dann unser LTE-iPhone haben?
Leicht bewölkt, ne, was?
Ist das dann LTE?
Achso, genau, was ist denn die? Genau, das haben wir vergessen, LTE im iPhone 5. Das haben wir vorhin verschlafen. Glaub ich, also ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Können schon sein, weil das iPad hat es ja auch. Aber wenn wir richtig Pech haben, dann auch wieder in so einer Version, die in Europa irgendwie nicht funktioniert.
Meinst du, das machen sie nochmal?
Ja, kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen, aber ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das kommt. Jetzt kriegen wir dann schön ein LTE, da kriegen wir schön ein LTE-i, dann geht das alles.
Ja, gute Frage. Also ich glaube, die wissen schon noch so ein bisschen, dass sie ohne, wenn sie mit LTE überhaupt rauskommen und dass es in Europa nicht geht, dass das ganz schön scheiße aussehen wird.
Also dieses Lumia 920 jetzt nochmal, hier Apple, das kann fünf LTE-Bänder und natürlich alle Deutschen.
Verstehe.
Also das ist jetzt hier mal die Latte, die es zu reißen gilt.
Also man müsste ja wahrscheinlich mal wirklich auch mal irgendwie einen dicken machen. Das Problem ist halt auch, dadurch dass es irgendwie keine OMTS-Repeater gibt, gibt es natürlich auch gar kein Interesse, an den Zugstrecken OMTS auszubauen. Weil warum sollte man jetzt irgendwo in die Pampa, wo man normalerweise nie und nimmer OMTS hinbauen würde, nach den derzeitigen Investitionsstrategien, weil da halt nur so zwei, drei Dörfer sind, von denen noch kein einziger ein Smartphone besitzt. Warum sollte man da ein OMTS an den Mast hängen, der da direkt an der ICE-Strecke lang geht, wenn in den ICEs sowieso kein OMTS empfangen werden kann? Ja, das ist sozusagen das Problem. Also es ist ein totales Henne-Ei-Problem und vielleicht sollte man da mal passenden Shitstormen los treten.
Vielleicht könnte die Barne auch einfach mal irgendwie ihr Netz mit irgendwas anderem fett ausstatten, dass du dann einen Impfzug WLAN hast und dann machst du hier Facetime-Calls und dann ist gut, scheiße auf dem Netz.
Das machen sie ja auch.
Was kostet der Spaß?
Wobei ich gehört habe, dass es wohl doch auf UMTS-Basis ist, aber nicht...
Schon hat sich ja ein Kommentar gemeldet.
Genau, das sei nicht wie ich vermutet hatte oder mal meinte, gehört zu haben auf Basis von, wie ist das noch gleich? Genau, sondern eben UMTS. Aber insofern eben speziell angepasst, wie man sich das ja auch denken kann, dass die Handovers quasi geo geteckt sind. Das heißt, er weiß ganz genau, wann er ein Handover durchführen muss und probt da nicht so lange rum und deswegen sind die Verbindungen dann eben auch so, ja, smooth. Interessant, dass sie da auch noch genug Performance rauskriegen, um so viele Leute dann mit WLAN zu bedienen. Aber ich habe auch keine Ahnung, wie viel das benutzt wird, wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel. Wenn es funktioniert, ist es geil, finde ich. Also hast du mal in so einem ICE gesessen?
Ach so, also könnte ich mit denen...
Ich meine, das sorgt ja auch für die Bahn. Das hat ja natürlich auch den Vorteil. Du steigst ein, klickst da so ein bisschen. Dann musst du schon aussteigen, weil du schon da bist. Also hast du das Gefühl, es ging aber wieder total schnell. Dann fährst du natürlich viel lieber Bahn, als wenn du irgendwie nach Köln fährst. Irgendwie, ich glaube, wie viel? Vier oder sechs Stunden? Dann irgendwie vier sind es vier, sechs?
Ich glaube auch so für Geschäftskunden und sowas wäre das total praktisch, weil dann könnten die nämlich ihren Mitarbeiter, dann haben die nämlich mal einen echten Vorteil gegenüber Auto oder Flugzeug. Dass sie nämlich auch hier gefälligst noch im Zug weiterarbeiten können.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass das schon verstanden ist. Aber das Problem ist, sie können halt nicht mal ebenso auf Zuruf in so einen ICE einen Repeater einbauen, weil dieser Einbauvorgang komplex ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass da jetzt einer irgendwie mit einer Hilti reinkommt, da irgendwie ein Loch in die Wand tackert und irgendwie mit Kabelbändern irgendwie dieses Teil da festbindet und eine Strippe zieht.
Soll ich euch was sagen?
Genau so ist es.
Der Unterschied ist, dass der Vorhang so eine ganz schicke Verkleidung abmacht und dahinter sieht es aus wie bei Brasil, wenn die da weiß schon.
Apropos Gaffa, ich hab ja mit meinem Kabelbinder, etwas was ich auch bestätigen kann, so aus eigener Erfahrung. Wenn du also im Prinzip diese Repeater-Geschichte ist halt auch in Regionalzügen und so weiter, also es betrifft quasi alle Züge. Aber diese Regionalexpress und Regionalbahn-Dinger haben halt nicht so bedampften Scheiben.
Da kommt noch ein Signal durch.
Da kommt mehr Signal durch. Und das ist auch meine Erfahrung, dass wenn ich mal eine Strecke mit Regionalbahn mache, dass ich dann auf einmal cooles Netz hab, dass ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit so 3G hab.
Da kannst du auch das Fenster aufmachen, oder, zum Not?
Das geht im ICE nicht.
Ja, das hängt, weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau. Aber das musst du dann halt auch noch nicht mal mehr, weil das Ding eben nicht ganz so viel Faraday im Port hat wie...
Das war bei italienischen Zügen total geil. Die hatten überall ein perfektes 3G, weil die sind eh halb auseinandergefallen.
Da der 3G-Schlitz, der 3G-Riss im Gehäuse.
Das war echt, also Fenster waren alle offen, war total warm, gab keine Klimaanlage, hat ein Fenster offen, überall in jedem Tunnel ein perfektes 3G. Ah, ja, ich wollte nochmal über einen Raspberry Pi ein bisschen was erzählen. Ich bin ja da mit meinem ewigen Experiment. Was hat mit Romney, was hat denn der da für ein Tablet?
Erzähl doch erstmal deine Geschichte weiter, Max. Wir lesen uns das mal durch hier und dann gucken wir.
Na gut, und dieses Experiment von mir, da jetzt XBMC drauf zum Laufen zu bringen, das ist nach wie vor nicht total gescheitert. Meine Freundin guckt mich immer schon ganz, weil ich fange dann immer, wenn wir irgendwas gucken, dann mache ich das immer erstmal auf dem Raspberry Pi, mal gucken, ob es läuft und dann nach spätestens zehn Minuten gehen wir dann auf und gucken auf einen klassischen PC, also der noch daneben steht. Das Ganze uns an. Es gibt im Wesentlichen, habe ich jetzt ausprobiert, also RaspBMC heißt das, das ist so eine Distribution, komplette Linux-Distribution, sehr schön gemacht. Man lädt sich so einen Python-Installer runter, den gibt es für Mac und den gibt es für Unix, packt man sich drauf, schiebt man rein in Raspberry Pi und dann startet der erst mal so einen Installer, der so eine Viertelstunde alleine rumrödelt, je nachdem wie schnell die Internetverbindung ist und danach hat man ein komplett bootbares System. Dann habe ich mal OpenELEC hier ausprobiert, das wird ja auch gerade im Chat empfohlen von Zwergnase. Habe ich nicht ganz so gute Erfahrungen mitgemacht, das hat irgendwie bei mir ein bisschen stärker gehakelt. Was mit Abstand am schnellsten war, war XBian, also so XB und dann wie Debian hintendran. Ich gucke jetzt mal xban.org, ist die Domain. Das lebt man sich runter, muss ein klassisches Image draufpacken, bootet Affen schnell, also es wirklich irgendwie die anderen brauchen so, ich weiß nicht, 120, 130 zum booten. Hier ein Follower hat das auch gestoppt. Das ist irgendwie so bei 25 Sekunden oder so was, also deutlich schneller als der ganze Rest. Hat auch so das Gefühl, dass so das ganze Interface deutlich schneller ist als bei den anderen. Was mich leider wieder davon abgebracht hat, ist, dass das ist irgendein Typ, der das zusammen hackt und der hat viel Ahnung, aber noch nicht genug Ahnung. Also es ist zum Beispiel so, dass ich habe da so eine 8-Gigabyte-Karte genommen und dann hat er halt eine 1-Gigabyte-Partition drauf und dann ist die halt so groß. Dann sind halt die anderen 7 Gigabyte von deiner SD-Karte flöten und das ist schon verdammt knapp. Sodass ich jetzt wieder bei hier RustBMC gelandet bin. Was ich mir da jetzt noch drauf gepackt habe, ist, weil ich habe ja diese kleine Squeeze-Box stehen in meiner Küche, habe ich ja schon mal von erzählt, dieses kleine rote Radio. Und da gibt es eine Software namens SqueezeSlave für, das ist so ein Squeeze-Box-Client. Und damit kann ich jetzt, dann habe ich mir hier von, Mist, jetzt habe ich so einen Namen vergessen, die Software iPang gekauft. Beziehungsweise, ich habe mir eine Version zuschicken lassen, die andere habe ich mir selber gekauft. Weil das ist schon relativ teuer. Das ist so ein Squeeze-Box-Steuerungsgerät. Also das ist eine Fernbedienung für die Squeeze-Box. Und was das Geile ist, dieses Squeeze-Slave macht zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi oder auch einen anderen PC, den man so hat, zu einem vollwertigen Squeeze-Box-Client. Der hängt jetzt so mit einer Anlage dran. Dann kann ich schön über das iPang sagen, welche Musik von meinem Server darauf gestreamt wird, kann Internetradio hören darüber. Was ich leider noch nicht zum Laufen gekriegt habe, ist hier, wie heißen sie gleich? Wie heißt jetzt dieser Hip-Bit-Dienst, der Musik streamt? Spotify. Spotify läuft auf der Squeezebox selbst. Super, auf diesem Squeeze-Slave aus irgendeinem Grund nicht. Aber was ein grandioses Feature ist, man kann diese Squeeze-Boxen synchronisieren. Also man kann sagen, hier, ich schalte eine beliebige Anzahl von Squeeze-Boxen und Squeeze-Slaves, und weiß ja toll, was, zu einem großen Lautsprecher zusammen. Und ihr spielt ab sofort dasselbe, und dann synchronisieren die sich untereinander. Und dann gibt es dann ein Interface für, und dann schaltet man die Dinger zusammen und plötzlich...
die synchronisieren sich untereinander.
Die messen ihre Netzwerkslazenzen irgendwie aus. Also man kann noch einstellen, wenn die Digital auf Analog-Hardware ein bisschen langsamer ist, kann man da eine etwas höhere Latenz angeben oder sowas. Aber ansonsten müssen sie da irgendeinen wunderbaren Mechanismus haben, dass die irgendwie einen Ping in die Einrichtung schicken und dann wieder zurück zum Server und dann so ausmessen, wie die Latenzen sind. Und du hörst, also fängst an, irgendwie Musik zu hören, und am Anfang ist es noch relativ unterschiedlich. Also hast du einen versatzendeutlichen. Und dann gleichen die sich während des Hörnens immer weiter an. Und irgendwann innerhalb von so 10, 15 Sekunden hab ich zumindest keinen Unterschied mehr rausgehört. Und dann kann ich quasi, also wenn ich dann am Küchenradio einen Sender einstelle oder andere Musik auswähle, was relativ komfortabel geht, weil das halt ein Display hat, und diese Steuerungsrädchen, dann spielt im Wohnzimmer automatisch exakt die gleiche Musik. Und wenn ich das mag, kann ich das mit dieser leider etwas hässlichen, aber sehr funktionalen Software namens iPang, eben, das gibt's das noch als iPhone-Steuerung, kann ich jetzt von hier aus die Katzen ein bisschen ärgern, indem ich im Wohnzimmer anfange Musik zu spielen. Es ist alles sehr, sehr selbst gebastelt, aber ist schon sehr, sehr cool. Achso, und man kann hier für ein bisschen Geld, kann man auch noch sein iPhone oder iPad auch noch zu so einer Box aufstrauben, zu so einer Squeezebox-Box. Das heißt, wenn man da, man kann irgendwie mehrere iPhones an irgendwelche Lautsprecher in einer Wohnung anschließen und iPads und kann die dann zu einer großen, zu einer großen Soundanlage zusammenschalten. Ist echt krass, was da geht. Und die haben da wirklich unglaublich viel Arbeit reingesteckt. Was der Nachteil ist, dass jetzt auf der IFA Logitech den Nachfolger der Squeezebox quasi angekündigt ist, was nichts weiter ist als die bisherige Squeezebox mit einem nicht mehr polierten, sondern glatten Gehäuse und einer neuen Software drauf, die offensichtlich komplett inkompatibel ist zu dem, was es bisher gab. Keine Ahnung, was sie da geritten hat, aber ja. Aber ja, dieses Squeeze Slave kann ich sehr empfehlen. Macht Spaß. Keine Ahnung, was man damit macht, aber. Ich kann Musik in allen Zimmern hören und zwar überall die gleich. Und ich stelle das einmal ein.
Ja, noch ein kleiner Programm-Tipp. Habe ich vorhin vergessen. Es gibt auf dem Mac so ein cooles Programm, auch von so einem Einzel-Developer, vor zwei mal rausgebracht, das Capo heißt. Was so zum Instrumenten-Lernen immer ganz hilfreich ist, weil man kann halt bestehende Musikstücke reinschmeißen und die ohne den Pitch zu verändern, verlangsamen und verschnellen. Man sieht das Spektrum auch sehr schön aufgeschlüsselt und kann irgendwie in das Spektrum reinklicken und er sagt einem, welche Noten das sind. Und man kann auch während der Song abspielt auf eine Taste drücken und er sagt einem, was zu diesem Zeitpunkt quasi die dominierende Note ist. Das heißt, man kann richtig cool Songs-reverse-enginieren. Und gerade wenn man ein Solo spielen will, ist das halt super cool. Du verlangsamst den, der Pitch bleibt dir gleich, also die Tonhöhe ändert sich nicht. Und dann kannst du eben noch gucken, ich kann das hier mal parallel aufmachen, dann siehst du, wie das aussieht. Und jetzt hat mir vorhin einer im Chat, als ich von der Gitarre erzählte, gesagt, dass es das jetzt auch fürs iPhone gibt und fürs iPad. Und ich hab hier auch die URL noch irgendwo offen, dann können wir das hier auch gleich nochmal reintun. Und wo ich eben, ach Mist, jetzt hab ich es hier verpastet nochmal, wo ich vorhin halt erzählte, dass so iPad eigentlich so für Musikkontext ganz praktisch ist, so als kleiner Begleiter, da ist dann eben Carpo auf jeden Fall auch ein cooles Tool. Also gerade so wie gesagt, zum Musikstücke Reverse-Enginieren und Lernen und sozusagen Mitspielen, super geil. Ja, wenn ihr also auch bei Mobile Macs rausfinden wollt, welche Tonlage aktuell wäre, während ich gerade spreche, die dominierende ist, dann probiert doch Carpo aus. Auf dem Mac ist es glaube ich relativ, also es ist nicht gerade günstig, es ist nicht so eine 1 Dollar App, kostet auf dem Mac glaube ich 39 Dollar und auf dem iPhone 20. Also wie gesagt, es ist auch ein Typ und er strickt halt auch schon seit ein, zwei Jahren da dran. Am Anfang hat er wirklich nur dieses Verlangsamen drin gehabt und das Spektrum und mittlerweile hat er immer neue, coole Features eingebaut und das ist wirklich eine sau coole App einfach. Also wirklich voll die Nische, letztendlich auch, aber so in der Kategorie Software gibt es irgendwie nichts anderes und die ist einfach echt praktisch.
Ja, ich hab auch noch so ein bisschen Abkram, den man mal melden sollte. Unter anderem, also wo ich immer noch nicht so richtig glücklich bin, aber wo es zumindest schon mal so die erste Abgibt, die halbwegs dieses Problem angeht, auch wenn ich so mit der Zusammenstellung noch nicht so ganz glücklich bin, ist das Problem, was für Cocktails, also ein First World Problem, was für Cocktails kann ich mit dem aktuellen Bestand in meiner Bar mixen? Ja, also es gibt ja massenhaft so Nachschlage-Ups, die sagen, wie mixe ich einen Bloody Mary und wie mach ich das und wie mach ich das? Und du stellst dann eigentlich fest, du müsstest jetzt nochmal zum Supermarkt oder, was weiß ich, in irgendeinen Spezi-Laden, um einfach nochmal so eine völlig absurde Zutat, die es in deinem Supermarkt gar nicht gibt, Es gibt noch zu erwerben und viel sinnvoller ist es ja einfach zu sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt hier noch einen Vodka rumstehen und ich hab irgendwie Lime Juice und ich hab das, das, das, das, das.
Ich hab noch einen Rum und noch eine Cola. Was könnte man damit anstellen?
Also bei mir weiß ich nicht mal, was ich mixen kann.
Bier.
Ja gut, aber ich hab immer so eine Partialmischung von Zeug, was alles noch so übrig geblieben ist, von Partys oder was nicht so richtig weggegangen ist. Du hast halt noch irgendwie einen Kahlua und so und dann willst du halt auch immer wieder was Neues ausprobieren, aber du weißt halt zum Verrecken nicht, was jetzt passen würde. Und da gibt es diese kleine App, die heißt Cocktail Flow. Die ist wie gesagt nicht besonders toll, aber die kann zumindest sowas schon mal so in etwa, falls aber da jemand noch einen Tipp hat.
Na geil wäre ja wohl, wenn du mit deiner Kamera gleich die Bar kurzst deiner Flaschen einfach so, tschack tschack tschack tschack tschack und dann musst du gar nicht tippen oder suchen oder sonst was.
Aber dann hast du ja alle möglichen Wodka-Sorten, das ist ja egal.
Na Wodka ist nicht gleich Wodka, ne?
Richtig gutes Barzubehör hat gar kein Barcode. Willst du jetzt deine Limetten irgendwie auch noch scannen oder was?
Ja.
Ja okay, vielleicht geht das noch.
Fotografieren.
Wer so ein bisschen eine Bar hat, der weiß halt, was er hat und kann das irgendwie auch grob klassifizieren.
Nur Mut, dem einfach zusammenzuschütten wird.
Ja, Bandausen.
Also mit so einer Limette.
Ja, was meinst du, wenn die Cocktails entstanden sind? Irgendwelche betrugene Typ hinter der Bar, irgendwas zusammengeschüttet und der Kunde hat gesagt, der ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Kann das seit Jahren. Ah, die kostet wenigstens was.
Na dann kann es ja schon mal die halbe Miete.
Ich hoffe, die nichts kostet, die kann auch nichts taugen.
Na ja, die UI sieht schon mal jetzt auch nicht so aus, als hätte das Geld wirklich was gebracht.
Die haben ja Geld halt in Alkohol investiert und nicht so an zu sein.
Aber seh ich das richtig, dass man hier sozusagen bei jedem Ingredient sagen kann. Na ja, okay, man kann die sich so einzeln zusammenstellen. Ja, weiß ich nicht, ist das wirklich genau das?
Du sollst es wirklich waren, 99 Cent auszugeben, um es auszuprobieren.
Ja, hier kann ich jetzt verschiedene Sachen machen und dann sagt er mir, was man daraus machen kann. Also Zimmeliebnis ist zwar, um es auf das Geld auszugeben, aber nicht alles. Ich hab keine Podcast-Kultur manchmal.
Aber du murmelst hier gerade so in dein Rechner rein. Ja, so kann man hier irgendwie so ein paar Naja, einzelne Zutaten oder so. Das ist halt irgendwie das Band einfach nicht voll ausgenutzt.
Und du sagst immer, wir sollen nicht zeigen, was die Hörer nicht sehen kann. Und ich meine, du sagst ja nicht, dass es so was zu sehen gibt, aber du guckst auf dein Film.
Jetzt kriegst du die volle Retour-Content.
Fuck me harder.
Naja, vielleicht Mixologist, keine Ahnung. Weitere Tipps gerne gesehen in den Show Notes. Ich probier das gerne mal aus. Ich bin mir jetzt hier gerade beim Anschauen der Screenshots nicht ganz so sicher, ob das das ist, was ich meine. Also man kann zwar hier bestimmte Sachen zusammenklicken und kriegt dann Vorschläge, aber ich will halt sozusagen explizit meinen Bestand pflegen und sagen, okay, das ist jetzt alle. Und dann geht's raus und man muss das halt immer speichern und nicht nur so eine temporäre Zusammenstellung für einen Vorgang. Ja, dann eine zweite Sache, die ich noch ganz putzig fand, so aus der Abteilung kann man vielleicht irgendwann mal gebrauchen und funktioniert dann zumindest gut. Es gibt eine Software, die heißt, jetzt hab ich es schon wieder verlegt, aber ich glaube, es war ganz straight forward, genau, Webkamera fürs iPhone und die macht halt zusammen mit einer Software auf dem Mac aus deinem iPhone eine Webkamera. Das heißt, wenn du die abstattest und die mit deinem Mac verbindest, dann hast du auf dem Mac so ein richtiges Kameradevice, so wie die eingebaute Kamera in deinem Monitor oder irgendeine beliebige andere USB-Kamera, aber es ist dann halt über WLAN in dem Moment dein iPhone. Du kannst ja sozusagen so mit dem iPhone durch die Gegend laufen und das so als Fernkamera benutzen, aber eben als Input für eine Software, die auf dem Mac läuft.
Gibt es von gleichen Hersteller auch als Mikrofon? Ist vielleicht ganz praktisch, wenn man so ein Skype-Telefonat machen will und dabei schön durch die Wohnung laufen will.
Ja, wie heißt das dann?
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich dann, wie heißt das so?
Shape Services heißt nämlich die Bude.
Guck doch mal, ob die noch eine zweite Software einfach da haben.
Ja, ich bin gerade am Kieken. Muss erstmal der iTunes hier erstmal mitkommen.
Kiekst du denn nur?
Gibt es auch in einer PC-Variante, wenn man nämlich im Büro ist und da natürlich man selbstverständlich, also was braucht man ja in einer Arbeitsumgebung nicht, also wenn man so ein Windows-PC hat im Büro, wie ich es früher hatte, dann kann man sich diese PC-Software einfach noch installieren, dann kann man den PC zu einem mikrofonentauglichen Rechner umbauen, kann doch mal ein Skype-Telefonat mitfügen.
Habe einfach ein wireless Headset. Schön einfach.
Funktioniert auch erstaunlich robust.
Ist das dann dieselbe Software, die ich schon für die Kamera installiert habe und die geht dann auch mit dem...
Ich weiß es nicht mehr...
.Dings oder ist es noch mal was?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ah, das ist sogar aus Deutschland, sehe ich gerade.
Ich kann hier noch mal kurz was für die Entwickler unter uns, für die iOS-Entwickler was empfehlen. Ist letzte Woche oder diese Woche ein bisschen rumgegangen und zwar Pony-Debugger. Genau, das ist Tim's Stichwort gewesen. Das ist eine Bibliothek, installiert man sich in seiner iPhone-App und kann daraufhin mit dem... also es gibt noch die kleinen für den Mac oder wahrscheinlich auch für den PC. Was der macht, ist er zeigt einem in der Chrome- oder Safari-Konsole, es gibt ja so diesen Inspector in Safari, zeigt er einem den Network-Traffic, den die App auf dem iPhone verursacht an. Total geil, also man schmeißt ihn da rein und sieht jede Verbindung. Außerdem kann er einem noch die Core-Data-Daten anzeigen. Alles live, über die Luft, über WLAN, funktioniert ganz hervorragend.
Bevor man es ausliefert, macht man es aus, ja?
Bevor man es ausliefert, sollte man es sowieso nur in der Debug-Konfiguration oder sowieso nur im Simulator laufen lassen, kann man ja alles machen, ist ja überhaupt gar kein Problem, aber davon haben wir ja schon genug. Da gibt es auch noch aus der selben Kategorie DC-Introspect, das hatte ich hier schon mal, das ist total geiles Werkzeug, um so Views zu inspecten, also damit kann man dann, man drückt nämlich dann im Simulator die Leertaste und daraufhin kann man innerhalb seiner App jedes beliebige Element anklicken und kriegt dann alle Daten raus, also siehst du den View und kriegst dann alle Parameter dieses Views raus, kriegst welche Klasse das ist, Koordinaten, kannst den Perkursor-Tasten verschieben, um so viele Pixel wie den du gerade brauchst, also gerade wenn man irgendwie so pixelgenaues Design machen muss oder sowas, erspart einem das eine ganze Menge Arbeit. Installieren kann man das Ganze. Ich möchte mittlerweile nicht mehr ohne Leben, ohne CocoaPods, jetzt auch nicht mehr das Allerneueste. Ich weiß nicht ob du das, Dennis hast du das mal genutzt? Installiert man sich Gem-Install-CocoaPods, ist von hier so ein bisschen an dieses Gem-Ding angelehnt. Man legt sich in sein Projekt ein Pot-File und schreibt da rein, welche CocoaPods man gerne hätte und dann sagt man danach Pot-Install und er erstellt einem automatischen Xcode-Workspace mit allen Einstellungen Stimmen und alles stimmt. Man braucht diese Bibliothek. Also wirklich in meisten Fällen braucht man Xcode nicht mal zuzumachen, sondern man sagt einfach Pot-Install und danach hat man 20 Sekunden später diese Bibliothek installiert und was fast noch viel besser ist, wenn man sie wieder loswerden will, restlos, dann nimmt man die Zeile, die entsprechende wieder aus seinem Pot-File raus, ruft nochmal Pot-Install auf und sie ist wieder weg. Ist so für jetzt hier zum Beispiel Pony-Debugger oder für Test-Flight oder für DC-Introspect oder für AF-Networking oder jede beliebige andere Bibliothek ganz, ganz großartig. Wenn es da irgendwas noch nicht gibt, kann man sich auch relativ leicht private Pot-Specs anlegen, die man nur selber hat. Ist wirklich, also wenn ihr iOS-Entwicklungen macht und ihr öfters mal darüber flucht, wie man Bibliotheken einbindet und dergleichen mehr von irgendwelchen Third-Party-Anbietern, guckt euch das auf jeden Fall mal an.
Ich hab auch noch eine schöne iOS-App. Weiß nicht, ob wir die schon mal besprochen haben. 360-Grad-Panorama. Kennt ihr die?
Irgendeine Panoramasoftware hab ich mir gekauft und hab sie jetzt schon wieder vergessen.
Die ist auf jeden Fall echt ganz cool. Also damit kannst du halt einmal so die Kamera rundrum im Raum drehen und er erstellt dir ein Panorama. Und das Coole ist, du kannst dann dein Accelerometer einschalten und kannst sozusagen zu Hause dich dann hinsetzen und rumdrehen und siehst dann quasi, kannst sozusagen mit dem Telefon dann das Panorama betrachten. Das ist ganz geil. Ich hab das gerade von der Metaebene gemacht, aber ich werde es nicht scheren, weil Tim das ja nicht mag. Ja, Tim ist schuld. Wenn ihr mal ein Panorama von 360 Grad Panorama haben wollt, müsst ihr Tim bezürzen. Aber ich schick euch mal den Link in den Chat und dann damit hoffentlich auch in die Show Notes zu diesem 360 Grad Panorama App, weil die ist echt ganz cool, um auch Freunde schöne lebendige Urlaubsfotos...
Schöne lebendige Urlaubsfotos.
Was ich ja gerade mache, ich mache schon seit ganz langer Zeit keine iOS Apps mehr, sondern ich mache für so ein Studio nach Schweiz Drehteller-Programmierung, wo halt die Rundumbilder schießen, indem sich der Drehteller dreht, die Kamera macht ein Bild, ein bisschen weiter drehen, wieder ein Bild und dann macht man fürs Internet so eine Rundumansicht. Wenn man jetzt aber einen Model hat, was auf dem Tisch steht oder wo auch immer, und man will von dem Model eine Rundumansicht, dann ist es natürlich schlecht, das Model immer ein Stück drehen zu lassen und ein neues Bild zu machen, weil es kann nicht so lange stehen. Und wenn die Haare so in der Luft schweben sollen oder die Klamotten, dann kann man halt nicht nacheinander diese 16 oder 24 oder 36 Fotos schießen. Deswegen haben die eine Plattform, wo halt 18 Kameras sind, die alle gleichzeitig ausschießen. Und da programmiere ich gerade, dass mit so einer Canon-Software 18 Kameras gleichzeitig auslösen. Und das ist das, was ich gerade mache, weil ihr gerade so viel von Panorama und so weiter erzählt. Ich mache nicht Panorama nach außen, sondern das gleiche sozusagen nach innen, aber so Matrix-Style, wo alle Kameras gleichzeitig folgen.
Genau, das hätte ich gerne bei diesem 360-Grad-Panorama. Das wäre nicht jetzt so ein Tim-Wackel mit dem Telefon, dass ich dann quasi so einen drehbaren Avatar plötzlich hätte. Eigentlich, das ist ein Feature fürs iPhone, statt also nicht nur eine Kamera, sondern so ein Kinect-Ding, was halt auch so quasi den ganzen Raum dreidimensional erfassen kann und so die Gegebenheiten. Dann hast du halt nicht nur ein 2D-Bild, sondern halt auch noch ein 3D-Model dazu, worauf du das Bild mappen kannst. Hast du mit dieser Kinect schon mal, also hast du schon mal gesehen? Die haben ja bei der Raumfahrtagentur so eine Kinect und haben das an ihren 3D-Printern, an ihren Makerbot quasi angeschlossen. Das heißt, du kannst da so einen Nerd vor diese Kinect stellen und dann kommt da so der Nerd 3D-geprintet raus sozusagen.
Das müsste man ein Rekursiv machen, dann müsste man den 3D-geprinteten...
Dieses Gummi-Zeug hier ist so fruchtig, dass da eine Fruchtfliege drin ist.
Na ja, mögen die nicht sowieso Zucker? Aber dann könnte man auch so einen 3D-ausgedruckten Nerd, dann kann man den wieder davor stellen und kann man ein Rekursiv drucken, solange bis die Bildqualität total schlecht ist und man nur noch ein Flatschee hat.
Und schmeckt die auch fruchtig?
Ich hab reingepustet und es ist mehr Zucker entgegengekommen.
Was soll ich?
Ich dachte die Fliege.
Klebt in deinem Bart. Also 3D-Kamera wäre doch eigentlich ein geiles Feature.
Irgendjemand hat schon so einen Ball gebaut, den ich total geil finde und zwar, die Idee ist so grandios, das ist einfach ein Ball, der hat diverse Handykameras, die alle in jede Richtung des Balls ausgerichtet sind. Dann schmeißt du diesen Ball nach oben und wenn er merkt, dass er an der höchsten Stelle ist, dann lösen alle Kameras gleichzeitig auch ein Panorama. Dann fällt der Ball wieder runter und du hast einen Ball mit einer Panorama-Aufnahme in alle Himmelsrichtungen.
960 Grad.
Naja, nicht nur rundum, sondern auch oben und unten, wirklich alle Richtungen. Finde ich total geil.
Ball. Und der höchsten Punkt dann automatisch auflöst, wenn die Beschleunigung null ist.
Wenn die Beschleunigung null ist, löst er aus. Dann lässt er mir runterfallen, dann hast du das Foto.
Und wie ist das Ding so geschützt?
Es ist ein bisschen Gummi. Ich meine, so Kameras, ich glaube so Handy-Kameras, die sind relativ robust. Und dann ist da halt noch so ein bisschen Gummi drum herum an den Stellen, wo keine Kamera ist. Mal gucken, hat bestimmt irgendjemand auch im Chat so einen Link. So ein grünes Teil. Das ist aber eine coole Idee. Die ist total geil. Er hat sich die Idee patentieren lassen, glaube ich, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, und will das jetzt so richtig produzieren lassen. Und dann mal eben so irgendwo auf den Platz stellen, nach oben schmeißen, ein paar Mal machen.
Und der macht genau dann das Foto, wenn es nicht wackelt. Wie geil! Das ist eine geile Idee.
Aber er kann sich ja immer noch so drehen.
Das kann er ja auch messen.
Er hat in alle Richtungen, nee, du machst einfach eine Kamera, in alle Richtungen hat er eine Kamera.
Der Bockel meint, dass die das selbst wenn am höchsten Punkt ist ja immer noch eine Rotation haben kann.
Die zur Verwischung des Bildmaterials ist.
Wenn die alle im Bild schießen, ist egal, ob der bei sich dreht oder nicht.
Wenn sie es schnell genug tun, ja.
Und du hast natürlich bei so weiten Distanzen nicht so das Verwacklungsproblem, weil so ein bisschen Drehung, na gut, hängt davon ab, wie schnell er sich dreht.
Also der hat hier so ein paar Bilder, die er damit gemacht hat. Kann man sich so angucken. Also es ist so ein Video. Genau, hier ist diese Wurfkamera bei Golem, ist gerade der Link.
Die Throwable Panoramic Ballkamera, wie geil.
Ist im Augenblick irgendwie noch Fußball groß, soll wohl noch Tennisball groß werden.
Da sind andere Projekte fürchtig. Ich glaube du willst auf Play beim Video klicken.
Wenn ich das?
Du willst da drauf klicken.
Ich darf das Siegkraft präsentieren.
Jetzt langweilen sich unsere Hörer schon wieder.
Unsere Hörer langweilen sich nie. Wir haben die besten Hörer. Die langweilen sich noch nicht mal, wenn wir die ganze Zeit dummes Zeug erzählen.
Max, sollen Sie zu wenig streiten, denn es sollen nicht so viel ZFS erzählen.
Nein, die sagen immer ZFS.
Tja, wir haben euch noch gar nicht alles erzählt.
Das dicke Ende kommt noch. Die hunderte Sendung wird sich ausschließlich um ZFS drehen.
Da bin ich krank.
Also wenn ich mir das Panorama so angucke, da sind da noch ganz schöne...
Das ist ja nur ein Prototyp, das wird noch besser.
Ja, aber das ist sozusagen noch nicht wirklich ein richtig...
Ich würde mal sagen, das ist das, womit sie 2016 die WM machen.
Ich finde, da sieht man auch deutlich, dass die Kameras offensichtlich unterschiedlich auslösen.
Ja, unterschiedlichen Abgleich haben da.
Genau, so Weißabgleich und sowas.
Das ist ja auch nicht so einfach, weil wenn du in die Einrichtung guckst, dann trifft das nicht direkt und dann kriegst du ein bisschen Direktes ab.
Die müssen einfach mit einer konstanten Belichtung arbeiten.
Das muss die Software machen. Ich nehme an, wenn man so was in Massenproduktion bauen will, dann kriegt man wahrscheinlich nicht die Kameras so hundertprozentig genau gegeneinander justiert, sodass die Software sowieso ausgleichen muss. So richtig trivial ist das bestimmt nicht, aber finde ich eine schöne Idee auf jeden Fall.
Wir sind durch.
Sind wir?
Ja, wir müssen es jetzt auch nicht übertreiben. Wenn wir müde sind, müssen wir auch weiterfahren.
Wir sollten nochmal den Link hier reinspeisen, obwohl er schon mal hier drin war.
Hier haben wir genug erzählt. Außerdem bin ich gespannt, wie hier die Show Notes-Experimente voranschreiten. Das soll alles noch viel toller werden mit den Show Notes.
Noch viel toller? Aber die sind doch schon so toll.
Die sind schon ganz schön toll, aber von dem theoretisch möglichen super tollen Zustand, in dem Podcasts generell versetzt werden sollen, da ist noch ein Stück Weg zu gehen.
Übrigens noch mal ein kleiner Hinweis. Morgen ist wieder erster Donnerstag im Monat. Da ist im Room 77 an der Grefelstraße 77 das Bitcoin-Treffen ab, ich schätze, um 19 Uhr Berlin. Klar, Berlin wohnt sonst.
Ja, und was passiert da?
Da ist man Bürger und kann mit Bitcoins zahlen und kann ein bisschen über Bitcoins quatschen. Da gibt es auch Ticker, die irgendwie mit Bitcoins verkaufen oder kaufen und alles sowas.
Ticker.
Dealer halt.
Bitcoin-Dealer.
Muss man sich halt mal so rumfragen und so.
Dass sie nicht von Bullen erwischen.
Wenn das der Spitzei erfährt. Jetzt dealen die ja hier hinterher auch schon mit Bitcoins.
Das ist ja auch ganz offiziell. Wie gesagt, der Besitzer verkauft sein altes Bratfett irgendwie und kriegt Bitcoins dafür. Ganz offiziell.
Kann mir jemand das Chat-Log zukommen lassen bitte? Weil ich hab jetzt gerade gesehen, dass man das...
Ach, das Chat-Log, ja. Oh ja, wir müssen auch noch die Chat-Logs der letzten Sendung einsammeln. Das hab ich auch ganz vergessen. Okay. Keine weiteren Ideen mehr. Die Crickets sind schon unterwegs.
Sind schon startklar.
Genau. Seht es uns nach. Wir machen heute mal ein bisschen früher Schluss.
Oder?
Und in zwei Wochen sind wir wieder da. Und dann überprüfen wir mal, wie unsere wargemutigen Zukunftsaussichten Start, also Star Trek Computer im iPhone war ja wohl wargemutig.
Das war wargemutig.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Also ich hab mich da wohl am weitesten aus dem Fenster gelehnt. Und hier 3D-Kamera, ja. Wohlgemerkt.
Will mal irgendjemand aufschreiben, was da alles kam?
Was wolltest du nochmal?
NFC.
Und er wollte noch irgendwas haben.
Was denn jetzt mit LTE? Eigentlich hattest du iPhone 5 LTE oder nicht?
Hattest.
Auch für Europa?
Vielleicht nicht für Australien.
Aber mal ehrlich, wir könnten auch noch nicht mal was hier in der Stadt damit anfangen, richtig? Gibt's noch mal gar nicht. Doch.
Gibt's das in Berlin schon?
Das hat doch nur in so Teststädten wie Quattrop, Rauchsel oder so ein Scheiß.
Mal, dieses Jahr geht's halt los. Also, morgens in Latzig, da war auch jemand, der Internet über LTE rein geholt hat und so. Also, das findet jetzt schon langsam statt. Mobiles DSL.
Berlin hat die schlechteste LTE-Abdeckung.
Na ja, und bevor nicht...
Ja, weil wir wahrscheinlich auch die beste 3G-Abdeckung haben, oder?
Ja gut, aber der Rollout, der geht jetzt los. Also, sie sind alle in den Startlöchern und im Prinzip bedarf es jetzt nur auf das iPhone.
Das iPhone müssen wir auch mal loslegen, ne?
Ja, gut, aber das dauert ja dann trotzdem noch wieder ewig.
Naja, aber gibt es keinen Grund, jetzt LTE da nicht einzubauen, wo sie schon ihren iPad eingebaut haben. Ja, also von daher...
Das wird dann wahrscheinlich die große...
Ja, das könnte in der Tat dann funktionieren, wenn man damit besser Netz im Zug kriegt, aber das bezweifle ich mal.
Oder Zug im Netz kriegt. Man kann auch Zug im Zug kriegen.
Oh man, Buckel ist durch.
Der Rausschmeißer bin ich.
Genau, Rausschmeißer, apropos Rausschmeißer. Rausschmeißer...
Hier kommt die Sonne.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Inke-Winke.
Tschüss, tschüss.
Danke, dass Sie hier sind und wir sehen uns bald.